BECAUSE OUR MISTER JONES SAWYER
IS HERE.
AND WE PROMISE TO LET HIM GO
FIRST.
YES HE ALWAYS GET SPECIAL
TREATMENT [inaudible]
AND YOU PROBABLY WOULD TOO IF
YOU WERE IN HIS.
WILL WE WILL WILL LEAVE THAT
ALONE.
ALL RIGHT SO WE ARE -- STARTING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE WAS WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET.
BUT WE WILL ALLOW -- YOU TO
START -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE.
THANK YOU YOU WILL GO TO ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB FIFTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR AND THEN LATER I WILL
ANNOUNCE.
THE OTHER ITEMS AROUND ABOUT OUR
AGENDA SO GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR THE
ASSEMBLY FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK FIRST.
OUR AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
CLARIFIES CHANGES TO THE YOUTH
REINVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WE AS AS LEGISLATURE FUNDED IN
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTY THREE
POINT THREE MILLION.
VIEWS REINVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM
IS CURRENTLY MINISTERED BY THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS WHO DISTRIBUTES
GRANTS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND INDIAN TRIBES. TO IMPLEMENT
TRAUMA INFORMED DIVERSION
PROGRAM FOR MINORS.
DURING HIS FIRST YEAR OF
APPLICATIONS MY OFFICE SOLICITED
FEEDBACK AND FOUND THAT
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY WAS NEEDED
FOR JURISDICTIONS WHERE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAS LEFT HAVE LESS
CAPACITY TO APPLY FOR FUNDS AND
TO INCENTIVIZE ADDITIONAL
PARTICIPATION.
WORST CASE IS A GRANT PROGRAM TO
CREATES WINNERS AND LOSERS ALL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE I PROMISE YOU
IN NEED OF CONNECTION TO
SERVICES.
THIS BILL HELPS ADDRESS THAT.
THIS BILL INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL FIT BECAUSE WHICH
MAKES IT EASIER FOR
JURISDICTIONS AND NONPROFIT
ENTITIES TO APPLY FOR GRANTS
INSURERS THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
USED FOR SUCCESSFUL DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. FOR EXAMPLE THIS BILL
ALLOWS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS DO YOU THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
TWO TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT MAKING SURE WE CAN IN THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE MAKE
SURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE PUT IN
THE HANDS OF PEOPLE DOING THE
HARD WORK OF DISMANTLING THAT
PIPELINE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY IS DAPHNA.
CAN.
BECAUSE ON WHOA WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH AND
LAW.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
DESIGNING I AM A POLICY ATTORNEY
AT THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW.
I'M HERE TO EXPLAIN SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO THE U. THREE INVESTMENT GRANT
WITH THE GOAL OF ENSURING THAT
THE INTENT OF THE LAW.
IS PROPERLY IMPLEMENTED.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE THE PRODUCT
OF A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WITH
THE A CC WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND ALSO WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHO PROVIDED US WITH
VALUABLE FEEDBACK AFTER THE
FIRST ROUND OF APPLICATIONS THE
THREE BEST A GREAT.
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THREE THEMES CAME
ACROSS.
FIRST BECAUSE THE INITIAL ROUND
OF GRANT FUNDING ONLY ALLOWED A
CITY OR COUNTY TO SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION.
NUMEROUS GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND
WE BASED ORGANIZATIONS WERE
UNABLE TO ACCESS FUNDING.
EITHER DUE TO A LACK OF
POLITICAL WILL OR COMPLICATED
APPROVAL PART BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY COULD NOT BE COMPLETED
DURING A GRANT TIME.
THE AMENDMENT REMAINING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND GOVERNMENT ENTITIES TO APPLY
DIRECTLY WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS AND
FURTHERS THE ORIGINAL INTENT.
OF SERVING YOUTH IN THE
COMMUNITY AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
REST INCARCERATION.
SECOND THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION
PLACE TO CAP A ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH DISSUADED SOME OF
THAT LARGER COUNTIES FROM BEING
pWOULDN'T MEET THE NEEDS. FOR
THEIR COUNTY.
WE HAVEN'T AT FORMULATED
AMENDMENT TO RAISE IT TO TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AS MAX AMOUNT
FOR THE GRANT.
FINALLY WHILE FIFTY APPLICANTS
REPRESENTING CITIES AND COUNTIES
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
ACROSS THE STATE APPLIED FOR
THESE FUNDS THERE WERE
GEOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES.
PROVIDING INFORMATION FORMS TO
ENCOURAGE APPLICATIONS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AS WAS DONE SUCCESSFULLY LAST
YEAR IN SACRAMENTO AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO THESE
FUNDS AND WE NEED TO WHERE THEY
NEED FOR DIVERSION PROGRAMMING
STILL REMAINS HIGH.
WE KNOW THESE PROGRAMS WILL HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF YOUTH WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT.
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WILL IMPROVE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
ARE PROVIDED COMMUNITY AND
HEALTH BASED INTERVENTIONS IN
LIEU OF ARREST AND INCARCERATION.
THANK YOU TO EVERY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BRIANNA'S LIFE
ALERT NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW IN TRANSPORT.
ANY OTHERS ALRIGHT ANY WRITTEN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NINE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE DARTH.
A CENTER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I'M JUST CURIOUS POINT EIGHT WAS
TO DELETE THE REQUIREMENT.
THAT AGENCIES HIGHER RESEARCH
AGENCY TO EVALUATE THE PROGRAMS
THAT I DIDN'T.
HEAR THAT ADDRESS COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHY THAT IS BEING.
DELETED [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible] EIGHT MICHAEL
IS A MY NUMBER EIGHT YEAH I'M
SORRY MY MY NOSE -- CITY CANCER
THERE WERE NO IMMEDIATE I'LL GO
TO THE MY OTHER NOTES HERE
THAT'S THREE INTO.
WHICH THING ABOUT TO LEADING.
FROM ARE GOING. FOR THIS ISSUE.
AND A MAJOR.
USE ME.
IN TRYING.
TO I CAN NOT MINE.
I CAN.
IF YOU.
GET.
WHERE CAN I FIND IT -- WE'RE
WORKING ON IT MADAM CHAIR HAVE
IT MIGHT WRITTEN NOTES -- IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE BSE
SEE SPECIFICALLY HAD REQUESTED.
AND I MEANT THAT I BELIEVE THAT
WAS ONE OF THE ONES THAT THEY
HAD REQUESTED I'M NOT GONNA
SPEAK ON WHY THEIR REASONS WERE
FOR IT WE DO BELIEVE EVALUATION
IS IMPORTANT AND WE ASK.
YEAH I WE DO BELIEVE EVALUATION
IS IMPORTANT AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS SOME PRETTY
RIGOROUS GRADING DIçN FOR THE
IT THE APPLICATIONS THEMSELVES
AND HOPE.
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO
REPLICATE THE SUCCESSES OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
BUT THEN THAT WHAT I CAN.
IT WAS FOR SEE [inaudible]
REMEMBER.
JOINT STORAGE SAWYER ANSWER I
CAN.
FIND THEM QUICKLY ON BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. NINE IF THE ACTUAL
BILL IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS.
THIS ONE HERE [inaudible]
RESERVE FUND [inaudible]
WORK OUT.
OR MAYBE YOU CAN GET BACK TO ME
ON THAT LET ME GET BACK TO YOU
AS WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE I NEED TO
TALK.
IN ADDITION TO THE B. SEC
BECAUSE AS CHAIR AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT.
EVALUATION IS A CRITICAL PART OF
THIS -- AND I HAD I BELIEVE THIS
IS TO HELP GET MORE PEOPLE IN
THE PIPELINE NOT NECESSARILY --
ELIMINATE OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY EVALUATE THESE PROGRAMS
LET ME GET A CLARIFICATION TODAY
FOR YOU SENATE YOU AND I'LL GET.
A BETTER.
YOUR QUESTION FOR YOU AS WELL
THAT WOULD BE GOOD APOLOGY
STATEMENT HERE -- WE WILL.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION -- WE WILL WE HAVE CORPS
LET'S ESTABLISH FORM.
LETS YOU ROLL CALL -- HERE MORE
LIKE.
BRADFORD JACKSON JACKSON HERE
MITCHELL BORROW WIENER.
WIENER HERE.
RIGHT SO WE CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION I JUST WANT -- TO I
APPRECIATE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOU'RE BRINGING
THE BILL I I THINK THE SEC.
IS -- WELL INTENTIONED BUT WE'VE
HAD EXPERIENCES BEFORE WHERE --
OF FUNDS THAT WERE ALLOCATED DID
NOT GET OUT BECAUSE OF EITHER
THE WAY THE R. F. P. WAS WRITTEN
OR OTHER -- OBSTACLES THAT
OCCURRED SO THAT THE POPULATIONS
AND ENTITIES THAT WE WERE
INTENDING TO FIND MAYBE OUR OWN
STATUTES WERE CLEAR ENOUGH.
DID NOT GET THE FUNDING THAT WE
HAD APPROPRIATED SO -- I THINK
YOUR YOUR CORRECTIONS ARE THE
YOUR THESE AMENDMENTS AND
CORRECTIONS ARE NECESSARY.
THE THING ABOUT THE RESEARCH ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS -- OBVIOUSLY
YOU'LL GET BACK TO MY AND VICE
CHAIR BUT ALSO I'M SURE WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY -- TO THE WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THE
RESEARCH AT A FUTURE TIME SO WE
CAN FUTURE APPROPRIATE IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
HONEST STATUTES SO IT THIS DOES
NOT.
PRE VENICE IT JUST DOESN'T HAVE
THE FINDING.
IN WITHIN THIS ALLOCATION THAT'S
ALL.
ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A
MOTION MRS -- AB FIFTH FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER ADVENTURE YES JUST LIKE I
COULD ASK ONE CERTAINLY QUITE
YET.
IT IS PAGE NINE AND IS FOR C.
AND IT'S BEING ELIMINATED BUT
IT'S ALSO.
STATING THAT THEY SHOULD BE SELF.
I ANALYZE AND AND I I JUST
WONDER ABOUT THE OBJECTIVITY OF
YOU KNOW ANALYZING YOUR OWN
GRANT.
WOULD THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY
GONNA SAY YOU DID A GREAT A
GREAT JOB WITH THE MONEY.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING HOW DO WE
GET SENT DEPENDENCE AND TURNED
IT WE WOULD.
DEFINITELY MAKE SURE IT IS A
INDEPENDENT OUTSIDE AGENCY
LOOKING AT IT NOT.
AS YOU WOULD SAY -- GREAT ME
LOOKING AT MY OWN PROGRAM.
GOING ON THEN I'LL JUST HOLD OFF
UNTIL I SEE IT ON THE FLOOR.
RIGHT SO WE HAVE A SIMILAR WHICH
I LIKE TO ASK RELIABLE.
ALL RIGHTS LET'S -- TAKE A ROLL
CALL AND THIS IS A DO YOU PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
JACKSON JACKSON AYE MITCHELL
MORALE.
WIENER.
RIGHT THERE ARE [inaudible]
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU.
SORRY IT'S NOT OUT USE ME THE
BILL STILL ON CALL BECAUSE WE
HAVE MISSED MEMBERS.
AT LEAST TWO MISSING MEMBERS.
SO APOLOGIES -- IT'S EARLY --
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR
WHO WILL BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN LET ME INDICATE THAT.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON IS BEING PULLED
FROM TODAY'S HEARING IT WILL BE
A TO YOUR BILL.
THE BILLS ON CONSENT OUR ITEM TO
AB THREE THREE TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY ITEM NINE AB EIGHT
NINETEEN MARK STONE.
ITEM TWELVE AB THREE THIRTEEN
CAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS AND
WE'RE GONNA WAIT BEFORE WE DO A
CONSENT MOTION BECAUSE WE HAVE.
TO GET POSSESSION OF AB EIGHT
NINETEEN AFTER IT WAS HEARD IN
HUMAN SERVICES YESTERDAY IT
HASN'T BEEN PASSED ON TO US YET
UNTIL IT'S IN OUR POSSESSION.
WE CAN'T ACT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE SOONEST WE HAVE IT
I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALRIGHT SO NOW WE'LL GO TO ITEM
THREE AB THREE FORTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN YOU HAVE TO FLOOR
THANK YOU CHAIR SKINNER I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THREE
FORTY AN INNOVATIVE APPROACH TO
KEEPING GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE THEM.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX THE DOJ
HAS MAINTAINED THE ARMED AND
PROHIBITED POSSESSOR OF PERSON
SYSTEM APPS AN AUTOMATED
DATABASE THAT CROSS REFERENCES
GUN REGISTRATION DATA WITH THE
LIST OF PROHIBITED PERSONS.
A BACKLOG OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
THOUSAND POTENTIALLY ARMED
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE APP
SYSTEM UNDERLINES THE NEED FOR A
NEW APPROACH.
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET -- THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND APPS AND
WANT TO THANK CHAIR SKINNER FOR
THAT -- THIS IS TO FOR A LOCAL --
PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE COUNTIES
OF ALAMEDA SAN DIEGO SANTA CRUZ
AND VENTURA.
AB THREE FORTY WOULD ENABLE
THESE COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH
ABSENT FORSMAN TEAMS CONSISTING
OF AGENTS AND OFFICERS.
FROM SHERIFF'S AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS WITH A
REPRESENTATION FROM THE DA'S
OFFICE AND STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES ROBUST
DATA COLLECTION AND THAT A
REPORT BE SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN LEARN WHAT
WORKS WHAT CAN BE APPROVED
IMPROVED AND HOW TO BETTER
FOSTER COLLABORATION BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS.
WHEN YOU HAVE WITNESSES
[inaudible]
ALL.
CORRECT.
OKAY.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA NINETY TWO CANS COME
BY ONCE -- WE HAVE BEEN LONG
TIME SUPPORTERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
ARMED PROHIBIT A PERSON SYSTEM
PROGRAM -- OBVIOUSLY TO THE
EXTENT THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROHIBITED AND PRESUMABLY
DANGEROUS ARE -- THE FIREARMS
REMOVED FROM THEM THE IT
ENHANCES PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN THIS
PROGRAM WAS INITIALLY CONCEIVED
THE IDEA WAS THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD BE.
GREATLY INVOLVED IN DISARMING
PROHIBITED PEOPLE IN FACT ONE OF
THE EARLY PROJECTS FOR
CALIFORNIA BRADY CHAPTERS WAS TO
REACH OUT TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY SIGNED UP FOR
WHAT WAS AN COMMON APPS SECURE
MAILBOX WHEREBY THEY RECEIVED A
PRINT OUT EVERY MONTH I BELIEVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
JUSTICE.
OF FOOD ARMED AND PROHIBITED IN
THEIR JURISDICTION.
MANY AGENCIES THAT EVEN SIGN UP
FOR THAT MAILBOX AND OBVIOUSLY I
THINK AS WE ALL KNOW -- MOST OF
THAT DISARMING OF INDIVIDUALS IN
APPS HAS BEEN BY DONE AND DONE
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE.
SO DID NOT HAPPEN AS PLANNED THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVEMENT MEANWHILE IN THESE
YEARS -- WE'VE ADDED TO THE APPS
BACK LOAD.
OUR STATE NOW RETAINS RECORDS OF
WHO HAS PURCHASE LONG GUN.
MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE MAY FALL ON
THE APPS WE HAVE RECORDS NOW FOO
HAS REGISTERED THERE ARE SO
CALLED FULL OF BUTTON ASSAULT
WEAPON OR THE GHOST GUN THE GUN
THAT THEY MANUFACTURED AND
ASSEMBLED.
THE END GUN SALES WERE VERY HIGH
VERTICALLY BETWEEN THE YEARS OF
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA SELECTED
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP -- SO
OBVIOUSLY THE WORKLOAD HAS
INCREASED OUR TO DISARM PEOPLE
IN APPS THE NUMBER KEEPS RISING
IT'S BEEN A GREAT FRUSTRATION I
KNOW TO MANY OF YOU -- AND
OTHERS IN THE STATE ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT IN THE MOST
RECENT SB ONE FORTY REPORT
SUBMITTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IS THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ONCE AGAIN --
HELP WITH DISARMING PEOPLE WHO
ARE PROHIBITED IN THEIR
JURISDICTION -- IN DOING A PILOT
PROGRAM IN THESE FOUR COUNTIES I
THINK IS A GOOD WAY TO GO TO SEE
HOW THIS WORKS TO LEARN FROM IT
ESTABLISH.
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PROCESSES
FOR OTHER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS --
SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
APPROACH FOR BRINGING DOWN THAT
APP.
BACKLOG I HOPE IT WORKS AND IT
CAN BE A MODEL FOR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN THE STATE.
SO WE DRIVE OUT.
FIGHT TO HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE BEHALF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT ESCRIBIR THANK YOU.
GIVE ME MATHIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
ONE MAN CHAIR MEMBERS RANCHER
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SINGMAN.
LOVELY WAY TO START THE DAY --
CENTER MORE LACK.
WILK MANAGER BECAUSE IT IS
AMANDA WILCOX THAT WAS THE KEY
WITNESS ALL A MOVIE ITEM
[inaudible]
GOOD -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
OKAY.
THE I KNOW THAT -- THERE WERE
SOME FUNDING.
FOR THIS PROGRAM APPROPRIATE IN
THE BUDGET WHICH IS GOOD.
AND WITH THAT WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER.
AND YOUR BILL WILL BE ON CALL --
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME MISSING
MEMBERS.
THANKS.
OKAY IT WILL NOW GO TO ITEM FOR
A. B. THREE NINETY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS SO I LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- WORKED OUT WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO NARROW THIS
SCOPE OF THE BILL TO CAPTURE
DATA UPON CONVICTION FOR WHEN
THE DO YOU I WAS COST SOLELY BY
MAYOR AND WE WANNA.
IN A WHEN I THINK THE CHAIR AND
HER STAFF TEAM FOR BEING A PART
OF THE PROCESS.
ARE AB THREE NINETY SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE THE ANNUAL REPORTING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF OUR
CONVICTION DATA RELATING TO
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
CANNABIS.
OTHER STATES THAT LEGALIZED
CANNABIS SAW INCREASES IN FATAL
CRASHES INVOLVING INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF CANNABIS.
THE LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL LIKELY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RISE OF
IMPAIRED DRIVING AS WELL.
WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INDEPENDENTLY KEEP STATISTICS ON
CANNABIS RELATED TO YOU AYE DATA.
OUR STATE HAS NO UNIFORM
MECHANISM IN PLACE TO EVALUATE
CANNABIS TRUCK DRIVING DATA.
R. A. B. THREE NINETY SEVEN WILL
ALLOW THE STATE TO HAVE ACCURATE
AND RELIABLE DATA OF HOW MANY
CANNABIS DO YOU AYE RELATED
CONVICTIONS.
OCCUR IN THE STATE TO ANNUALLY
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WILL ALSO
MAKE A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
CHANGES.
TO CORRECT SOME -- CROSS
REFERENCES IN VEHICLE CODE.
SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A PRIVATE.
THANK YOU -- DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LUCIA MUCH LIKE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
RECORDS SUPERVISORS -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT WAS AT
BRITAIN HOWEVER ON SINCE THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN ACCEPTED BY
THE AUTHOR WE'RE HAPPY TO REVIEW
THE BILL AGAIN.
AND I SEE IF WE CAN REMOVE
OPPOSITION TO LEGISLATION THANK
YOU OKAY.
ANY ONE ELSE WINNERS OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- YES HERE'S ANOTHER.
JANUARY TEARS ONLY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THAT RIGHT AND LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY -- MY AFTER WE HAVE
COME INTO QUESTION MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR AND TAKING YOU
MANAGE I KNOW THAT.
OUR HIGHWAY PATROL AND MANY
OTHER AGENCIES ARE VERY EAGER
FOR US TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
WE HAVE A VALID -- CAST AT THE
POINT OF ARE ANY OFFICER.
PULLING OVER SOMEONE WHO IS --
DRIVING THEN THEY FEEL IMPAIRED.
SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
DETERMINATION.
OF IF THEY'RE UNDER THE
INFLUENCE AND IF AND WHAT
THEY'RE UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH CANNABIS IS
THAT T. H. C. WILL STAND
SOMEONE'S BLOOD SYSTEM. FOR A
GOOD PERIOD OF TIME SO THEY
COULD HAVE A UTILIZED CANNABIS A
DAY EARLIER TWO DAYS EARLIER --
AND BE.
PERHAPS BE IMPAIRED FOR ANOTHER
REASON AND YET IT MIGHT SHOW
CANNABIS WITH OUR CURRENT
TESTING SO I THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENT YOU'VE TAKEN IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL GIVE
US MORE ACCURATE INFORMATION
BECAUSE WE REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
WHETHER THAT IMPAIRMENT IS
SOLELY CANNABIS ARE PRIMARILY
CANNABIS OR IN A DIFFERENT DRUG
SO THAT GIVES US THE INFORMATION
AS TO WHETHER OUR THE NOT OUR
BUT THE FACT OF LEGALIZATION.
IF IT IS CONTRIBUTING TO MORE --
IMPAIR DRIVING INCIDENTS --
CERTAINLY OTHER STATES DATA
WOULD INDICATE THAT IS SO AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY YOUR MOTIVATION
OF YOUR BILL IS TAKE NAY BLESSED
TO GET THAT DATA BUT I THINK
THIS AMENDMENT IS A IS A GOOD.
CORRECTION I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TAKING IT ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THAT SUGGESTION
AS WELL CERTAINLY AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I ASKED HER ADULT.
EXCELLENT SO NOW -- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WILL DO A ROLL
CALL.
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE WIENER.
YOUR BILL WILL BE ON CALL
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME MISSING
MEMBERS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER MY ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE
WHO'S HERE.
OKAY GET A TEAM OF BREAKFAST
.
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WE WILL
ALLOW YOU TO PRESENT IT IS ITEM?
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE SIXTEEN GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
HEARD THERE WAS AN OPENING HAPPY
TO TAKE IT -- FIRST OF ALL YOU
WERE NEXT.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION OF AB
FIVE SIXTEEN A BILL THAT WOULD
REFORM A FEW TELLING PRACTICES
THAT ARE SEVERELY IMPACTED LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
LET ME FIRST START BY --
PROVIDED A SIGNIFICANT THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF YOUR
WORK WITH THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE.
AND OUR OFFICE ON VERY
SIGNIFICANT MOMENTS WE'VE TAKEN
IN THE SENATE. FOR MY
PRESENTATION ALI WILL BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE WATER BILL SEEKS TO DO
WATER BILL DOES NOT DO -- AND
SUMMARIZE ARMAMENTS FOR SORT OF
BUILD US.
EARLIER THIS YEAR A STATEWIDE
STUDY ENTITLED TOWED INTO DEBT
EXTENSIVELY DOCUMENTED THE
IMPACT OF THREE TOWING GROUNDS
REFER TO AS PARTY TO US.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY FOR FIVE
PARKING TICKETS AND OUTDATED CAR
REGISTRATION FOR A PRIVATE
PARKING SPOT -- SINCE OVER
ALMOST HALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
DON'T HAVE A SPARE FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS FAR LESS THAN THE
AVERAGE COST TO GET YOUR CAR OUT
OF A TOW YARD.
GETTING TOWED EQUALS ASSET
FORFEITURE YOU LOSE YOUR CAR
YOUR ABILITY TO GET YOUR JOB.
MANY INSTANCES YOUR JOB YOU'RE
ONLY ECONOMIC ASSET FOR YOUR
ONLY FORM OF SHELTER.
THESE TOES HAVE ACCELERATED
POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS.
IT TURNS OUT THE TO YOUR ALSO
LOSE MONEY ON THESE PROVISIONS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO STORE CARS
BEFORE AUCTION SALES.
AND THE AVERAGE STORAGE IN THE
IN AN AUCTION SO CASA FAR EXCEED
THE AVERAGE SALES PRICE OF A CAR.
FOR SIMILAR REASONS CITIES
RUNNING THESE TOWING PROGRAMS
ALSO LOSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS IS WHY WE ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED ELIMINATING THESE
PROVISIONS TO END A CYCLE OF
POVERTY NOT WORKING FOR WORKING
FAMILIES TôI YARDS OR CITIES.
NOW I WANT TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT OUR BILL DOES
NOT DO BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF MISINFORMATION ABOUT IT.
FIRST THERE BEEN SOME ADVOCATES
FOR CITIES TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
BILL AND STOWING THAT IS FALSE
THRE ARE OVER THIRTY GROUNDS TO
TOW CARS UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW.
MOST HAVE TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND TRAFFIC FLOW WE'RE
NOT TOUCHING ANY OF THOSE.
SECOND SOME CITIES HAVE SAID
WILL ALLOW ABANDONED CARS ON THE
STREETS THAT IS ALSO FALSE
THERE'S A SPECIFIC TOWING
PROVISION THAT ALLOWS CITIES TO
TOW CARS THAT ARE BANNED IN
WRECKED OR INOPERATIVE.
WE'RE NOT TOUCHING THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE MAY HAVE ALSO
HEARD THE SUGGESTION THAT WERE
SOMEHOW REMOVING LOCAL CONTROL
AND THAT IS ALSO FALSE THERE IS
YET ANOTHER TIME PROVISION.
THAT WE'RE NOT TOUCHING WITH
THIS BILL THAT ALLOWS THE CITY
TO PASS LOCAL TOWING LAWS TO
ADDRESS LOCAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
THIS IS A BILL THAT SUPPORTS
PURE LOCAL CONTROL.
NOW JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO
DISCUSS THE SIGNIFICANT MOMENTS
WE TOOK THE ORIGINAL BILL VOTED
ON BY THE ASSEMBLY WOULD HAVE
DELETED THE THREE POVERTY TOWING
GROUNDS UNDER STATE LAW.
AFTER NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE WE AMENDED OUR BILL TO
ONLY DELETE ONE OF THE THREE
TELLING GROUNDS.
THE AMENDED VERSION OF THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW CITIES TO CONTINUE TO
TOW FOR EXPIRED REGISTRATIONS.
THE AMENDED VERSION OF THIS BILL
WILL ALSO ALLOW CITIES TO
CONTINUE -- TO TO CARS THAT HAVE
BEEN LEGALLY PARKED ON PUBLIC
STREETS.
CURRENT LAW SAYS CARS CAN BE
TOWED AFTER SEVENTY TWO HOURS
WITHOUT NOTICE.
SINCE MANY CITIES TOLD US THAT
THEY DON'T TELL UNDER THIS OFFER
AT LEAST A WEEK OR LONGER.
AND SUPPORT PROVIDING NOTICE TO
CAR OWNERS ARMAMENTS WOULD ALLOW
A CAR TO BE TOWED IMMEDIATELY
AFTER A NOTICE AND FIVE BUSINESS
DAYS.
OR BILL DOES MOVE TO AND TOWING
FOR UNPAID PARKING TICKETS WHICH
IS THE PUREST VERSION OF TELLING
SOMEONE TO COLLECT A MINOR DEBT.
I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT OUR BILL
DOES NOT MAKE IT LEGAL TO NOT
PAY PARKING TICKETS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN CONTINUE
TO LOSE USED AT LEAST EIGHT
OTHER ALTERNATIVE REMEDIES TO
COLLECT UNPAID DEBTS.
LESSON ONE A NOTE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THERE ARE STRONG
CONSTITUTION ARGUMENTS THAT
TELLING SOMEONE TO CLICK TO
MINOR DEBT VIOLATES THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S PROHIBITION.
AGAINST SEIZURES OF PROPERTY THE
EIGHTH AMENDMENT'S PROHIBITION
AGAINST EXCESSIVE FINES.
AND THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT'S
PROHIBITIONS AGAINST DEPRIVING
DUE PROCESS AND EQUAL PROTECTION
WITH UP WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
A WITNESSES.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
I AM GRAHAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AS A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL.
AS THE REPORT HIGHLIGHTS
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS LOSE
THEIR CARS EVERY YEAR AS A
RESULT OF POVERTY TOES THIS IS
THEIR LIFELINE TO TRAVEL TO WORK
GET TO SCHOOL OBTAIN HOUSING
TAKE THEIR FAMILY TO THE DOCTOR.
WHEN CARS GET TOWED FOR UNPAID
PARKING TICKETS A COSTS
INITIALLY HUNDREDS TO GET YOUR
CAR THE TO A LOT?
AND THOUSANDS OFTEN BECAUSE LOW
INCOME FOLKS NEED TIME TO GATHER
THAT INITIAL MONEY BUT EVERY DAY
THAT THEY SPEND TRYING TO
COLLECT THOSE FUNDS ADDITIONAL
STORAGE FEES GET TACKED ON TO
THEIR FINAL BILL.
AS A RESULT THE CARS OFTEN COST
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO GET OUT
OF THE TOTAL YARDS LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CAN'T AFFORD THAT THEY
FORFEIT THEIR CARS.
AND A CYCLE THAT BENEFITS NO ONE
ENSUES THE CARS GET SOLD BY THE
TOW YARD SET A LIEN SALE.
THE MONEY FOR THE PARKING TICKET
THAT NEVER GETS COLLECTED BY THE
CITY AS THE TOW YARD TO KEEP THE
LIEN SALE.
SO THE INDIVIDUALS OUT A
LIFELINE FOR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND THE ORIGINAL
PARKING TICKET THAT GOES ON PAID.
AND CARS WITH UNPAID PARKING
TICKETS DON'T POSE A PUBLIC
SAFETY THREAT THEY DON'T IMPEDE
TRAFFIC LOW BUT THEY ARE
UNFORTUNATELY EXTREMELY
ESSENTIAL TO DAILY LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY WE BROUGHT THIS BILL
SO THAT MANY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS DON'T
CONTINUE TO BE TOWED INTO DEBT.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THEIR PARKING TICKETS.
NEXT WITNESS.
MADAM CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE ALSO A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL.
AND THIS IS -- YOU KNOW FOR THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS NOW OUR
ORGANIZATION AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN BRINGING.
OF LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF YOU
THAT DEALS WITH THE HIGH COST OF
BEING POOR -- AND SO WE'VE WE'VE
WORKED ON TRAFFIC TICKETS WE
WORKED ON BAIL WE'VE WORKED ON
JUVENILE FINES AND FEES REPORT
ON PARKING TICKETS.
ALL OF THESE ARE EXAMPLES THAT
WE SEE IN OUR LEGAL SERVICE
PROGRAMS EVERY DAY WHERE PEOPLE
ARE -- BEING SUBJECTED TO THE
HIGH COST OF FINES AND FEES MAY
SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO STAY UP
WITH THE COST OF THESE AND IT
GETS THEM INTO SERIOUS DEBT.
AND IN THE IN THE SITUATION WITH --
OF PARKING AND TRAFFIC FEES
ULTIMATELY OUR CLIENTS
FREQUENTLY LOSE THEIR MAJOR
ASSET THAT THEY HAVE THAT THEY
DEPEND ON TO GET TO WORK TO BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY.
PAY THE COST OF THESE FINES AND
FEES.
OUR GOAL IN BRINGING THESE BILLS
IS THE TRIED TO SELF ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH THESE.
THESE LAWS WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE -- TO GET THEIR CARS
REGISTER WE WANT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO GET THEM SMOG AND BE LEGAL ON
THE STREETS.
BUT THE WAY WE SET UP MANY OF
OUR LAWS WE WE CREATEDECONOMIC
IMPEDIMENTS TO THEIR ABILITY TO
DO THAT SO WE SEE AB FIVE
SIXTEEN AS THE LATEST THINKING
IN A PATTERN OF CHANGES THAT
WE'RE PROPOSING.
THAT WILL ALLOW OUR CLIENTS TO
DRIVE LEGALLY SAFELY M. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB FIVE SIXTEEN
AND DRIVE VOTE TODAY.
WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SENATOR SCANNER.
Q..
YES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JEFF.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
CAN'T CORRAL SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF ANYONE
WITH A C. R. U. CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OLIVIA SHE'LL TO THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONALIZATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
A RUBBER COLD SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL CAM TELL HERE ON
BEHALF THE CITIES OF SANTA
MONICA OF LOS ANGELES IN BEVERLY
HILLS OPPOSITION THANK
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WATER TIGHT CHECK ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE IN OPPOSITION.
MOTOROLA WHEN THEY CAN.
GO AHEAD.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RUNNING PRETTY
GOOD HERE -- ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES --
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
AMENDMENTS -- WE REMAIN STRONGLY
OPPOSED -- TO AB -- FIVE ONE SIX
IT DOES PREAMP CITIES -- FROM
TOWING UNDER SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES -- WHEN YOU DELETE
SECTIONS OF THE VEHICLE CODE --
THE VEHICLE CODE IS WHAT GIVES
CITIES AND COUNTIES -- THE
EXPRESSIVE FORTY THE TONER
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES THERE FOR
WHEN THOSE PROVISIONS ARE
DELETED.
THE AUTHORITY GOES AWAY --
CALIFORNIA VEHICLE CODE SECTION --
TWENTY ONE BASICALLY THE
INTRODUCTION TO THE TIRE VEHICLE
CODE -- CLEARLY PREEMPTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- FROM THIS FIELD
OF LAW -- THEREFORE WHEN YOU
DELETE THE SECTIONS AGAIN -- THE
AUTHORITY -- GOES AWAY WITH THAT --
UNDER AB -- FIVE ONE SIX CITIES
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TOW CARS --
IF THEY HAVE FIVE OR MORE MP
PARKING TICKETS -- AND AND KEEP
IN MIND WHEN SOMEBODY GETS FAR
MORE UNPAID PARKING TICKETS --
CITIES ALSO HAVE TO BE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY ONE DAYS FOR
THOSE.
FOLKS RESPOND -- AND NOT ONLY
THAT BUT BECAUSE OF AB -- FIVE
OH THREE BY SOMEONE MEMBER
LACKEY WHICH WAS CHAPTER A JUST
TWO YEARS AGO CITIES ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED. TO OFFER PAYMENT PLANS
ANYBODY WHO'S AND DIGIT MEANING
THAT THEY ARE ON SOME FORM OF
CASH ASSISTANCE -- WITH THE
STATE.
AND SO -- WE DO THINK THAT THAT
THERE ARE THAT THERE ARE
REMEDIES -- FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
LOW INCOME -- TO ENROLL INTO A
PAYMENT PLAN AND BASICALLY -- BY
THE TIME THAT THEY HAVE THEIR
FIFTY TAKE IT THAT IS ON
RESPONDED -- TO IT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT COMPLYING OR EVEN
DOING SOMETHING BASIC AS GOING
DOWN THE CITY HALL -- AND
RESPONDING TO THE VIOLATION OR
ROLLING IN A PAYMENT PLAN -- AND
WE THINK THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM --
THE OTHER THING ON THE SEVENTY
TWO HOURS -- BASICALLY WE HAVE
TO WAIT WE WOULD UNDER THIS BILL
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO WAIT AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE BUSINESS DAYS --
TO LAPSE -- AFTER THE SENATOR
OVER OUR VIOLATION HAS OCCURRED --
WITH THE SCIMITAR VIOLATION AS
YOU ALL KNOW -- EVEN WHEN YOU
LOOK AROUND YOUR CITY -- THOSE --
THAT PARTICULAR -- MUNICIPAL
CODE IS TYPICALLY NOT SIGNED --
FOR SOME CITIES RECEIVED OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND COMPLAINTS FOR
CARS BEING -- PART OF FOR TOO
LONG WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION --
AND SO WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
THE BANDWIDTH TO REALLY -- DEAL
WITH ALL OF THE COMPLAINTS -- SO
WE TYPICALLY DON'T DON'T
NECESSARILY SIGN FOR THAT -- BUT
CITIES DO TYPICALLY PLACE A
NOTICE -- ON ON THE VEHICLES
SAYING THAT YOU'RE GONNA ONCE WE
WITNESS THE VIOLATION
ESSENTIALLY A CAR BEING UNMOVED
FOR SEVEN TWO HOURS -- WE JUST
CAN'T TAKE A COUPLE YOU KNOW A
COMPLAINTS WORK FOR IT -- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE TO SEE THE SAME TO
OURS THE LAPS THEN WE'LL THEN
CITIES WILL TYPICALLY PLACE A
NOTICE ON WHICH FIELD.
THANK FROM TODAY YOU HAVE THINGS
ARE SOME OF YOUR CAR IF YOU
DON'T THEN THE CARD GETS TOWED.
THIS WOULD ADD AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE BUSINESS DAYS THROUGH THAT
PROCESS WERE LOOKING AT A
MINIMUM OF EIGHT EIGHT DAYS --
BEFORE PARKING CAN GET TOWED.
CAN I DO THINK THAT THAT CREATES --
A PUBLIC SAFETY RISK -- IF NOW
HOMELAND SECURITY MAYBE SOME
DOMESTIC ISSUES -- I THINK COULD
BE AT RISK -- THERE AS WELL --
AND SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS --
WE REMAIN OPPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO NOW WE CAN.
JACKSON MAN TELL ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD WE
HAVEN'T OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND HAVE SUBMITTED
THOSE AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU.
MANAGER DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
CITIES OF BURBANK GLENDALE
MARIETTA PASADENA SAN MARCOS AND
STRONG OPPOSITION.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING CHAISSON BRIAN OF THE
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS AND THEN IT'S A DELL WE
THINK THAT ADDRESSES PART OF OUR
CONCERN WE STILL DO HAVE
CONCERNS THE BILLS WE MANIFEST
THANK YOU.
G. V. AIRS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSE REPOSSESS SERVERS -- WE
DEAL -- WITH THE VEHICLES WHICH
BEEN TOLD ALL THE TIME.
AND ALTHOUGH WE ARE SYMPATHETIC
TO THE TO THE GOALS OF THE BILL
WE THINK THERE ARE BETTER WAYS
OF DOING THEIR STAR NUMBER OF
INCREMENTAL -- TRAPS AND WHICH
IN WHICH PEOPLE GET CAUGHT UP IN
THE SYSTEM -- THERE THAT WE
THINK COULD BE IMPROVED WHICH
WOULD GET YOU CLOSER TO THE GOAL
OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
THE BILL.
THAT SO WE HAVE AN OPPOSING
LESSON IN A POSITION.
ELEONORA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SWEARS
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE SIDE OF
THE MAN.
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF TO SEE IF
SACRAMENTO OPPOSED.
LITERATURE MEMBERS COREY SAYS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
THIS CHAIR MEMBER GREG HAYES ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL PUBLIC
SAFETY TRANSPORTATION
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
ESSENTIALLY THE WELFARE OF THE
CITIZENS IS RESPONSIBILITY THE
COUNTY AND THE STATE.
THE SHIPS THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE A
CITIZENS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
MUST ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AS IT
OCCURS IN THEIR FROM THEIR
BUSINESS OR IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
MY PARENTS ARE IN THEIR EIGHTIES.
ARE TYPICAL OF THEIR GENERATION
HAVE A HANDICAP PLACARD BUT THEY
DON'T USE IT AND ACCESS TO
APPOINTMENTS AND PHARMACIES IS
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY BEING
HAMPERED MORE AND MORE THESE
DAYS.
MY FATHER HE IT TAKES ABOUT
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO WALK A FEW
BLOCKS BUT PEOPLE DO IT.
AND IT'S IT'S NOT REALLY FAIR
THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO ADDRESS --
THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE DIRECTED --
THAT ARE BEING.
TARGETED WITH THIS BILL WE HOPE
YOU CONSIDER THAT THANK YOU.
RAINY PERIOD WE HAVE A POOR ACT
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- COMMENTS SENATOR
MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SOME NUMBERS CHIU.
AN INTERESTING BILL HERE I A I
TRY NOT TO SAY THIS IS QUITE A
BIT BUT I'D TOWING SERVICE IS
REALLY BAD MUSIC.
I WANNA BE REAL REAL CAREFUL
HERE SEPARATION YOUR SUPPORT
YEAH.
SO I WILL GO UP ONE MORNING AND
MY YOUNGEST SON WHO I THOUGHT IT
MOVED OUT WAS IN HIS BEDROOM.
HE HAD MOVED TO THE PENINSULA
NEWPORT BEACH I SAID WHAT YOU
DOING HERE HE SAID.
I COULDN'T FIND A PARKING SPOT.
WHAT CAN WHAT WILL BE HELD SO
THAT'S ONE WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT
AND SO I'M SITTING HERE I'M
TRYING TO REACT?
AND I'M I'M WONDERING IF WORD
MISDIAGNOSED IN THE PROBLEM AND
AND WE'RE NOT GETTING IT
CORRECTLY BY JUST LOOK AT SOME
SYMPTOMS.
SO I I'M REAL CONCERNED THAT YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF
ENABLING.
PEOPLE TO DO THINGS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE DOING.
AND EVEN IF THE BASED ON THEIR
ECONOMIC STATUS OR CONDITION.
THAT STILL DOESN'T PERMIT SHOULD
NOT PARK PROPERLY MULTIPLE TIMES
AGREED IN TIME I'M JUST TRYING.
TO GET MY ARMS AROUND WHAT YOU
KNOW IS THIS GRAY ACER IS THIS
DYSFUNCTION AND I'M TRYING.
TO SETTLE THAT MY MIND AND I'M
SORT OF LEANING TOWARDS YOU KNOW
NOT HELPING SCOFFLAWS THAT ARE.
JUST DOING WHATEVER THEY WANT.
HEARING NO REPERCUSSIONS.
SO I AGREE WITH YOU.
LET'S START WITH THAT -- LET ME
SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT THIS
THERE'S BEEN.
A LOT OF MISINFORMATION THAT'S
BEEN PUT OUT IN THIS BILL I
RARELY IN MY OPENING STATEMENT
SORT OF LAY OUT WHAT THE
MISINFORMATION IS -- BUT WE ARE
NOT TRYING TO ELIMINATE.
WE WERE TRYING TO GET AT A
HANDFUL OF PROVISIONS OUT OF
OVER THIRTY THAT ADDRESS TIME IN
MY CITY THE THREE PROVISIONS WE
WERE INITIALLY TALKING ABOUT
WOULD HAVE TOLD ABOUT 10%
MALTOSE.
SO 90% OF ALL DOES THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH PUBLIC SAFETY TRAFFIC
FLOW WOULD HAVE BEEN ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE WE HAVE NOW AMENDED.
SERVER ONLY TALK ABOUT TOUCHING
ONE OF THOSE -- THREE TO SO
AGAIN PROBABLY A COUPLE OF
PERCENTAGE OF AUTO SO MY GUESS
IS 979698% OF AALTO'S WILL.
CONTINUE TO BE ALLOWED WHAT WE
ARE SAYING WITH THIS BILL AS
IT'S BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED
WITH THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
IS THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO PAY FOR PART FIVE
PARKING TICKETS.
WE SHOULDN'T USE THE HAMMER
VERTIGO TO GO OUT YOU LET ME LET
ME TO DELINEATE THE EIGHT OTHER
WAYS.
THAT ALL OF OUR CITIES COULD GO
AFTER INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE NOT
PAID THEIR PARKING TICKETS.
YOU COULD CHARGE THEM LATE
PAYMENT PENALTIES YOU COULD WITH
A WHOLE TAX RETURNS YOU COULD
PLACE REGISTRATION HOLDS YOU CAN
SEND DEBTS TO COLLECTION
AGENCIES.
YOU CAN OBTAIN CIVIL JUDGMENTS
YOU CAN LEVY BANK ACCOUNTS YOU
CAN GARNISH WAGES YOU CAN PLACE
PLANES.
I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE THAT I SIT ON
WHO HAVE SUPPORTED THIS BILL
BECAUSE OF THE VERY STRONG
CONSTITUTION ARGUMENTS.
THAT TOWING VIOLATES THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT THE EIGHTH AMENDMENT
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AS I
DESCRIBED BEFORE.
IT REALLY IS TRULY
DISPROPORTIONAL.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THERE
BEEN A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WERE PROPERLY TO CITIES SUCH AS
SIMPLY ARE ARE NOT TRUE -- LET'S
TAKE THE CHANGES WERE ASKING TO
FOR THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE
THAT IS CURRENTLY ON THE STREETS
RIGHT NOW THE RULES SAYS.
SPEND THREE BIS THREE CALENDAR
DAYS IS THE A PERIOD OF TIME.
IN THE LEAGUE OF CITIES OWN
OPPOSITION LETTER.
WHAT THEY STATE IS -- THAT
PEOPLE TYPICALLY MOVE THEIR
VEHICLES WHEN THEY RECEIVE A
NOTICE SO THE SUGGESTION IS.
THERE THERE YOU KNOW NOTICES
OKAY WHICH IS WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM CITIES.
AND VEHICLES A. GET TONER OFTEN
UNMOVED IN EXCESS OF SEVENTY TWO
HOURS WHAT WE HEARD FROM MANY
CITIES IS.
CITY STILL WANT THE RIGHT TO DO
THIS BUT THEY'RE OKAY WITH A
SLIGHTLY LONGER PERIOD OF TIME
AND WITHOUT NOTICE AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR AMENDMENT DOES.
PROVIDE TO NOTICE AND WE SAY
RATHER THAN THREE CALENDAR DAYS
FIVE BUSINESS DAYS SO -- AGAIN
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
MODEST CHANGE LONG TO REALLY
ADDRESS -- SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN INTENSIFYING POVERTY
INTENSIFYING THE HOMELESSNESS
THAT WERE SEEN ON IN YOUR COUNTY
AND MY COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AND
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO THIS
AND AND A MEASURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE.
LAKE.
FOREST.
QUOTE I SOME DEMOCRATIC SHORT
STORY ABOUT MY POKING EXPERIENCE.
WHICH I DID NOT GET NOTICED
ABOUT -- MY CARD BEEN MISSING
FOR A MONTH IT WAS STOLEN I'D
REPORTED IT BEING STOLEN.
AND THEN ONE DAY I GET THIS --
TICKET I GET THE THING IN THE
MAIL THAT I'M ROOM IN ARREARS
FOR LATE PAYMENT OF A TICKET.
I CALL AND SAY HEY YOU KNOW THIS
IS STONE VEHICLE AND THEN
THEY'RE LIKE YEAH WELL IT WAS
TOWED NO MICHAEL YOU DIDN'T EVEN
NOTICE MINUTES TOAD AND THEN I
GO TO THE TOW YARD.
NO ONE'S TOLD ME YET VEHICLES IN
OFFERED TO IT'S CHRISTMAS EVE I
GO TO THE TOW YARD THE TOW YARD
SAYS WE CAN'T WAIT TO EVEN LOOK
AT YOUR VEHICLE UNTIL YOU PAY
THE TICKET.
HI BUT THIS WAS A STORM VEHICLE
THEN THEY'RE LIKE WELL YOU HAVE
TO HAVE PROOF OF THAT AND OF
COURSE ANYWAY SO.
HELLO.
DIDN'T GET THAT CAR ADDED THERE
UNTIL WELL AFTER CHRISTMAS EVE
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE TOW YARD
CLOSED.
AND THE CITY AND THE TOW YARD
WE'RE STILL GOING TO EXPECT ME
TO PAY FOR THE STORAGE OF THAT
STOLEN VEHICLE.
SO ANYWAY IT WAS A VERY
INTERESTING EXPERIENCE -- US
SUFFICE IT TO SAY I PROBABLY
HAVE EVEN STRONGER CAM K<c.cyan></c>
SPENT ANYWAY -- BUT CERTAINLY
WHAT I SAW IN GOING TO THE TOW
YARD THE MULTIPLE TIMES I HAD.
TO WHERE PEOPLE THAT LITERALLY
WORK FULLY DEPENDENT ON THEIR
CAR. FOR THEIR LIVELIHOODS AND
WERE ALL OF A SUDDEN THAT WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM AND FOR
MANY OF THEM IT WAS FOR EXACTLY
THE IT WAS EITHER A UNPAID
REGISTRATION OR AN UNPAID --
TICKET AND AS WE KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE REGISTRATION UNLIKE MOST
OTHER LARGE PAYMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE THAT WE COULD DO IN
INSTALLMENTS.
VIEW COURT WE DON'T ALLOW THAT
IN CALIFORNIA SO FINDING THAT --
INITIAL THAT. FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT BIG CHUNK OF MONEY
WHETHER IT'S THREE HUNDRED BUCKS
FIVE HUNDRED BUCKS WHATEVER THAT.
IS VERY DIFFICULT SO SOMETIMES
IT GETS DELAYED.
AND INTO IT WAS A VERY
INTERESTING EXPERIENCE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL AND I KNOW
YOU REFERENCED ARE COMMITTEE I
DON'T KNOW IF WE WERE THE ONES
WHO ASKED FOR ALL OF THOSE
LIMITS BUT THAT'S OKAY IT WENT
THROUGH TO COMMITTEES -- SO I
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LITTLE MORE --
APART ALLOWED A FEW MORE OF YOUR
CATEGORIES BUT WHATEVER -- WILL
LEAVE IT -- IT WE'VE GOT A
MOTION -- IT SAYS.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION APOLOGIES
I EAT IT.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SIR BRADFORD.
POLITICIANS NOW WE'LL DO THE
ROLL CALL. OH SORRY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COOK VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
EVERYONE HAS A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES HERE WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS.
OUR EXPERIENCES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE EXPERIENCES
OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
DON'T HAVE FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO GET THE CAR BUT TO YARD IN
THE SITUATION THAT WE JUST
DESCRIBED FAR MORE THAN THAT.
ON AVERAGE IT'S ABOUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO TWELVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS BY THE TIME YOU ADD FEES
AND AND STORAGE FEES AND AND AND
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SOMEONE -- HAVING THE ASSET THAT
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME TO TWO
TO EARN OR LOSING THEIR THEIR
CAR LOSING THEIR ABILITY TO GET
TO WORK LOSING THEIR JOB.
POTENTIALLY LOSING THEIR ONLY
FROM A SHELTER -- WE THINK THIS
IS A VERY MODEST STEP TO ADDRESS
AND WITH THAT RESPECT THE OSCARS
SUPPORT.
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
RIGHT JACKSON MITCHELL AROUND.
WELL NOW WIENER. ONE OF ONE
SECOND OKAY MORE LIKE NOW.
THANK YOU SENATORS.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER AT THE
BILL WITH STAND CALL.
AND LET'S SEE HERE WE HAD MISTER
BONTA BUT IS HE ARE YOU STILL
HERE OKAY GOOD I JUST DIDN'T SEE
ON THE FRONT ROW ANYMORE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL START WITH ITEM
ONE A. B.
.
THIRTY TWO MARTY MANAGED CARE
AND COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A. B. THIRTY TWO TODAY
AB THIRTY TWO PERHAPS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
FOR ME DOING ARE ENTERING INTO A
CONTRACT WITH A FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISON.
FACILITY BEGINNING ON JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY AM COMPLETELY
PHASE OUT THEIR USE BY. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT SB THIRTY TWO WAS
RECENTLY AMENDED. TO EXPAND THE
BAND TO THE USE OF FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES
GENERALLY.
THIS INCLUDES THOSE FOR PROFIT
DETENTION FACILITIES THAT HOUSE
IMMIGRANT SUBJECT TO CIVIL THE
TENSION.
THE REALITY IS THAT THE FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE PREVENT PRISONS
AS FOR PROFIT CORPORATIONS HAVE
A FIDUCIARY DUTY. TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR PROFITS FOR THEIR
SHAREHOLDERS AS A RESULT
MAXIMIZING PROFITS OFTEN COMES
AT THE EXPENSE OF DIRECT
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIANS SUCH
AS TREATMENT.
pEDUCATION REHABILITATION
SERVICES AND OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
HELP CREATE A HIGHER CHANCE OF
SUCCESS UPON RE ENTRY.
IN MY VIEW THE FIDUCIARY DUTY OF
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS IS IN
CONFLICT WITH THE INVESTMENT IN
REHABILITATION OF PEOPLE THE
REDUCTION OF RECIDIVISM RATES
AND THE MAINTENANCE OF SAFE AND
HEALTHY CONDITIONS OF
CONFINEMENT.
IT ALSO CONFLICTS WITH OUR
VALUES AS A STATE AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THE
WELFARE AND WELL BEING.
OF OUR RESIDENTS FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES
HAVE REPEATEDLY FAILED WITH
DOCUMENTED HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
INCLUDING INADEQUATE MEDICAL
CARE AND MEDICAL ACCESS.
AT THIS MOMENT IN HISTORY IN THE
FACE OF SHAMEFUL ABUSES WE NEED
TO TAKE STRONG ACTION TO DEFEND
OUR VALUES OF JUSTICE AND
DECENCY AND COMMON HUMANITY.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THE GOALS OF
OUR GOVERNMENT TO PROTECT THOSE
WHO LIVE IN THE STATE AND
MAXIMIZE THEIR CHANCES FOR
SUCCESS IS IN DIRECT CONFLICT
WITH THE GOALS OF THESE
CORPORATIONS.
WHICH IS TO MAKE AS MUCH MONEY
AS POSSIBLE LOCKING UP
CALIFORNIANS A. B. THIRTY TWO
WILL BEGIN TO RE DIRECT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
INVEST IN AN PRIORITIZE
EFFECTIVELY ABILITY TO PROGRAMS.
WHICH WILL MINIMIZE RECIDIVISM
RATES AND MAXIMIZE SUCCESS FOR
INMATES UPON THE RE ENTRY INTO
SOCIETY.
AND HELP INSURE SAFE AND HEALTHY
CONDITIONS OF CONFINEMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS.
WITH SB THIRTY TO RECOGNIZE THAT
OUR STATE'S COMMITMENT IS TO ITS
PEOPLE. TO ITS PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
BE LIMITED TO STATE PRISONS BUT
SHOULD STAND TO PROTECT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN WHO'S IN THE CUSTODY
OF A CORPORATION RUNNING A FOR
PROFIT DETENTION FACILITY WE
NEED TO DO MORE. TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE AND INVEST IN THEIR
SUCCESS A. B. THIRTY TWO AS
AMENDED SUCH AS DOWN THAT PATH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWO IS PROFESSOR BILL
HANG.
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO SCHOOL OF LAW AND RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION CO SPONSOR
OF AB.
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU CAN PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I WAS
ASKED TO TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THE RACE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES ONE
RELATES TO THE COMMERCE CLAUSE
IN THE OTHERS THE TAKINGS CLAUSE.
THE UNDER THE COMMERCE CLAUSE
STATES ARE PROHIBITED FROM
BURDENING COMMERCE IN WAYS LIKE
SIGNIFICANTLY SIGNIFICANTLY AND
DIRECTLY IMPEDE INTERSTATE.
COMMERCIAL TRANSACTIONS THERE'S
A PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT
PREVENTS -- THE SENDING OF
INMATES TO OUT OF STATE PRIVATE
FACILITIES AND I SUPPOSE THAT
THE RADICALLY THAT RAISES THE
COMMERCE CLAUSE BUT WHEN THE
STATE WHEN THE STATUTE REGULATES
EVEN HANDEDLY. TO EFFECTUATE A
LEGITIMATE LOCAL PUBLIC
INTERESTS OF THE NATURE THAT THE
THE SOMEONE BONTA AS OUTLINED
ITS AFFECTS ON INTERSTATE
COMMERCE ARE ONLY INCIDENTAL IT
WILL BE UP HELD.
UNLESS THE BURDEN IMPOSED ON
SUCH COMMERCE IS CLEARLY
EXCESSIVE IN RELATION TO THE
PUNITIVE LOCAL BENEFITS.
I'M I WOULD POINT OUT TO YOU
THAT.
OF AB THIRTY TWOS PROHIBITION
FROM ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT
WITH PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES
FROM OUT OF STATE.
OF DISABILITIES APPLIES TO THE
CALIFORNIA CDC ARE IT DOES NOT
APPLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY THEREFORE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD NOT
HAVE STANDING ACTUALLY TO RAISE.
OF A SO CALLED DORMANT COMMERCE
CLAUSE CLING CLANG.
SO THE COURT WILL NOT INVALIDATE.
A STATE LAW MERELY BECAUSE AN
ECONOMIST MIGHT THEORETICALLY
FIND THE THE COST OF THE STATE
LAW TO INTERSTATE COMMERCE
EXCEEDS ITS BENEFIT TO LOCAL
RESIDENTS THE COURT REQUIRES THE
PERSON.
CHALLENGING ON NON
DISCRIMINATORY STATE LAW TO
PROVIDE THAT THE BURDEN ON
COMMERCE IS GROSSLY EXCESSIVE.
SIMILARLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TAKINGS CLAUSE.
THE TAKINGS CLAUSE WILL ONLY BE.
IMPLEMENTED IF AGAIN.
IF THE GOVERNMENT REGULATES LAND
IN A WAY THAT MAKES THE LAND
TRULY VALUE LISTS AND THAT JUST
WOULDN'T HAPPEN HERE EVEN IF OFF.
OF A PRIVATE PRISON COMPANY OWN
LAND IN THE STATE AND RAISE THE
ISSUE THEY WOULD NOT BE
PROHIBITED FROM ENTERING INTO
CONTRACTS WITH DHS OR OTHER
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OFFICIALS FROM DOING BUSINESS
OUR STATE ON THE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFF ALSO OUTLINED
ISSUES RELATED TO OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THAT I
WOULD DEFER.
TO RELATED TO PREEMPTION -- AND
AND AND OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
SUPREMACY CLAUSE SO IN MY VIEW
THIS LAW IS CLEARLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AND WOULD.
WITHHOLD ANY CHALLENGE FROM
PRIVATE COMPANIES OR FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS RANCHER WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTERS
ARE ANATHEMA TO CALIFORNIA
VALUES ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT.
THE ALMOST DAILY NEWS ACCOUNTS
OF THE HORRORS WITHIN THESE
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT FACILITIES.
SB THIRTY TWO WILL BAR THE
RENEWAL OF CONTRACTS OF FOR
PROFIT PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES AND PHASE OUT THERE
USE OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
ASIDE FROM CAPITAL PUNISHMENT
FOR THE PROVISION OF LIBERTY IS
THE MOST SERIOUS OF ACTIONS
TAKEN BY OUR GOVERNMENT.
INCARCERATION IS INHERENTLY
GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTION THERE
SHOULD NEVER BE ANY TYPE OF
PRIVATIZATION.
INTHE COURTS CORRECTIONS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CIVIL ATTENTION
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT IMPRISONS
ITS RESIDENTS.
IT MUST PERFORM THIS FUNCTION
ITSELF AND SHOULD BE BARRED FROM
DELEGATING THIS FISHEL ACTION TO
LOWEST COMPETITIVE BETTER.
MUST ASK OURSELVES.
WHO SHOULD BE IN CHARGE OF
INCARCERATING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA?
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
OR MAKE PRISONS INCORPORATED.
THE US IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OR ACME CIVIL
DETENTION LLC. FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISONS DETENTION
CORPORATIONS OPERATE SOME OF THE
MOST TROUBLED AND IN HUMANE
SECURE FACILITIES IN OUR NATION.
THOUGHTS ON STAFF AND ON THE
INCARCERATED THE CURRENT RATE
40% HIGHER THAN PUBLIC
FACILITIES.
ACCORDING TO OUR OUR REPORT LAST
MONTH THE TWO MAIN PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT PRISON COMPANIES GEO
GROUP AND COURSE CIVIC SPENT
FOUR POINT.
ONE I'M SORRY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION FEDERAL LOBBYING AND
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MAY SEEM LIKE A
LOT OF MONEY IT PALES IN
COMPARISON. TO THE FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION IN REVENUES THE
COLLECTED DURING THAT SAME YEAR.
IT JUST MAKES SENSE TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S INMATES AND
BILLIONS OF EXPENDITURES OF
PUBLIC DOLLARS WITH OUR STATE
AND SERVE EXPORTING TAXPAYER
MONEY. TO OUT OF THE FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE PRISON CORPORATIONS.
THESE COMPANIES ARE TRADED ON
THE NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
AND MUST MEET THE FINANCIAL
TARGETS OTHER INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS.
THIS IS EVIDENCED IN THE QUOTE
FROM THE CEO OF BANK CORRECTIONS
CORPORATION OF AMERICA NO COURSE
OF IT.
WHEN HE STATED INMATES ARE A
COMMODITY IN OUR LINE OF WORK?
TREATING INMATES LIKE
COMMODITIES MAY PROVE BENEFICIAL
TO THE BOTTOM LINE OF THESE
CORPORATIONS.
BUT SUCH AN APPROACH DOES LITTLE
TO REHABILITATE INMATES OR
PROMOTE PUBLIC SAFETY UPON THE
RELEASE OF THEIR COMMODITIES.
BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
PRIVATE PRISON OPERATORS LOWER
THE BAR WHEN IT COMES.
TO THE CORRECTIONS PROFESSION
THEY DO SO BY PROVIDING THE
LEAST AMOUNT OF STAFF AND WORK
POSSIBLE WILL EXPAND EXPENDING
THE LEAST AMOUNT.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE THEIR
PROFITS FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS.
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CAR SERRATION.
BUT STILL THAT ALL INCARCERATION
FACILITIES ARE PRONE TO CUSTODY
RELATED ISSUES.
PUBLIC PRISONS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY OUR ELECTED IF
AND OTHER GOVERNMENTAL OFFICIALS
WE ARE NOT PERFECT.
BUT WE DO OUR BEST TO PULL THEIR
SWORN OATH TO THE PEOPLE
CONSTITUTION OF CALIFORNIA.
AB THIRTY TWO INSURERS THE
CALIFORNIA WILL NEVER AGAIN BE A
COMPLICIT GOVERNMENT PARTNER
WITH A FAILED EXPERIMENT THAT IS
THE FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISON
INDUSTRY.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELEN ROTH DELTON SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND AND SUPPORT.
THE STATE WORKERS UNION.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT APPRECIATE THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS THE INCLUSION
OF DETENTION CENTERS.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BUT ALSO
REPRESENTING THE LINES OF BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA LAST FOR YOU TO
COMMUNITY JUSTICE INSTRUCTS
APART THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MIKE HAS FROM THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL RESOURCE CENTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IN A WILLOWS FROM PANGEA LEGAL
SERVICES IN SAN FRANCISCO IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HEALING KIPLING MAJIDI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIA DEGROOT FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA AND PEACE AND JUSTICE
A GROUP AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SUSAN ARNETT FROM STOCKTON IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNINGCAROL GONZALEZ
REPRESENTING THE NORTH REGIONAL
FIRST REPRESENTING AS NORTH
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE DEMOCRATS AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE SEX
STATE -- DEMOCRATS AND I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT TO HELP LIMIT THE
EXPANSION OF CONCENTRATION CAMP
THANK YOU.
WHICH WAS WITH CHIRLA AND
SUPPORT.
MADELINE TERRA GRAIN WITH ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAT CARRILLO FOR INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA STRONG IN SUPPORT.
I'M A BETTER LESSON WE HAVE A
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION A SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT.
JULIE CHAPMAN I'M REPRESENTING
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN
INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA STATE
STRONG AND RINSES STRONG SUPPORT.
RUN THE RAILS KRAVITZ I
REPRESENT IDEA ON THAT IN THE
CAMPAIGN FOR IMMIGRANT DETENTION
REFORM WORKING.
TO BETTER CONDITIONS AT YUBA
COUNTY JAIL AND VERY VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI I'M DAN EXAMPLES A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH SACRAMENTO OCT
REPRESENT FIFTY SIX DIFFERENT
CONGREGATIONS AND SIXTY THOUSAND
FAMILIES AND SECOND AN AREA
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KIM MORE WITH YOU W. WE SHOULD
NEVER INCENTIVIZE MASS
INCARCERATION AND ATTENTION WE
ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB
BONTA.
RAINY HICKS -- CALIFORNIA GREEN
PARTY CALIFORNIA CAP GREEN PARTY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HOW MANY HAS ON CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE PEOPLE ON COMMODITIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT?
JACKIE GONZALEZ POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE REPRESENT
COMMITTEES FROM THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CENTRAL COAST AND THE BAY
AREA PROVIDING REPRESENTATION TO
INDIVIDUALS SUBJECT IT. TO ICE
ENFORCEMENT AND DETAINED IN
THESE FACILITIES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
HIS THE WATSON MEMBER OF
SACRAMENTO ACT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMES WITH ME BON
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KAELIN DEAN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDREAS TILL MAN ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE OF BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AS WELL AS THE STOCKTON
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER.
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARK TURGEON ANY A MEMBER OF
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYER SUPPORT.
KATIE FLEMING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LET IS WHEN THE PART OF THE
SACRAMENTO FAMILY UNITY
EDUCATION LEGAL NETWORK A
DEPORTATION OFFENSE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED BY THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO.
I'M IN A COLLABORATIVE OF
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- LOCAL IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS EDUCATORS AND FAMILIES
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DORIS CREWS FROM BROWN ISSUES IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
ADELA ROYAL.
FROM A UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
CENTER FROM SIERRA COLLEGE AND
SUPPORT.
SAM'S LEGAL FOR THE IRC IN
STRONG SUPPORT -- RUBBER COLOR
GREEN PARTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JESSICA GUNDERSEN CALIFORNIANS
RESTATING JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ANDRE PERRY WITH CALIFORNIANS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND
SUPPORT.
THAT WERE LITTLE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ABIGAIL ROMERO'S ZOMBIE HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THIS HOMOCORE THEN
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SURELY SHOWING US THE FORMER FOR
ALLEGIANT AND MEMBER OF A LIFE
FOR BOARDING HAYWARD STRONG
SUPPORT.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
JULIET SIMMS ON BEHALF OF
PREVENTION INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT LET'S HAVE THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION WE CAN NEVER COME
TO THE TABLE.
THIS IS WHERE YOU'RE ALLOWED --
TO LARGE.
MONEY MANAGER MEMBERS CHORUS
ALSO HEAR ME OFF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION -- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND TO BE
CLEAR OUR POSITION IS NOT BUILT
ON A JUDGMENT FOR AGAINST
PRIVATE PRISONS WERE.
AGNOSTIC ON THE NOTION BUT
RATHER OUR CONCERN IS TAKING
TOOLS OFF THE TABLE -- THAT WILL
RESULT IN EITHER PRISONER
RELEASES FROM CDC ARE OR
INCREASED PRESSURE ON COUNTY
JAILS TO HOUSE THOSE INMATES WHO
CANNOT FIT AT CVS YOUR SHIRT FOR
NOT READY FOR ANOTHER
REALIGNMENT -- THE BUFFER
BETWEEN THE POPULATION RIGHT NOW
IN THE STATE PRISONS -- AND THE
FEDERALLY ORDERED POPULATION CAP
IS LESS THAN TWO THOUSAND
THERE'S ANOTHER VALLEY FEVER
OUTBREAK IF THERE'S SOME
SITUATION THAT TAKES A PRISON
OFFLINE IF THERE'S A SPIKE IN
POPULATION.
DANGEROUS OFFENDERS WILL BE
RELEASED OR THEY'LL BE SOUGHT TO
BE HOUSED IN COUNTY JAILS
THERE'S REALLY NOT MUCH ELSE IN
WHEN IT COMES TO OPTIONS --
JAILS ARE ALREADY FACING
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FROM
HAVING DANGEROUS OFFENDERS FOR-LONGER TERMS -- AND WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL WHICH WE
THINK COULD EXACERBATE THOSE
PROBLEMS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE GUYS SENATOR WIENER.
I THINK YOU'RE IN CHARGE ON A
THANK THE AUTHOR -- RINGS FOR IT
I WAS GOING TO I ASKED ABOUT IS
A CO AUTHOR AND I LOOKED AND
RECALL THAT I AMICALE.
SO -- THIS IS -- OVERDUE I KNOW
ANYTIME YOU GO THROUGH.
A TRANSITION.
THERE IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE SOME
AWKWARDNESS BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT WE WE HAVE I I THINK.
FAR TOO MUCH CAPACITY THAT WE
BILL IN OUR EXISTING -- PRISON
SYSTEM WE NEED TO WIND DOWN --
THE PRIVATE PRISONS AND THEN OF
COURSE WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW --
WE'VE ALREADY REDUCE OUR OUR
PRISON POPULATION OVERALL AT
SOME POINT WE NEED AS THE CHAIR
HAS COMMENTED BEFORE IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CLOSE ONE
OF OUR ACTUAL CDC OUR PRISONS --
BUT THIS IS A A SINGLE COULD
START AND MOVING AWAY FROM NOT
JUST MASS INCARCERATION BUT SOME
OF THE ABUSES WE'VE SEEN -- AND
SO I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER RIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION SENATOR MORE
LOCK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MISTER CELLS HILLS -- PHILO
PLEASE THEM.
I WOULD ASSUME THAT SURE OF SIR
NOT USING.
BUT YOU'RE I GUESS WE ARE WE
GONNA USE THE TERM PRISON
FACILITIES OR OR DETENTION
FACILITIES ARE PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT MINISTRY OF FACILITIES
WHAT.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT USING THEM.
AS A COST SAVINGS WERE JUST
USING THEM AS THE TO HOUSE
PEOPLE SHOULD YOUR FACILITIES BE.
FULL IS THAT CORRECT -- CHAIR
ASM THANK YOU -- THE JAILS PIECE
OF THIS IS SO.
FEES ARE AS STATE FACILITIES
OBVIOUSLY AND THEN THEY HAVE
PRIVATE CONTRACTED FACILITIES AT
THESE FOR POPULATION MANAGEMENT.
IF YOU TAKE THAT OFF THE TABLE
AS THIS BILL DOES BEEN CCR HAS
LIMITED OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING PEOPLE IN THAT HOUSING
IN THE FACILITIES THAT CCR HAS
PRISON FACILITIES -- OR WE
EXPECT -- BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
ASKED THIS QUESTION HOW ANY OF
THE COUNTY JAIL BEDS ARE THERE
THAT THERE WILL BE A DRAW AN
ATTEMPT TO DRAW ON COUNTY JAIL
FACILITIES AND THAT'S WHAT WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IN THIS REGARD
SO.
THAT THE PRIVATE FACILITIES ARE
NOT TAKING JAIL CAPACITY -- IT'S
JUST AGAIN IT'S ONE IT'S ONE
THING THAT THE STATE HAS ON THE
TABLE AND AND THAT'S OUR CONCERN
IS THE SORT OF TRICKLE DOWN IF
YOU WILL ON HOW THAT COULD
IMPACT COUNTY JAIL FACILITIES.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH IT COSTS TO
HOUSE AN INDIVIDUAL WITH CDC ARE
FOR A YEAR.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE IF
YOU JUST DIVIDE THE TOTAL BUDGET
OF CITIES ARE BY THE NUMBER OF
INMATES THAT OUR HOUSE THAT IS
AROUND EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
MARGINAL RATE THE ACTUAL
DIFFERENCE FROM RELEASING ONE
PERSON BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE
ALL OF THE OVERHEAD IN THE YOU
DON'T LOSE THE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE BUT IT'S ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THE MARGINAL
RATE.
THEN WHAT IS IT COSTING TO USE A
PRIVATE.
FACILITY I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
RATE IS CERTAIN.
THEN -- I JUST WONDER IF MAYBE
PROVIDE WILL BALANCE AT LEAST
THE INDIVIDUAL FROM RIVERSIDE --
MENTION THAT THEY WEREN'T
PERFECT AND I WOULD JUST SAY AS
A FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR
HAVING HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
JAILS.
IN THE LAWSUIT.
AND THE CULTURE -- I WOULD SAY
THAT'S CORECT INSIDE I DON'T
KNOW IF I CAN MAKE COMPARISON.
TO A PRIVATE INSTITUTION VERSUS
A PUBLIC INSTITUTION BUT THEY'RE
BOTH.
BOTH HAVE ISSUES I WOULD WANT TO
SPEND A NIGHT EITHER.
ONE SO -- BUT I'M I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT BLOCKING A PRIVATE SECTOR
OPPORTUNITY.
SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AT THANK YOU -- WE'VE GOT A
MOTION AS BEFORE YOU CLOSE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER INAPPROPRIATE
SHINS IF YOU'D BE WILLING I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
I TEND NOT TO CO AUTHOR BILLS
THAT ARE GOING TO COME BEFORE MY
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE'RE THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE -- BUT I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING I SO IF YOU BUT YOU
MAY CLOSE WE ARE HAVING A CO
AUTHOR MET MADAM CHAIR.
OF AND THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR
THE POINTS JUST A JUST A FEW ON
A REASONED RESPONSE ONE IS IN IN
MY HUMBLE OPINION AS A
LEGISLATOR.
I THINK THAT.
SOME OPTIONS JUST SHOULD NOT BE
ON THE TABLE WHEN THE LEVEL OF
OF ABUSE AND MISTREATMENT IS AS
HIGH AS IT IS -- I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- IT'S SEEN AS AN OPTION
BUT IT'S AN OPTION WHERE.
NOT FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
PRISONS BUT IT'S AN OPTION WHERE --
WE HAVE -- CHRONICALLY CHRONIC
UNDER STAFFING.
WHERE WE HAVE AN ADEQUATE
TRAINING BUT WE HAVE INADEQUATE
PAY -- WHERE WE HAVE LACK OF
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE AND
INADEQUATE HEALTHCARE WE HAVE
ASSAULTS OF INMATES ON OTHER
INMATES IN INMATES ON STAFF?
AT MUCH HIGHER RATES -- SO I'VE
SEEN STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT THAT
THE FOR PROFIT PRIVATE DETENTION
FACILITIES COST MORE.
BUT EVEN IF THEY COST LESS.
THE THE OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIANS IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M I'M PUSHING FOR
OUR AT THE END OF THEIR USE.
THAT WE SHOULD NOT SUBJECT
CALIFORNIANS TO SUCH CONDITIONS --
WHERE THEIR HEALTH AND WELFARE
AND SAFETY IS PUT AT RISK EVERY
DAY?
WE HAVE A CHOICE AND WE CAN DO
DIFFERENTLY -- WE DID ASK ABOUT
THE CAPACITY FOR IN STATE COUNTY
AND CITY JAIL BEDS -- WITH THE
IDEA THAT IT SHOULD WE EVER NEED --
COULD ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AND WE
DON'T NOW AND WHAT WERE UNDER
THE QUARTER CAP AND WIH THINGS
I PROP 47-57.
OUR NEED FOR BEDS IS EVER
DECREASING BUT IF WE EVER NEEDED
THEM WE COULD AT ARMS LENGTH --
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH THAT AS A
COUNTY JAIL POTENTIALLY IF THE
COUNTY JAIL WANTED.
AND THEY WERE THE PAY IN THE
COMPENSATION FROM THE STATE WAS
ADEQUATE THE SECURITY LEVELS
RIGHT -- WE COULD PUT --
CALIFORNIANS IN A PUBLIC
FACILITY WHERE THERE'S OVERSIGHT
AND TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AN APPROPRIATE
TRAINING AN APPROPRIATE STAFFING --
OF COURSE TO AS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED THAT WE CAN DO BETTER
AND ALL OF OUR FACILITIES
INCLUDING OUR PUBLIC FACILITIES.
BUT BOB BETTER TO HAVE A
FACILITY WHERE YOU'RE NOT DRIVEN
BY THE MIGHTY DOLLAR.
I AND YOUR DRIVEN BY -- WHAT
LEGISLATIVE POLICY IS AND THAT
IS TO TO BE ABILITY --
CALIFORNIANS PREPARE THEM FOR A
BETTER FUTURE. FOR SEX FOR
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY -- THAT'S
WHERE WE SHOULD BE SPENDING OUR
DOLLARS -- SO I THINK THE TIME
IS CALM I I I DO BELIEVE -- THAT
THESE OF FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION FACILITIES
WAS WAS WRONG THEN AND IT'S
WRONG NOW.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
THE COURSE OF WHERE WE'RE GOING --
WITH RESPECT THAT TO THIS POLICY
IN I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT.
YOU SUPPORT AB THIRTY TWO SO WE
CAN DO JUST HAT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY -- RESPECT THE
ASTEROID BELT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION IT IS --
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHATEVER ROLL CALL SKINNER HI
SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD
[inaudible]
JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
AROUND NOW WINNER.
I WIENER AYE.
BILLS ON CALL FOR YOU HAVE A
YOUR NEXT BILL.
IS -- AB.
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE MANAGER
BECAUSE OF A WITNESSES SCHEDULE
IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE TO TAKE AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE FIRST YES.
YES WE ALL DO IT OUT OF ORDER
AND YOU CAN.
NOW PERCENT IS A YOUR NEXT BILL
AB SIX EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE AND
THEN WILL RETURN.
TO THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR A COLLEAGUES AND
STUFF ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A. B..
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE WHICH
PROMOTES GREATER PUBLIC SAFETY
IN A MORE COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
ENFORCEMENT MODEL. FOR
INDEPENDENT -- AMMUNITION
VENDORS THAT CALIFORNIA'S GUN
SHOWS CURRENT LAW OUTLINES
PUBLIC SAFETY MEASURES FOR FIRE
ARMS DEALERS WHO SELL AMMUNITION
AT GUN SHOWS IN THE STATE.
HOWEVER INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION
VENDORS DO NOT RECEIVE THE SAME
SCRUTINY AND THEY SHOULD A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE WOULD CORRECT
THIS DISCREPANCY BY REQUIRING
INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION VENDORS
TO BE LICENSED.
VENDORS ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WOULD REDUCE THE NON REGULATORY
FEE FOR THE FIREARMS
TRANSACTIONS.
FROM NINETEEN DOLLARS TO ONE
DOLLAR AND AUTHORIZED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO CHARGE
A FEE OF THIRTY ONE DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN CENTS PER FIREARMS
RELATED TRANSACTIONS SOLELY TO
COVER THE COST.
OF ITS FIRE ARMS RACE RELATED
REGULATORY AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
A COLLEAGUES THERE ARE HUNDRED
GUN SHOWS A YEAR IN CALIFORNIA
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING FIREARMS LAWS AT THESE
GUN SHOWS.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE ENSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
PERFORM THE DUTIES TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE I HAVE WITH ME
HERE TODAY ACTUALLY AIRS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SPONSOR OF AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HAVE YET TO SET.
MAYBE HER SEAT.
THANK YOU HOW WE HAVE TO GET
TRAINED ON WE LIKE.
TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
FOR OFFERING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
AT THERE ARE TWO PARTS TO THIS
BILL AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PRESENTED AT THE FIRST PORTION
IS IN RELATION TO INDEPENDENT
AMMUNITION VENDORS.
THE OP PROP SIXTY THREE FIFTY
FOR ALL ACT REQUIRED AND VENDOR
LICENSES.
FOR HAVE AMMUNITION. FOR THOSE
SELLING AMMUNITION GOING FORWARD
AFTER THE ENACTMENT HOWEVER
THERE THE GUN SHOW ACT PORTIONS
OF THE PENAL CODE WORD LEFT ON
TOUCH TO SO THIS IS.
A BIT OF A CLEAN UP FOR THOSE
SECTIONS IN ORDER TO TREAT ALL
AMIN ALL VENDORS WHO WERE
SELLING AMMUNITION EQUALLY SO
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE SELLING.
EMISSION EVEN THOUGH YOU MAY BE
IN STATE OR OUT OF STATE SO LONG
AS YOU IF YOU ARE SELLING
AMMUNITION YOU ARE SELLING
AMMUNITION YOU'RE BEING TREATED
EQUALLY UNDER THE LAW AND BE
REQUIRED. TO UNDERGO THE SAME
APPLICATION PROCESS IS THE ONLY
THING REQUIREMENTS AS ANYONE
ELSE REGARDLESS OF YOUR BROKEN
WATER OR IF YOU'RE LOCATED IN
STATE OR OUT OF STATE.
NOW THE SECOND MORE COMPLICATED
PORTION OF THE BILL IS IN
RELATION TO THE DRESS THE DRESS
HE WAS ORIGINALLY ENACTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND WAS WAS
BE FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS SINCE
THE INITIAL ENACTMENT OF THE
DRAW CITY.
THE ITEMS THAT THE FEE WAS
INTENDED TO COVER HAS GROWN TO A
LIST OF ELEVEN DIFFERENT ITEMS.
PENAL CODE SECTION TWENTY TWO TO
FIVE BE IS ONE THROUGH ELEVEN
WHAT IT IS THAT WE HAVE DONE IN
THIS BILL AS WE HAVE PULLED OUT
FOR REGULATORY ACTIVITIES AND
ITEM BE.
ELEVEN RELATING TO THE SALE
POSSESSION TRANSFER LOAN.
OF A FIRE AND PUT THAT IN THE-NEW PENAL CODE SECTION PENAL
CODE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT TWO
THREE THREE AND WE HAVE MADE
THAT SECTION THE FEE FOR THIRTY
ONE DOLLARS AND NINETEEN CENTS.
WHEREAS THE REIMBURSEMENTS
RELATED TO THE AND AGAIN THE NON
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES REMAIN IN
THE ORIGINAL PENAL CODE SECTION.
THIS IS INTENDED TO FIND AGAIN
THE PROGRAMMATIC AND THE
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUREAU FIREARMS.
NOW I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE BUT THE
THOUGHT AGAIN WE ARE.
BORROWED THE LANGUAGE FROM
TWENTY TWO TO FIVE BE ELEVEN TO
SAY.
THAT THE FEES INTENDED TO COVER
ANYTHING RELATED TO THE SALE
LOAN TRANSFER FOR POSSESSION OF
A FIREARM AND WE CLARIFIED.
THAT POSSESSION MAY INCLUDE
LAWFUL AND OR UNLAWFUL
POSSESSION WHICH MAY ENCOMPASS
THE ARMED AND PROHIBITED PERSON
SYSTEM THERE'S NOTHING EXCLUDING
APPS.
FROM BEING ADDRESSED BY THIS FEE
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT DOES
INTEND TO USE OF THIRTEEN
DOLLARS.
AND NINETEEN CENTS INCREASE FOR
THE REGULATORY ACTIVITIES IN THE
REGULATORY ACTIVITIES IN THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS ONLY.
THE APPS FOR GRAHAM PURSUANT TO
THE BUDGET AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS NOW FUNDED BY
GENERAL FUND.
SO IF WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GO AHEAD NEXT WITNESS YEAH
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA NINE EIGHT AGAINST
COMPLIANCE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- THE
SECTION RELATED TO IT AMIL
AMMUNITION SELLERS AT GUN SHOWS
IN CALIFORNIA THINGS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN TERMS OF
MAKING A CONSISTENT WITH
REQUIREMENTS A PROP SIXTY THREE
IN MAKING SURE THOSE.
AMMO SELLERS ARE LICENSED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE IN
THE REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN TERMS OF DEALERS AND
VENDORS THAT ARE -- PRESENT AND
A GUN SHOW IN CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF THE TROPHY THIS SEEMS
LIKE A DRAMATIC INCREASE UP TO
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
CENTS -- HOWEVER IF THE FEE HAD
BEEN RABIES AS I BELIEVE IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ALL ALONG
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX THAT FEE WOULD BE
TWENTY SIX DOLLARS.
I BELIEVE TODAY SO THAT INCREASE
IS NOT AS DRAMATIC.
AS IT.
APPEARS ARMED OBVIOUSLY COSTS
HAVE GONE UP SINCE THE LAST
INCREASE IN NINETEEN NOT OUT IN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR LABOR
COSTS HAVE GONE UP IN CERTAINLY
THE WORK LOAD AND THE GIRL
FIREARMS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
HAS INCREASED DRAMATICALLY NOT
ONLY THE APPS PROGRAM WHICH AS
WE DISCUSSED BEFORE HAS BEEN A
FRUSTRATION.AND A DEMAND ON GRAY ON FOR OF
RESOURCES BUT ALSO THE NUMBER
BACKGROUND CHECKS THAT HAVE TO
OCCUR.
MINOR TING GUN SHOWS -- GUN
DEALERS EVERY TIME WE PASS A NEW
LAW AND I'M PART OF THAT I'D MET --
DOJ HAS TO DO THAT TECH UPGRADES
AND CHANGE THEIR SYSTEMS SO
IMPLEMENT NEW IMPLEMENTATIONS
COSTS -- THAN HIGH NUMBER OF GUN
SALES COSTS OBVIOUSLY THERE IT'S
IS THE IMPACT ON THE RP BUT A
PERSON SYSTEM PROGRAM BUT ON THE
OTHER ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AND
OF COURSE THE MOST IMPORTANT JOB
IS TO IN THE BACKGROUND CHECK
WHICH I HAD THOUGHT THE NINETEEN
DOLLARS.
COVERED IT DOES NOT A COST
CONSIDERABLY MORE -- SO I THINK
DOJ NEWS NEEDS THE RESOURCES TO
THE JOB TO DO THE JOB THAT
CERTAINLY MY ORGANIZATION
EXPECTS THEM TO DO.
BUT ALSO ON THAT AS LEGISLATORS
AND LAWS THAT YOU'VE ENACTED --
YOU EXPECT THOSE LAWS TO BE
FULLY ENFORCED THIS IS WHERE WE
ARE I BELIEVE NOW IN CALIFORNIA
IN TERMS OF WORK ON LOS.
ENFORCEMENT AND RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE IN THE DECLINE IN OUR
FIREMAN DEATH RATE -- DECLINE
THAT LEADS THE NATION IN
REDUCING FARM INJURY AND DEATH --
BUT WE NEED RESOURCES TO DO THAT
THE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BRENT SPENCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
CALVIN QUICKLY AREAS STUDENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ALRIGHT LET'S THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION -- WILL NEED TO MAKE
ROOM AT THE TABLE
.
BUT GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD DâN RE WITH NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION ALSO HERE FOR
CALIFORNIA RIFLE ASSOCIATION
TODAY.
THIS IS A PRETTY CONFUSING BILL --
AND I'LL JUST BRIEFLY GO OVER
THE GUN SHOW WE FEEL THAT THE
GUN SHOW PORTIONS ARE
UNNECESSARY AS THE LAWS OF THE
STATE APPLY NO MATTER WHETHER
YOU'RE AT A GUN SHOW.
OR OFF SITE AND WE FEEL THAT
FALL TO CODE CLEANUP IT IT'S NOT
NECESSARY TO ENFORCEMENT TODAY --
OR OPPOSITIONS REALLY HEDGES ON
ON THE DROVES INCREASES IT'S
GOING TO DRAMATICALLY.
INCREASE AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE THE
FEES ARE PAID BY -- PEOPLE WHEN
THEY GOING TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
RIGHT NOW WHAT IS COMMONLY
REFERRED TO AS THE DRUGS HE'S
ACTUALLY MADE UP OF SEVERAL FEES
AND SO YOU HAVE -- THE NINETEEN
DOLLARS WHICH IS ACTUALLY DID
EUROCITY WHICH IS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED TO GO TOWARDS
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND REGISTRIES.
MANY OF A ONE DOLLAR FIREARM
SAFETY ACT FEE AND A FIVE DOLLAR
FIRE ARM SAFETY IN ENFORCEMENT
THE AS WELL AS OTHER PHYSICAL
CLING FSE SIX CETERA.
I'M INTO WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
IS THAT NINETEEN DOLLAR FEE IS
GETTING MOVED DOWN TO ONE DOLLAR.
AND THEY'RE LIMITING THE
APPLICATION OF THAT ONE DOLLAR
FEE.
AND THEN THERE CREATING AN
ENTIRELY NEW FEE -- WHICH WE
FEEL IS A TAX BECAUSE OF THE
BROAD APPLICATION IT CAN BE USED.
FOR AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
HAPPENING IS -- TWENTY EIGHT TO
THREE IS NOT EVEN BEING ADDRESS
WHICH STILL SEEMS TO ALLOW TO BE.
DONE DOT TO CHARGE FOURTEEN
DOLLARS AND I I WOULD LIKE SOME.
BIG THAT NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT
OF CLARIFICATION ON THAT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW A LOT OF THIS HINGES
ON AND SO I THINK THAT THAT IT
THAT SECTION NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT WHETHER.
THEY COULD STILL POTENTIALLY
CHARGE.
UNDER THAT NOW IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HISTORY OF OF DROGO'S OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME IT IT HAS
INCREASED YES.
AND IN FACT TO ROCES AMASSED A
SURPLUS IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS NOT THAT LONG AGO --
THIS FEE.
BACK IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND
WE'RE ABLE TO BORROW I THINK
AROUND TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO GO TOWARDS OUR APPS
PROGRAM.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT GUN SALES VAN
AS IS SO SEATED WITH NOW
CONCEALS WERE ABOUT HALF OF WHAT
THEY ARE TODAY.
SO PRESUMABLY DOJ'S GETTING A
WHOLE LOT MORE MONEY COMING IN
IN FACT FOR THE LAST.
UP TO SEVEN SEVEN YEARS OR SO
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN DOING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND SURE FARM
TRANSACTIONS.
SO IF WE WERE ABLE.
TO A MASS THAT KIND OF SURPLUS
WHEN FIREARM SALES WERE HALF OF
WHAT THEY ARE PRESUMABLY THEY'RE
TAKING IN ALL CLOSE TO TWICE AS
MUCH MONEY.
NOW GRANTED THE DOJ DOES HAVE
MORE CONSTRAINTS ON THEM AND
THAT IS SUBJECT SUBJECT TO
LITIGATION WHICH WAS MENTIONED --
THERE WAS CITY -- RULING THAT
SAID IT WASN'T A TAXING GENTRY
CASE IN THE LOWER COURTS BUT
THAT IS ON APPEAL AND THURS
THEY'RE THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
SINCLAIR PAIN CASES TO WHETHER
THAT'S GOING.
TO BE -- YEP HELD IN THE COURT
OF APPEALS.
BUT I THINK THAT BEFORE WE GO
ABOUT AND INCREASING THIS THIS
WEEK THIS FEATURE MANICALLY WE
NEED TO ACTUALLY LOOK AND SEE
WHAT WERE THOSE THAT MONEY'S
GOING.
THERE IS AN HONOR REQUEST A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT WAS DENIED
BECAUSE OF THAT PENDING
LITIGATION BUT BEFORE WE GO AND
WRITE THIS.
THIS MASSIVE CHECK I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO EXAMINE WHERE
THAT MONEY'S GOING.
AND NOT CONTINUE TO PUT MORE AND
MORE COST CONSTRAINTS ON GUN
OWNERS -- TO FOR THE FUN OF
FIREARMS DIVISION WITH WITH THIS
BROAD CHARGING STATUTE.
IT'S FOR THAT.
AND MANY OTHER REASONS THAT WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO A ALSO ONE
OTHER NOTE -- I KNOW THAT.
THERE WAS MENTION THAT CUT
BACKGROUND CHECKS SALES HAVE
GONE UP BUT WE'VE HEARD THAT --
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE MORE
CHECKS TODAY IT'S LESS LABOR
INTENSIVE BECAUSE WE BECOME
INCREASINGLY MORE AUTOMATED WITH
OUR RECORD SYSTEM IN THE SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN IMPROVED SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY REQUIRING MORE
PERSONNEL. TO DO MORE CHECKS SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE MANAGER MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN WAS CALIFORNIA
JUST A COUPLE OF POINTS TO FOR
THE CLERK FIVE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES.
HAS POINTED OUT ON THE THE
AMMUNITION LAWS.
DO NOT EXEMPT ANYBODY -- WHETHER
YOU'RE A GUN SHOW DEALER OR OUT
OF STATE DELIVER ANYTHING IT
INCLUDES EVERYBODY SO.
THE ADDITION OF THE OF THE
CLEANUP LANGUAGES IS NOT AS DIRE
AS YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE IT -- THAT THAT
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
ALL AMMUNITION VENDORS AT ALL
GUN SHOWS COMPLY WITH ALL OF THE
AMMUNITION -- SELLING LAWS --
AND AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND ALL OF THAT SO THAT THAT --
KIND OF PUT THAT TO REST IN OUR
OPINION.
THE THE THE SWITCHING OF THE THE
FUN FROM THE REGULAR DRAWS TO
THIS NEW CHAPTER -- OR OR NEW
NEW NEW SECTION -- IT CANNOT BE
CONSIDERED AS ANYTHING OTHER
THAN JUST THE ATTACKS I THINK
THAT THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS ADD.
UP AND DOWN THE ROAD SO FAR --
IT WAS AT FIRST -- STATED AS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE -- AND NOW IT'S
IT'S MAGICALLY NOT -- BECAUSE OF
NO CHANGES IN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT'S BEEN RAISED AND
WHAT IS BEING SPENT FOR JUST HOW
IT'S BEING CATEGORIZED IN THE IN
THE STATUTE SO -- IF IT LOOKS
LIKE A DUCK IN IT.
SOUNDS LIKE A DUCK IT'S PROBABLY
A DOCK SO IN THAT CASE WE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS -- ATTACKS
AND ONE POINT THAT MY COLLEAGUE
MADE THAT WAS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
GIVEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE DROSE FEE WAS NOT INCREASED
BY THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
BECAUSE IT ACCUMULATED.
AS MY COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SURPLUS THERE WAS NO NEED TO
RAISE THAT BE IT WAS OBVIOUS
THAT.
DURING THAT TIME OF THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WAS ALLOCATED FOR
FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS AND THE
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DRAW SPEED --
WERE BEING PAID FOR THEN AS WAS
POINTED OUT TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS WAS BORROWED FROM THE
DRAWS FUND IN ORDER TO TRY TO
GET APPS TO CATCH UP -- IT DID.
DIDN'T SUCCEED TO TO ANY -- A
GREAT EXTENT A AND THAT THAT
LOAN HAS NOT BEEN REPEATED TO
THE DRAWS FND AS FAR AS WE CAN
TELL.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR AUDITS IN
ORDER TO FIND AND VERIFY THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT FUND IS GOT.
BEAUCOUP BUCKS AND WE WE STILL
LOOK UPON THIS IS A TAX -- IT'S
PRETTY.
A SHIRT MOST ASSURED THAT --
WITH THAT IT WILL BE LITIGATED
IF THIS BILL.
DOES PASS AND IS SIGNED.
BY THE GOVERNOR SO FOR THESE
REASONS AND HOME A LOT MORE --
WITH GUNNERS CALIFORNIA'S IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MEDICS WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR KATHY
LET'S REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION AS
FAR CLUB INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTS IS COALITION CALIFORNIA
SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY AND CROSSROADS
OF THE WEST GUN SHOWS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THE RIGHT
NOW WITH YOUR NAME AND YOUR
OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SEEING.
NINE COMMENTS FOR QUESTIONS BY --
MY COLLEAGUES.
ALL RIGHT TIME TO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BEFORE US.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT I THINK THIS IS LIKE A
COMMONSENSE BILL ON THE
INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION VENDOR
COMPONENT AND A WISE USE OF OF
RESOURCES.
TO FULFILL THE REQUIREMENTS AND
THE OBLIGATIONS AND DUTIES OF
THE DOJ'S OR SPEC LAST YEAR YOUR
ITEM.
THANK YOU -- THE MOTION IS DO
YOU PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'M MORE LOCK.
LIKE NOW BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MORALE.
AROUND -- WIENER.
RIGHT BILLS ARE CALL NOW WILL GO
TO YOUR NEXT AND LAST BILL WHICH
IS -- A. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE THANK YOU
MANAGER AND COLLEAGUES THE STAFF
ONCE AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE I WANNA FIRST START BY
EXCEPT -- SAYING THAT I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK.
ON IT ON THE BILL WORKS TO
ADDRESS DATA GAPS AND IMPROVE
ACCURACY IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INFORMATION BY ENHANCING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND INCREASING DATA TRANSPARENCY
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
RECORDS DO NOT PAINT THE WHOLE
PICTURE.
MISSING INFORMATION AND
INACCURACIES IN DATA UNDERMINE
THE FAIR ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE AND OUR ABILITY AS
LAWMAKERS TO ESTABLISH BEST
PRACTICES. FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE SETS
CLEAR REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
COURTS AND HELP WITH DATA
TRANSPARENCY AND ENHANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY.
AMONG OTHER CRITERIA THE
FOLLOWING MUST BE REPORTED
PERSONS IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AND
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER DATE OF
ARREST CHARGE DISPOSITION AT
SUCH A WITH MORE ACCURATE DATA
AND MORE REGULAR AND CONSISTENT --
FREQUENCY OF REPORTING OF THAT
DATA CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT A MORE FAIR AND SAFE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND BE ABLE TO MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR STATE.
PROGRAMS IF WE ARE TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE AND FIX OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE MUST START AT
THE FOUNDATIONAL LEVEL.
IN THIS CASE WITH GOOD DATA SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE IS THE FIRST
STEP IN ENSURING WE HAVE
RELIABLE AND COMPLETE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE DATA I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK THE AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY ADD.
LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVED INJUSTICE AND MARIA
MCKEE SAM TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
ARE YOU MAY PROCEED WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M MARIA MCKEE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WHERE I SERVE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AND
ANALYTICS.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
EVIDENCE BASED DATA DRIVEN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE POLICY AND
REFORM YET OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
OUR CRIMINAL HISTORY DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS NOT BEEN
MEANING FULLY UPDATED IN ALMOST
FIFTY YEARS.
THERE ARE TWO CRITICAL ISSUES
WITH CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL
HISTORY RECORDS THAT EIGHTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE SEEKS TO
ADDRESS.
FIRST THEY LACK TIMELY
INFORMATION AND SECOND THERE
OFTEN INCOMPLETE AND MISSING
INFORMATION ALL TOGETHER.
IMAGINE ASKING AN ER DOCTOR TO
MAKE A DIAGNOSIS WITH OUT OF
DATE INCOMPLETE INFORMATION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
DECISION MAKERS ACROSS THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO DO
EVERY DAY.
THIS HAS REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR JUSTICE.
FOR EVERYTHING FROM RISK
ASSESSMENT TO GUN CONTROL TODD
TO RECORD CLEARANCE.
BAD DATA IS DEPRIVING OUR STATE
OF BETTER OUTCOMES WE ARE
OVERDUE IN ADDRESSING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE DATA GAP.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT SUCCESSFULLY
ENTER THE MODERN ERA OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE OPERATIONS AND REFORM
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THIS GAP.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE TAKES AN
ESSENTIAL STEP TOWARDS IMPROVING
THE QUALITY AND TIMELINESS OF
CRIMINAL RECORD REPORTING IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS EDWARD
LITTLE.
ON I'M REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WILL
IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
CENTRALIZATION OF CRIMINAL
HISTORY DATA TO INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY.
AND DATA DRIVEN POLICY
DEVELOPMENT.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA HAS A RAY OF
MANDATES REPORTING IS NOT DONE
CONSISTENTLY.
AND LIKE CENTRAL AS REPORTING.
AS A RESULT CRIMINAL RECORDS
SUFFER FROM PERVASIVE DATA GAPS
AND UNDERMINE THEIR ACCURACY AND
RELIABILITY INCLUDING MISSING
AND OR DELAYED ARREST AND CASE
DISPOSITION.
MISSING INFORMATION.
AND MISSING AND COMPLETE
SENTENCING.
INFORMATION.
THE SOLUTION IS AB.
THIRTY THIRTY ONE SB THIRTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE HELPS TO
MODERNIZE OUR CRIMINAL HISTORY
DATABASE BY ESTABLISHING
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL
ADDRESS DATA GAPS AND ALLOW FOR
AUTOMATED RECORDS MANAGEMENT IN
THE FUTURE.
CALIFORNIA'S DESERVE.
AS MUCH ATTENTION TO AND
RESEARCH INTO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS POSSIBLE.
A ROBUST SCHOLARLY RESEARCH
DRIVEN CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
OPERATION OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHERE AND WHEN IT
WORKS AND WHERE AND WHEN IT
FAILS.
AND HOW IT CHANGES OUTCOMES ON
AN INDIVIDUAL LEVEL.
AND ON A MASS SCALE ISCRITICAL
FOR EVEN SEEING FOR IDENTIFYING
THE PROBLEMS WE NEED TO FIX.
THESE CRITICAL EXAMINATIONS AND
CONVERSATIONS MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFER.
IMPROVING THEM MEANS ENSURING
THAT WERE HAVING AS MANY
ARGUMENTS AS POSSIBLE.
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE BELIEVES THAT A RAPE AND
BARRIERS THAT KEEP PEOPLE FROM
BEING ABLE TO STUDY OUR SYSTEM.
AND ADD TO THE CONVERSATION FOR
HAVING ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE IT
IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
IT IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND WHO HAVE A REAL LIFT
EXPERIENCE WITH THIS IN ADDITION
TO RESEARCH.
POSITION TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CRITICAL DATA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
LITTLE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DETACHMENTS FROM HAVE FOR SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DOES HE GOT -- SOME OF THE TIME
DONE CAMPAIGN AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ARIANNA PASTA WITH THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT.
ISRAEL BE ABLE TO CALIFORNIA
ALLIES VTECH COMMUNITY JUSTICE
INSTRUCTABLE.
ANGELIQUE EVANS WITH A NEW WAY
OF LIFE AND THE TIME DOWN
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG STRONG
SUPPORT.
THERE ARE STORED STATEWIDE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA SAFETY
AND JUSTICE TIE DYE CAMPAIGN IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BY ME BUT
AS A WHOLE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA PERRY WITH
CRIMES REYES FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THEY JORDAN CS A STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN MORE WITH YOU W. IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAME IN DEAN POLICY LINK IN THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS.
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A MOTION ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM AT
THE TABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUCH ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT.
FORSMAN ASSOCIATION OF RECORD
SUPERVISORS IRIX RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- I DID
TALK TO THE AUTHOR PERSONALLY --
AFTER ON COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
SIDE -- OF COURSE WE DO NOT
OPPOSE THE CONCEPT OF TIMELY AND
ACCURATE PORTING AND WE SUPPORT
THAT CONCEPT HOWEVER -- WE ARE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
RESPECT OF HAVING THAT THIRTY
DAY -- CURRENT REPORTING GOING
DOWN TO A WEAK REPORTING -- I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS NOT A FISCAL
COMMITTEE BUT THIS IS A HUGE
MANDATE ON OVER FOUR HUNDRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHO ARE NOW
GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETELY.
CHANGE AND THEIR RECORD
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM TO BE ABLE.
TO FULFILL THIS REQUIREMENT --
ALSO I WE'RE NOT UNCLEAR -- WHAT
IT DO TIONAL DATA WOULD BE
REQUIRED BY DISPEL -- CURRENTLY --
ALL THESE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED BY LAW TO
REPORT ON A MONTHLY BASIS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ON THE THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY
ON IN EXISTING LAW SO WE'RE NOT
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IT DOES
TIONAL INFORMATION WOULD BE
REQUIRED THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL --
TO UP MAKING OUT PUBLIC ANY
SAFER -- SUPPORTERS REASONS THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY -- ASK FOR ID
AND NO VOTE AND WE WILL
OBVIOUSLY -- TALK ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THIS BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARK NEVER THE
JUDICIAL COUNCILS WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THINK THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US LISTING THEIR CONCERNS
ON THE BILL AND INVITING US TO
BE PART OF THE PROCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COUNCIL IS
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL MUST
AMENDED AND FUNDED IN THE FUNDED
PIECES REALLY -- KIND OF THIS
CONCERN TO FOR CLARITY ON
WHETHER THEY MEAN FOR THE
RECORDS TO BE.
REFER THE COMMISSION REPORTED
WHEN THEY CASES FILED ORDERS
DISPOSED.
IF IF IT'S ONE IS FILE THE BE A
WORKLOAD COSTS AND WILL BE
ADDRESS THAT IN FISCAL COMMITTEE
BUT IF IT'S AT THIS POSITION
IT'S JUST THE COST UPDATE OUR
EXISTING COURT TECHNOLOGY.
AND SYSTEMS TO ACCOMMODATE FOR
THE PORTAL CARMEN'S.
WE'RE CONCERNED ALSO FOR THE
DELAYED EFFECTIVE DATE OR WHERE
THE TYPICALLY I. T. -- LARGE I.
T. CHANGES THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE NEED SOME ADDITIONAL
TIME ESPECIALLY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE -- TO GO
THROUGH THE STATE PROCESS TO GET
THEIR I. T. SYSTEM PROVED NOW
ALSO WHATEVER'S SOLUTION THEY
CHOOSE TO REPORT THE DATA THAT
WILL.
IMPACT THE COSTS THE COURTS AND
HOW WILL OF A BONFIRE SYSTEMS TO
COMPLY WITH REQUIREMENTS THE
FINAL PIECE FOR AMENDMENT AT
FOUR SEGMENTS FOR IS TECH
CLARIFY THE EXISTING REPORTING
SECTION OR UNDER PINNACLED.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE I THAT
REQUIRES THE COURTS TO REPORT
DATA EVERY THIRTY DAYS WHERE IS
THIS WITH A CART WEEKLY.
THE COURTS ARE SEEKING SOME
CLARITY ON WHICH PARTICULAR THAT
TIME FRAME WE'RE DOING OBVIOUSLY
IF IT'S ONE WE PULLED BY THE
WEEKLY BUT IF IT'S A WEEKLY IN
THIRTY DAYS THERE'S SORT OF A
CONFLICT WITH.
REPORTING TWO SETS OF
INFORMATION ON TWO SEPARATE TIME
FRAMES.
AND THE FINAL PIECE OF THE
RECEIPT AMENDMENTS ON IS -- THE
REQUIREMENT REPORT ILLICIT
MONIKERS THE COURTS DO CAPTURE
THE INDIVIDUAL'S NAME IN CASE
DATABASE BUT WE DON'T NOT
TYPICALLY IN HAVE NOT THE PAST
CAPTURED AT THE CASE ALIAS
MONIKERS FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED IN THE CASE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WERE
OPPOSED.
Q. ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU HAVE RELIED ON I DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR OBSERVING THAT SIR THANK YOU
OUT.
OF THIS BONTA WOULD YOU CAN YOU
RESPOND -- TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S.
INQUIRE USE AROUND NEEDING MORE
CLARIFICATION ABOUT THE KIND OF
DATA YOU'RE SEEKING.
YES I CAN THANK YOU I AM IN I I
APPRECIATE THAT THE POINTS THAT
WERE MADE -- BUT BUT IN THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE BEEN HAVING IN
A DIALOGUE.
THROUGH OUR COMMITTEES -- AT
DEBATE -- ONE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND ONE ANSWER MAYBE IF
YOU DON'T MIND A COUPLE OTHER --
POINT MADE BY THE OPPOSITION BUT
YOU THE A LOT OF THE DATA IS
BEING COLLECTED NOW YES -- BUT
THERE IS ADDITIONAL DATA -- AND
YOU KNOW I I CAN READ A LIST
HERE FROM THINGS LIKE THE DOCKET
NUMBER WHAT THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS A PUBLIC DEFENDER OR
COURT APPOINTED COUNSEL.
IF THERE'S A DISPOSITION OF
DEFERRED ENTRY OF JUDGMENT A LOT
OF SENTENCING DATA -- SUCH AS
THE DATE OF SENSING THE
SENTENCING TYPE LENGTH AND
CONDITION -- ANYTIME CREDIT FOR
TIME SERVED IN LIKE THAT CREDIT --
SO WE THINK THAT'LL IMPORT
INFORMATION THE MORE DATA POINTS
THE BETTER WE CAN UNDERSTAND OUR
SYSTEM BETTER WE CAN STUDY IT --
YOU KNOW THE MORE DATA THERE IS
THE MORE DATA POINTS THE MORE
THE MORE THE SAVE THE DECISIONS
IN THE FAIR THE DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM SO.
IT OUT WE ARE NOT -- SUGGESTING
THAT ALL OF WHAT WE'RE ASKING IS
IS NEW BUT SOME CRITICAL DATA
POINTS ARE.
AND I JUST SET FORTH A NUMBER OF
THEM -- THERE IS ALSO A AB
REPORTING REQUIREMENT FOR EVERY
THIRTY DAYS WE THINK THAT'S FAR
TOO LONG THE GOLD STANDARD
SHOULD BE REAL TIME WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S HARD WE'RE NOT READY TO
GET THERE YET.
SO WE FEEL AT APPROPRIATE
COMPROMISES EVERY WEEK -- WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS ALL SORTS OF THINGS
CAN HAPPEN YOU CAN.
HAVE A THAT YOU KNOW I BE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME
DISQUALIFIES YOU FROM OWNING A
HANDGUN BUT BEFORE IT SUPPORTING
GO GET A HANDGUN -- THIS SAME
WITH SOME OF THAT COULD PUT YOU
ON THE APPS PROHIBIT PERSONS
LESS IT DOESN'T GET ENTERED --
SIMILARLY.
BUT YOU KNOW YOU COULD HAVE A
REST AND ARRESTED THAT A
DISPOSITION.
AND THAT COULD PREVENT YOU FROM
GETTING A JOB OR OR OR HOUSING --
WHEN REALLY WAS DISMISSED AND
HAZARDOUS BUT THE PUT IN THE
RECORD YET?
BUT IT'S ALL SORTS OF EXAMPLES I
CAN SUGGEST YOU THAT ARE BOTH
UNFAIR AND SAFE AND THIS BILL --
WHICH IS IN A BETTER DIRECTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
OKAY THANK YOU -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- BONTA MAY I ASK YOUR
WITNESSES OR THE OR THE ACT TO
THE OPPOSING WITNESSES SOME
QUESTIONS WERE QUICK.
MR NEW BROUGH.
UP IN THE WHAT KIND OF YOU USE
THE TERM COURT TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS -- SO IS THAT A FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY WIDE.
DATABASE THAT THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH.
ALL COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
SO HE GETS TO EACH COURSE HAS A
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM VOTE
COLLEGE YEAH THAT'S CORRECT
FIFTY COURTS HAVE.
FIFTY CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
FOR THE MOST PART THERE'S ABOUT
FIVE OF FIVE TO TEN DIFFERENT
VENDORS A DIFFERENT SYSTEM THAT
THEY USE INDIVIDUALLY.
SO IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A ONE AND
MAKE IT CLEAR IT'S NOT A
CONFERENCE STATEWIDE DATABASE
THAT FINAL INFORMATION AND A IN
THE EXISTING CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS BUT THEY DO HAVE A SMALL
NUMBER OF VENDORS THAT WE
REACHED OUT TO TAKE KIND OF
UNDERSTAND THE MODIFICATION OF
THE NEED. FOR THIS BILL AND
THAT'S WHERE IT CAME TO THE
CONCERNED ABOUT WEALTH REALLY
WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR CLARITY
ON THE PROGRAM VERSION THE
COURTS TO COLLECT HER ONLY
CONCERN IS A LISA MONIKERS.
AND THEN WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
SUCH ST CLARITY ON WHETHER IT'S
DETECT CLARIFY THE EXISTING
RECORDER APARTMENT OF THE THIRTY
DAYS IF IT'S GOING TO BE MATCHED
TO THIRTY DAYS ARE WE CLEAR HOW
IT'S GONNA BE MEDICAL SORT OF
CONFORM TO AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
ONE PROPOSALS. FOR LIFE.
SO WHEN WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
KEEP THIS DATABASE UP.
ARE ARE WE TALKING ABOUT MR MR
BUT WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT IN
THE INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES OR WE'RE
LOOKING AT A STATEWIDE SYSTEM.
IT IT IT'S REPORTING FROM LOCAL
FORTUNE AGENCIES WILL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS AND AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS COURTS.
TO A STATEWIDE SYSTEM AND RIGHT
NOW.
SOME OF THE REPORTING IS DONE IN
HARD COPY.
IT'S NOT EVEN ELECTRONIC -- SO
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THAT WE
CAN HAVE A YOU KNOW A SINGLE
PLATFORM OR A PLATFORM SECOND
TALK TO EACH OTHER UNDERSTAND
EACH OTHER.
WHERE THE DATA IS -- YOU KNOW
SENT ELECTRONICALLY WORD
SEARCHABLE WE CAN -- IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC PIECES OF IT THAT THAT
ARE OF INTEREST AT THE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME -- THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL.
SIXTY MANY CLARIFY IRA CONCERNS
WOULD IT MAKE SURE SYSTEMS COULD
SPEAK TO THE DOJ SYSTEMS ARE
POOR THE DATA ACCURATELY TO MAKE
A SINGLE SEVENTY WITH DATABASE
ON TO CLARIFY THE WAS NO SINGLE
STATEWIDE DATABASE RECORDS
SYSTEMS OUTSIDE OF WHAT REPORTED
THE ATTACK.
AND AND MISS BACHELOR.
WHAT IS IT LIKE FOR YOUR
ORGANIZATION? FIFTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS -- AT WHAT
ALSO LOCAL AGENCY EACH LOCAL
AGENCY -- AT AS THE GENTLEMAN
MENTIONED -- THEY ALSO HAVE
VENDORS THAT THEY CONTRACT WITH --
AND THOSE VENDORS WILL COME AND
TO IF OBVIOUSLY IF THIS BILL
WERE TO BECOME LAW THEN DOES
WHEN VENDORS WOULD HAVE TO COME
IN.
AND JUST DO A WITH THE EXISTING
UP PROCEDURES AND ADD START.
BRAND NEW WITH CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM -- FOR THESE AGENCIES TO
BE ABLE TO MEET THIS MANDATE AND
OF COURSE THOSE ARE.
THOSE HAVE HUGE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM.
AND ALSO NOT TO MENTION -- THAT
STAFFING THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE
ON A WEEKLY BASIS TO BE ABLE --
TO MEET THIS -- MANDATE TO RIGHT
NOW YOU'RE USING HARD COPY IN
EMAILS TO GET DATA.
WELL SOME OBVIOUSLY SOME LOCAL
AGENCIES ON THAT ARE SMALLER AND
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES YES AND
THAT SOME -- ARE MUCH MORE
UPDATED AND YOU KNOW DAY ODD
THEY DO USE A MUCH MORE UPDATED
THAT -- EQUIPMENT TO BE ABLE --
TO DO REGULAR CURRENTLY PARTING.
SO WITH SO THIS IS SORT OF A
BOTTOM UP PROPOSAL.
WHY ARE WE LOOKING AT A TOP DOWN
WHAT WE CAN TO GET UNIFORM?
SO IT IS LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT I
CAN A PHONE NUMBER ON MY
CELLPHONE IT AUTOMATICALLY
STORES AND I'M DONE I DON'T HAVE
TO EMAIL SOMEONE -- YOU KNOW
JUST IT WOULD GET BETTER I. T.
LIKE I KNOW THAT THE DANGEROUS
AREA CALIFORNIA BUT WHY ARE WE
WHY ARE WE IMPOSING THIS ON
MULTIPLE VENDORS WHEN WE MIGHT
WANT TO START FROM THE TOP AND
WORK FOR DOWN A REALLY GET THE
WHOLE SYSTEM FOR ALL OF STATE.
FIXED.
A LOT OF THE DATA LIVES IN IN IN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND WITH COURT SO IT IF IT STAYS
THERE IT DOESN'T GET REPORTED TO
A CENTRAL CLARING HOUSE SO WE
NEED THE REPORTING.
THAT SO THAT IT DOES GO TO A
STATEWIDE DATABASE -- AND THAT
WE NEED -- BOMB PLATFORMS AND
TECHSYSTEMS THAT SPEAK WITH ONE
ANOTHER SO THAT THE INFORMATION
CAN BE SHARED IT DOES
UNFORTUNATELY.
REQUIRE SHARING IT THE DOJ HAD
ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION ON
ITS OWN INDEPENDENT FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN COURTS
THIS WOULD BE NECESSARY BUT THIS
IS ABOUT SHARING INFORMATION
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS SO THAT
WHEN AND AND THE DECISION ABOUT
AN INDIVIDUAL THE CAMANCHE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS MADE.
ALL DATA COMES TO BEAR ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND THE DECISION
BEING MADE IS AVAILABLE TO THE
DECISION MAKER SO THAT I CAN BE
FAIR.
AND SAFE -- WORK WE'RE
DEFINITELY -- THE ARE BILLED AS
A DETAIL ALL THAT YOU KNOW
DOESN'T IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
PLATFORM -- AND WE WANT TO
CREATE SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THAT --
THAT THERE COULD BE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT WERE AFFORDABLE AND
MADE SENSE.
BUT IF THEY DO NEED TO SPEAK
WITH ONE ANOTHER SO THAT SO THE
DATA CAN BECOME A JUSTICE DATA
CAN BE SHARED.
IT MAY MAY.
THANK YOU -- SO I WOULD SAY THAT
WHILE IT MAY SOUND IDEAL TO HAVE
ONE CENTRALIZED SYSTEM FOR
ENTIRE STATE I THINK THAT
ACTUALLY THERE IS SORT OF UP.
THERE THAT CREATES ITS OWN
ROADBLOCKS NOT ONLY WOULD IT BE
POTENTIALLY VERY EXPENSIVE --
BUT SOMETIMES HAVING ONE BIG
SYSTEM IT CAN KIND OF TRAP YOU
MORE THAN THAT INNOVATION THAT
YOU CAN THAT CAN ARISE FROM
HAVING MANY SYSTEMS.
THAT MAY SOUND BETTER TO HAVE
ONE BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
ACTUALLY IS BETTER IN THE MODERN
TECHNOLOGICAL ERA AND I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT TECHNOLOGY HAS
ADVANCED TO SUCH A DEGREE THAT
WE DON'T ALL NEED TO HAVE THE
SAME SYSTEM. FOR OUR SYSTEMS TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY -- I
THINK THAT THE EXAMPLE OF THAT
FIVE TO TEN VENDORS ACROSS THE
STATE ALL OF THOSE VENDORS ARE
ABSOLUTELY CAPABLE OF MAKING
MODIFICATIONS TO THEIR SYSTEM TO
THEN REPORT FROM EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE COUNTY COURTS
DIRECTLY TO THE STATE.
I'M IN THE SAME WOULD BE TRUE
FOR ANY RECORDS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
I'M IN A LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THERE'S BOTH FEDERAL
AND STATE WIDE INITIATIVES TO
ADVANCE THAT KIND OF THAT DATA
SHARING THAT ALLOWS US TO HAVE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ESSENTIALLY SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE AND SO WE KIND OF GET.
TO A WE GET TO THE TOP APPROACH
WHERE WE HAVE CENTRALIZED DATA
COUNTIES AND AGENCIES TO HAVE
SYSTEMS THAT WORK BETTER FOR
THEM ON THE GROUND.
GREAT THANK YOU I DOES COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WE AD A SURE IF THAT
HAD THE ABILITY TO GET TO A
DATABASE I WAS NATIONAL.
WAS KIND OF REMARKABLE WHAT YOU
COULD DO TO FIGHT CRIME YOU KNOW
THERE'S A WHITE VAN FROM
MINNESOTA.
IN FRONT OF THIS BUILDING IN A
WORLD THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THIS
BAND HAS BEEN AT THE FOLLOWING.
CRIME SCENES IN ARIZONA AND YADA
YADA.
SO THINGS CAN BE DONE RATHER
RATHER QUICKLY I THANK YOU THANK
YOU WERE TESTIFYING DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
DO I HAVE I HAVE A MOTION MADAM
CLERK WHEN WE TAKE THE ROLE
[inaudible]
THE VEHICLES.
ARE YOU I DID FEEL TO IT BUT HE
WAS BUSY ON A SPONSOR.
HE WAS TEXTING STATED NEED TO
CLOSE. TO THE RIGHT OF HIS
FATHER WAS POSSIBLE CANETTI AND
AND THE CHAIR OF COURSE -- NOT
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I I THINK -- A FAIR
AND SAFE HELLO JUSTICE SYSTEM
RELIES ON THAT SOUND ACCURATE
COMPREHENSIVE DATA THIS BILL
SEEKS. TO HAVE A PROVIDE THAT
DATA THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
MORLOCK I MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
JACKSON MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARM AROUND WIENER.
KIDS TWO ONE AND IT'S ON CALL
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER BONTA FOR
YOUR THREE BILLS HAVE A GREAT
DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
THAT TAKES US TO THE WORLD
FAMOUS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN.
KEEP UP -- WILL KEEP UP SENATOR
MITCHELL KEEP UP.
WELCOME THIS IS IT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIVE TWENTY ONE THANK YOU THE
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB FIVE TWENTY ONE TODAY.
THIS BILL WOULD TASK THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER WITH
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ON REDUCING THE
RISK.
OF FIREARM RELATED HARM AMONG
PATIENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION REPORTED THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
FIREARM RELATED DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA.
ROUGHLY HALF OF WHICH WERE
SUICIDES AND THE OTHER HALF
HOMICIDE.
FURTHERMORE AND MASS SHOOTINGS
ARE CHANGING THE CHARACTER OF
PUBLIC LIFE IN THE STATE.
JUST LAST NOVEMBER.
A MASS SHOOTING AT BORDERLINE
BAR AND GRILL IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA RESULT RESULTED IN
TWELVE DEATH.
LAST YEAR THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF PHYSICIANS PUBLISHED A
POSITION PAPER THAT RECOMMENDS A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH O
FIREARMS RELATED VIOLENCE.
IN THE PREVENTION OF FIREARM
INJURIES AND DEATHS.
WHILE MANY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
RECOGNIZE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
HELP PREVENT FIREARM RELATED
INJURY AND DEATH.
MANY CITE LACK OF KNOWLEDGE
REGARDING WHEN AND HOW TO
COUNSEL PATIENTS AS A PRINCIPAL
BARRIER TO ACTION.
THE POSITION STATEMENT ADOPTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STATED THAT EXPANDED
EDUCATION AND TRAINING ARE
NEEDED TO IMPROVE CLINICIAN
FAMILIARITY WITH THE BENEFITS
AND RISKS OF FIREARM OWNERSHIP.
SAFETY PRACTICES IN
COMMUNICATION WITH PATIENTS
ABOUT FARM VIOLENCE.
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE RECOGNIZES
THAT HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO HELP
PREVENT FIREARM RELATED HARLEM.
AND AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FIRE ON VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER IS UNIQUELY
QUALIFIED TO EQUIP THEM WITH THE
EDUCATION.
TRAINING AND RESOURCES NEEDED TO
IDENTIFY PATIENTS AT RISK FOR
SUCH HARM.
PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED
COUNSELING TO MITIGATE RISK IN
INTERVENE IN SITUATIONS OF
IMMINENT DANGER.
I WAS ABLE TO SECURE FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET FOR THIS EFFORT.
IN AB FIVE TWENTY ONE WILL
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO THE CENTER
AS TO HOW THE FUNDING SHALL BE
USED.
WITH ME TODAY IS DOCTOR DEAR AND
WHAT I MEAN THE DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO ME
GOOD MORNING AND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'LL I'LL BE BRIEF
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
MENTIONED -- THERE ARE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
DYING FROM FIREARM RELATED
INJURIES IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR ONLY TEXAS HAS MORE SUCH
DEATHS THAN.
WE DO ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AND AS
A CLINICIAN IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ME AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE COMMITTEE. TO RECOGNIZE
THAT NATION WIDE 75% OF THE
PEOPLE WHO DIE FROM GUNSHOT
WOUNDS DIE WHERE THEY ARE SHOT.
FROM MONSTER ESSENTIALLY NOT
SURVIVABLE SO OUR INTEREST IN
PREVENTION.
IS AS STRONG AND LEGITIMATE AS
IS OUR INTEREST IN PREVENTION
FOR OTHER MAJOR CAUSES OF DEATH
CANCER HEART DISEASE AND SO
FORTH.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
OUTLINED THERE'S BEEN A SURGE OF
INTEREST AMONG HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS GENERALLY IN
GETTING OFF THE SIDELINES AD
MAKING A DIFFERENCE HERE THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IN THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
FIX THAT PROBLEM.
THE SURGE OF INTEREST IS NOT
JUST A MOM HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
OUR OUR RESEARCH CENTER RECENTLY
DID A STATEWIDE SURVEY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND FOUND THAT 90% OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND 80% OF
FIREARM OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT COUNSELING OF FIREARM
OWNERS BY HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WHEN.
RISK IS ELEVATED AND ALL AND I'M
JUST WITHOUT A QUICK POINT ABOUT
ABOUT THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MENTIONED.
THERE IS AN APPROPRIATION IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET THREE POINT EIGHT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS.
THE MEDICAL CARE COSTS ALONE OF
FIREARM INJURIES IN CALIFORNIA
WERE RECENTLY ESTIMATED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT IT HAD ONE HUNDRED
TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
PER YEAR AND THE MEDICAL CARE
COSTS ARE A VERY SMALL PORTION
OF THE COST OF FIREARM VIOLENCE
GENERALLY.
IF WE AGGREGATE THE ENTIRE COST
THE COST PER DEBT FROM FIREARM
VIOLENCE OR BETWEEN FOUR AND
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A PIECE.
PREVENTING A SMALL NUMBER OF
THESE DEATHS WERE NON FATAL
INJURIES WOULD ENTIRELY OFFSET
THE COST OF THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GORDON DOWDY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION NATIONAL ORGANIZATION
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
POLICY COMMITTEE.
IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS TO MAD REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF OF BRADY
CALIFORNIA UNITED AGAINST GUN
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
AND ALSO THE LOCAL CHAPTERS OF
BRADY IN SACRAMENTO AND THE
YELLOW COUNTY.
HELLO I'M DR GLENNA TRICHET ON
BEHALF OF THIS YEAR ZERO
SACRAMENTO VALLEY MEDICAL
SOCIETY REPRESENTING OF
PHYSICIANS IN SACRAMENTO YOLO
AND EL DORADO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MAKING ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANGELA MAC ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC%
HEALTH ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HELLO COULDBE RESURGENT
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT. THIRTY ONE
REPRESENTING AMERICAN KENNY
PEDIATRICS AND SUPPORT.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THAT BRINGS S BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR EVEN MAYBE FROM THE
CHAIR FOR SELF.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IF
I COULD -- SINCE THE GET THE
WORLD FAMOUS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN HERE IN THE ROOM.
I JUST IT JUST CURIOUS WHAT THE
CORE MISSION OF THE UC FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER IS.
I'LL DEFER TO THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CORE MISSION I KNOW WHAT MY
BILL WANTS TO DO BUT I CAN'T
TALK TO THE CORE MISSION OF THE
CENTER -- TECHNICIAN IS ACTUALLY
OUTLINED IN IN STATUTE IN THE
THERE ARE PROVISIONS OF THE
PENAL CODE WHICH OUTLINED AT THE
PRIMARY MISSION OF THE CENTER IS
CONFUSED TO CONDUCT RESEARCH
WHICH IS.
CAN BE BASIC CORE EPIDEMIOLOGIC
WERE TRANSLATIONAL WE ALSO TRAIN
NEW INVESTIGATORS IN THE CONDUCT
OF THIS.
RESEARCH WE WORK ACTIVELY TO GET
THE RESULTS OF OUR RESEARCH OUT
TO THE PUBLIC WE ARE A PUBLIC
FACING INSTITUTION OUR MISSION.
IS TO IDENTIFY EVIDENCE AND AND
BRING IT FORWARD WE WORK ON A
REGULAR BASIS WITH POLICY MAKERS
BECAUSE WE HOPE THAT THE
EVIDENCE WE UNCOVER WILL HELP
INFORM THE POLICY MAKING PROCESS.
SO YOU DIDN'T INCLUDE TRAINING
AND EDUCATION SERVICES I AGAIN
I'M SORRY BUT JUSTICE BESET
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS OR GROUPS
SHOULDN'T.
TALK ABOUT GOING OUT TO MEDICAL.
PROFESSIONALS I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS REALLY APART EVERY
DRIFTING A LITTLE OR WE
EXPANDING.
GET A TAKE JUST A SECOND TO
PERHAPS AT STAGE -- OUR ORIGINAL
TRAINING AND EDUCATION MISSION
HAD TO DO WITH TRAINING AND
EDUCATING RESEARCHERS.
THAT LANGUAGE WAS DRAFTED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND IN THE
INTERVENING TIME IT'S IT'S
BECOME CLEAR THAT THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL ELEMENT TO WHAT I
WOULD SEE AS PART OF OUR CORE
MISSION.
THAT WOULD BE VERY VALUABLE TO
THE STATE AND DIRECTLY TO THE
NATION AND ITS.
TO SPECIFY THETERMS OF THAT
ADDITIONAL ELEMENT THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN DRAFTED THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEFORE YOU SO
THIS I DO NOT SEE THIS IS
MISSION CREEP TO BE HONEST.
I SEE THIS IS SOMETHING REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE DIDN'T SPECIFY
THE FIRST TIME.
AND SO WHEN I'M THINKING OF
MEDICAL PRACTITIONERS --
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
COME TO MIND AS IT RELATES TO
MAYBE.
YOU KNOW MENTAL ILLNESS YES AND
FIREARMS YES IN INDIA BUT I'M
JUST WONDERING WHY THE ENTIRE
SPECTRUM SO I USE HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO LIBERALLY I AM
A CLINICIAN I DIE.
MY LAST SHIFT IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WAS LAST SATURDAY I
TOOK CARE OF SOMEBODY WHO IS
THERE FOR SICK CALL I HAVE --
GUNSHOT WOUND -- SO I I KNOW AS
A CLINICIAN THAT A WIDE ARRAY OF
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HAVE A ROLE
TO PLAY HERE -- PHYSICIANS TO OF
ALL SORTS IN PRIMARY CARE -- IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS IN TRAUMA
SURGEONS BUT BUT ABSOLUTELY
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
ALTHOUGH TO BE HONEST.
THEIR ROLE IS PROBABLY LESS THAN
IT COM IT IS COMMONLY THOUGHT TO
BE MENTAL ILLNESS PLAYS A MUCH
SMALLER ROLE IN FIREARM VIOLENCE
THEN IT IS.
COMMONLY THOUGHT TO DO -- AND
ALONG WITH IF IF I CAN REFER TO
THEM THIS WY AND THAT SORT OF
TOP OF THE PYRAMID PROFESSIONALS
THERE ARE NURSES AND SOCIAL
SERVICE.
IN THE SOCIAL SERVICE WORKERS WE
HOPE HEARD FROM A REPRESENTATIVE
OF OF SOCIAL WORKERS JUST A
MOMENT AGO.
PART OF WHAT MAKES THIS EXCITING
FOR US FRANKLY IS THERE ARE ALL
SORTS OF HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WHO WORK OR NARAL WHO WORK
ALREADY IS A TEAM SAYING WE WANT
TO WE WANT A PIECE OF THIS
PROBLEM WE WANT TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO THE
INTENT HERE IS TO FIX THAT PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
YOU'RE WELCOME BACK -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE'VE
ALREADY GOTTEN THE ALL THE
WITNESSES [inaudible]
OKAY -- APPRECIATE THE BILL --
WE KNOW THAT.
THE LARGEST PERCENT OF DEATHS BY --
WITH.
FIRE ARMS IS SUICIDE.
SO CLEARLY THERE'S A CLEAR.
MEDICAL CONNECTION THERE BUT I
THINK THERE'S ADDITIONALLY --
WHETHER IT'S A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
INCIDENTS OR OTHER TYPES OF INTO
INCIDENTS -- AFTER WOMEN YOU
REFERENCE.
THE ISSUE OF OF HAVING BEEN IN
THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
THERE ARE SOME GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS THAT
LITERALLY THEY'RE NOT MEDICAL
BUT THEY LITERALLY.
WORK IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM AREA
BECAUSE ANOTHER LARGE FACTOR.
IN GUN VIOLENCE DEATHS ARE
REVENGE SHOOTINGS AND SO VERY
CALMLY.
WHEN A VICTIM OF A GUNSHOT WOUND
COMES THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND
THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS ARE
THERE?
THE THEIR MEDIA IT'S OUR DESIRE
IS GET BACK AT WEBER -- WHOEVER
WHOEVER'S AFFILIATED WITH THE
PERSON THAT MAY HAVE SHOT THEIR
LOVED.
ONE AND DASH SO THERE'S BEEN
INTERVENTIONS -- THAT HAVE SOME
RESEARCH INDICATES VERY VERY
EFFECTIVE TO TRY.
TO BRING DOWN THAT THOSE
REACTIONS AND SUPPORT AND ASSIST
THE VICTIM IN THE FAMILY MEMBER
SO THAT.
THERE ISN'T THEN IMMEDIATELY A
REVENGE SHOOTING SO.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE TRAINING
YOU'RE LOOKING OUT WOULD INCLUDE
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT CERTAINLY
THERE SIR THE VERY LIMITED
RESEARCH I'VE SHOWN INDICATES
THAT IT'S PRETTY EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION.
ANYWAY YEAH MY UNDERSTANDING IS
IT A WOOD AND THE OTHER OTHER
EXAMPLES ARE YOU KNOW IF IF YEAH
COUPLE COMES IN IN THE GONNA
START A FAMILY.
AND IT IS GOING TO KIDS IN THE
HOUSE TO TALK ABOUT HOW BEST TO
IT ONE OF THE BEST PRACTICES FOR
KEEPING YOUR FIREARMS SAFE -- IN
A HOUSE WITH YOUNG KIDS AND AND
HOW YOU KNOW THAT MIGHT CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC DYNAMICS AT HOME AND
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
BEST.
PRACTICES IN PLACE BECAUSE WE
READ STORIES TOO OFTEN ABOUT.
SH BABIES GETTING ACTUALLY YOUNG
CHILDREN GETTING ACCESS TO
HANDGUNS THAT THEY SHOULDN'T OF
AND AND SHOOTING THEMSELVES OR
OTHERS -- SO THERE'S ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT EXAMPLES WHERE THIS
IS AN ABOUT TAKING PEOPLE'S GUNS
AWAY IT'S JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THEY UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENT RISKS AS LIKE CHANGES --
AND USING BEST PRACTICES IN THE
HOUSE TO TO TRY TO MITIGATE AS
MUCH RISK AS POSSIBLE.
RIGHT SO YOU MAY CLOSE THAT IS
IT OKAY DON.
I'M LET ME SEE IF THERE'S A
MOTION.
WE MAY HAVE TO WAIT ON A MOTION
GOTCHA -- BUT DON'T WORRY MY
COLLEAGUES WILL WRITE.
HAS BOUNDARIES RIGHT MY
COLLEAGUES WILL RETURN.
AND WE CAN ENTERTAIN THAT MOTION.
I THINK THAT WAS YOUR ONLY BILL
YES RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU SIR MY
SENATORS CERTAINLY.
I WILL GO TO ITEM SEVEN NOW WHAT
YOU BE SIX FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MORNING.
MORNING MAN CHAIRED.
COLLEAGUES THE ONE PRESENT TO
YOU AB.
SIX FIFTY SIX THE I SHOULD START
BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AN EXCELLENT JOB WITH
THE ANALYSIS AND SO I WILL BE
BRIEF THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS
TO ESTABLISH.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SAFE
COMMUNITIES UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION STRATEGY AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE AT RISK. FOR INVOLVEMENT IN
VIOLENCE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
HERE TODAY SPREAD VIA WITH ME BY
NICOLE BROWN WITH URBAN PEACE
INSTITUTE THAT WILL NOT TESTIFY.
YES PLEASE GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON ON THE WHOLE NUMBERS
AND AND IT PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICOLE
BROWN AND I'M A SENIOR POLICY
ASSOCIATE AT THE URBAN.
INSTITUTE ALSO KNOWN AS UPI AND
WE'RE BASED IN LOS ANGELES. FOR
OVER TEN YEARS YOU PI HAS WORKED
TO IMPLEMENT VIOLENCE REDUCTION
STRATEGIES AND PROMOTE COMMUNITY
HEALTH BY TRANSFORMING SYSTEMS
COMMUNITIES AN INDIVIDUAL LIVES
TO ACHIEVE SAFETY.
WE HELPED TRANSFORM HOW THE CITY
OF LA ADDRESS VIOLENCE BY
HELPING TO ESTABLISH A PUBLIC
INVESTMENT OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR TO BE SPENT IN
NEIGHBORHOODS MOST IMPACTED BY
VIOLENCE.
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE OF GANG
REDUCTION AND YOUTH DEVELOPMENT.
ACCORDING TO STRATEGY AND
TARGETED FUNDING HAVE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE VIOLENCE IN
OUR CITY.
TAKING LESSONS LEARNED FROM LA
U. P. I. PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO REDUCE STREET
VIOLENCE AND CITIES SUCH AS
OAKLAND SACRAMENTO STOCKTON AND
CHICAGO.
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF AB SIX
FIFTY SIX TO ESTABLISH AN OFFICE
OF HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW FOR A
COORDINATED STATEWIDE VISION AND
STRATEGY TO REDUCE.
VIOLENCE.
THIS OFFICE WILL PROMOTE BEST
PRACTICES FOR REDUCING VIOLENCE
THROUGH TARGETED INVESTMENT IN
HEIGHT AND HOUSE NEED AREAS.
WILL HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER THROUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT
CAPACITY BUILDING AND
COORDINATION.
AND IT WILL CONSOLIDATE FUNDING
AND PROGRAMMING TO BEST TARGET
EFFORTS WITH GUIDANCE FROM
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND AND EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTHY AND SEE
COMMUNITIES WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL CAPACITY IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR REDUCING
VIOLENCE IN ALIFORNIA.
BY LEVERAGING EXISTING
INITIATIVES AND ADMINISTERING
FUNDING TO MAKE THE MAXIMUMIMPACT.
FURTHERMORE IT WAS JOHN PORTENT
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS VARIOUS TYPES OF
VIOLENCE.
IN THE STREETS AND OUR SCHOOLS
FOR IN OUR HOMES -- THE OFFICE
WILL HELP US IN LA STRENGTHENED
CURRENT BROWN'S PREVENTION
EFFORTS IN OUR CITY AND COUNTY
AND CORPORATE BEST PRACTICES FOR
ADDRESSING OTHER FORMS OF
VIOLENCE SUCH AS DOMESTIC AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
WE HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND HOW
STRATEGIC COORDINATED FUNDING
HAS MADE LA SAFER FOR ALL AND
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE STATE TO INVEST IN WHAT
WORKS.
WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE HELP BUILD
HEALTHIER AND STRONGER
COMMUNITIES BY VOTING YES ON
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS A GOOD
MORNING WHEN IS THE US MY NAME'S
ISRAEL VIA I'M THE POP
PROGRAMMING PARTY CORNER WITH ME
FIVE MORE OF AN INDIVIDUAL
LEADERSHIP FOR PUBLIC
ADVANCEMENT.
WHICH IS A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION SALINAS CALIFORNIA --
I GREW UP IN THE SALINAS OFTEN
ALL WE HAD WAS A SUPPORT WE
PROVIDED EACH OTHER.
THE COMMUNITY CONDITIONS POVERTY
VIOLENCE AND DESPAIR THAT GOES
ALONG WITH THAT WAS OVERWHELMING
FOR ME AS A CHILD.
AT AN EARLY AGE I SUCCUMB TO THE
PRESSURES OF VIOLENCE AS A
RESULT I WAS INCARCERATED ON AND
OFF FOR EIGHTEEN OF MY FORTY ONE
YEARS.
THERE WAS ALWAYS A WELL RESOURCE
AND COORDINATOR APPROACH TO MY
PUNISHMENT INCARCERATION BUT
NEVER FOR HEALING INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION.
IMAGINE IF DEAF DECADES AGO
CALIFORNIA HAD INVESTED IN A
COORDINATED APPROACH THAT
FOCUSED ON PREVENTING VIOLENCE.
HEALING UNDERLYING TRAUMA AND
SUPPORT OF INTERVENTIONS FOR
PEOPLE CAUSING HARM.
THAT WAS NOT THE DECISION THAT
CALIFORNIA MADE BACK THEN BUT IS
A DECISION WE CAN MAKE TODAY.
THE MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF
MULTI GENERATIONAL VIOLENCE AND
TRAUMA I LEARNED THAT THE CYCLES
OF VIOLENCE CAN BE EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSED THE COMMUNITY BASE
PREVENTIONS.
AT ME BUT WE WORK WITH YOU YOUTH
AND ADULT TO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS
OF VIOLENCE AND SOME WHO HAVE
CAUSED HARM.
AND WE USE CULTURE ROOTED
PRACTICES TO FOSTER HEALING AND
INVEST IN THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
STRENGTH.
THIS APPROACH IS WORKING IN
SALINAS IT'S ALSO WORKING
ORIGINAL WERE HOMICIDE IS DOWN
BY 50% BECAUSE OF COMMUNITY
BASED VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
IT'S WORKING ALL THE PLACES WERE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY VIOLENCE.
HAVE STEPPED UP TO BUILD SAFER
NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE KNOW HOW TO BUILD REAL SAFETY
WE'RE DOING IT EVERY DAY BUT
THESE EFFORTS ARE NOT CORE NEED
ACROSS THE STATE AND THEY ARE
NOT PROPERLY FUNDED.
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE PLAN AND
HOME PROVIDERS PREVENTION
HEALING OUR EFFORTS ARE LIMITED
AND ISOLATED AND WE'RE NT ABLE
TO BILL TOGETHER AND COORDINATED
FOR EVEN GREATER IMPACT.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AN OFFICE OF
HELPING SAVE COMMUNITIES BY
HAVING A DEDICATED OFFICE WE CAN
BRING TOGETHER PEOPLE PRACTICES
AND RESOURCES UNDER ONE ROOF AND
FINALLY CREATE THE STATEWIDE
PLAN AND VISION.
THAT WILL ALLOW HEALTH AND
SAFETY TO FLOURISH.
CALIFORNIA'S NEW SURGEON GENERAL
PEDIATRICIAN DOCTOR NADINE BURKE
CARROT STATES UNLESS YOU FIX THE
TRAUMA THE WHOLE IN THE SOUL.
WHERE WOUND STARTED HERE WORKING
AT THE WRONG THING MY REQUEST OR
TWO THAT YOU LISTEN WITH YOUR
HEART AND CONSIDER THESE
COMMUNITIES MOST VULNERABLE TO
VIOLENCE?
I RESPECTFULLY AND HUMBLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CAITLYN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
I DO ROMERO'S ZOMBIE HAVE THE
LET THE NO COLLISION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA ARE PROUD COSPONSORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF ME
BOND STRONG SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
REAR DECK THREE A DEGROOT FROM
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
KIM LINDBERG FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR DESIGNED THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW STRONG
SUPPORT.
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TEND TO VESTED
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
JULIET SIMMS ON BEHALF OF
PREVENTION INSTITUTE A CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE ANGEL MAC ON BEHALF OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES OF CO
SPONSOR IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
PERRANCE TOUR WITH TIME DO A
CAMPAIGN STRONG SUPPORT.
BROWN'S WIFE WHERE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND JULIE GIVENS WITH THE NEW
WAY LIVE STRONG SUPPORT.
HIS INTERNET FOR SOMEONE KEEP
PEACE AND JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
JUST FINISHED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT.
MILLER LIKE IT'S UP IN YOU JUST
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT.
ROSARIO THOMAS WITH THE JUST
COLLISION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN MARLING FINANCES DINNERS
DISTURBED IN SUPPORT -- BREACHES
COALITION IN LA STRONG SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
LUCKY DAY [inaudible]
FOR I'M.
CENTER MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SOME
NUMBER -- SEE I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS -- WHAT'S THE VISION FOR
STAFFING AND FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
AND I KNOW THIS IS NOT
APPROPRIATIONS BUGS CURIOUS.
ABOUT WHAT YOU ANTICIPATE COST
MIGHT BE.
VISIT IN THE STAFF REPORT AND I
DON'T BELIEVE IS FOR THE COST.
IS -- IN THE ANALYSIS -- I DON'T
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE ANALYSIS
HOWEVER DOES HAVE A BREAKDOWN OF
WHAT -- THE OFFICE -- FRAMEWORK
WOULD LOOK LIKE AS WELL AS AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT'S ON
PAGE -- FARM ARMY ON THE RUN.
AROUND YOUR HEAD.
I'M ON THE WRONG TAP I'M LOOKING
IN THE WRONG REPORT I APOLOGIZE.
THIS IS A STAFF TEAM.
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE BUT IT
DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY DETAILS.
FIVE TEN TWENTY HUNDREDS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT HIGHER NAY --
STAFF TEAM PUT THAT [inaudible]
OF DIRECTOR.
AND AN ADVISER.
AND THEN WE HAVE A BREAK DOWN.
OF AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE MADE UP
OF OF VARIOUS -- COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS -- FROM
UNIVERSITIES A MEMBERS OF THE
PART IN A PUBLIC HEALTH --
INEQUITY.
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL --
NUMBER OF OUR LAST -- PRISONERS --
SEVEN MEMBER BERMAN WAS ABLE TO
GET FUNDING IN THE BUDGET FOR
HIS PROPOSAL WERE YOU ABLE TO DO
THE SAME.
NOT SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS
PROPOSAL HOWEVER THERE IS MONEY
DEDICATED FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS.
AND SO THEN WHY HASN'T THE THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND JUST TURNED IT ON ITS
OWN.
THE ACTUAL -- THIS TYPE OF UP
WORK IS ALREADY TAKING PLACE
UNDER THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
AND I FIGURE ANALYSIS --
HIGHLIGHTS THAT.
SPECIFICALLY THE CALVET PROGRAM
GROWLED VIOLENCE WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE THROUGH THE LENS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND UNDER THE US SURGEON GENERAL
WE BELIEVE -- AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS WHERE AT
LEAST TYPES OF COORDINATED
EFFORTS ARE TO BE A TAKING PLACE.
SO -- EMERGENCY OFFICE --
ALREADY DOES.
SOME OF THIS WORK.
BUT IT ISN'T A FULLY COORDINATED.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS CONSOLIDATED.
EFFORT TAKES PLACE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CERTAINLY -- OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
ON IS THERE A MOTION FOR AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA'S BILL.
THANK YOU -- BEFORE I ASK YOU TO
CLOSE THE THE MANY OF THE
SUCCESSES THAT WERE CITED.
ARM LIKE CITY OF RICHMOND OTHERS
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING FROM OUR
ON CALVET PROGRAM AND WE DID IN
THIS LAST BUDGET.
INCREASE THE FUNDING AVAILABLE
TO CALVET.
BUT I THINK IN THERE WITH COULD
BE AN ARGUMENT THAT THIS WE HAVE
AN EXISTING PROGRAM SO I CREATE
ANOTHER -- ONE I'M SUPPORT OF
YOUR BILL BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
WE HAVE -- COME TO UNDERSTAND
WHICH WERE CLEARLY IS THAT GUN
VIOLENCE IS NOT PRIMARILY A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ISSUE.
IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
NOT SOLELY IN ONLY BUT AND THE
MORE THAT WE CAN APPROACH IT
FROM THAT PUBLIC HEALTH POINT OF
VIEW.
PERHAPS WE CAN GET AT EITHER THE
ROUTE OR YOU KNOW [inaudible]
HELP THE START TURNING AROUND.
THE STATISTICS -- IN WAYS THAT
JUST GOING THROUGH THE LENS OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE MIGHT NOT KNOW
WHILE THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IS NOT NECESSARILY A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICE -- IT IS
MUCH MORE IT'S JUST ORIENTED AND
NOT THAT THE FUNDING THAT WE'VE
PROVIDED UNDER CALVET THIS
NECESSARILY BEEN ORIENTED THIS
WAY BUT IS MORE ORIENTED TOWARDS.
THE REACTION TO A THING AFTER IT
OCCURS OR VERSUS THAT PREVENTION
SO.
I THINK THIS IS A PUTTING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
IS MUCH MORE REFLECTIVE OF OUR
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE ROOT
CAUSES OF GUN VIOLENCE AND WILL
I THINK IMPROVE OUR ABILITIES TO
PREVENT IT.
AND WE'LL JUST HAVE TO SEE
WHETHER A REST THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION AGREES OR
NOT.
SO -- WE HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I'LL TAKE THAT AS
OF MY MY CLOSING COMMENTS
MANAGER THANK YOU -- LET'S DO A
ROLL CALL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS SKINNER.
HI SKINNER I'M MORE LOCK.
BRADFORD ON BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL.
MORALE NO AROUND THAT WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
BILLS ON CALL -- THANKS SO MUCH.
THEN WE WILL GO TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AND I NOTICED THAT
YOU HAVE TO ITEM SO WE WILL.
FOLLOW ITEM EIGHT WITH -- NO NO
I THINK YOU PULLED TO ONE OF
THOSE NO OKAY NO SORRY I'M
GETTING GIPSON GRAYSON MIXED UP
APOLOGIES -- SO WE'LL START WITH
AB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN AND THEN
NOW IT'S PURELY THE NAMES ON A-PIECE OF PAPER.
DON'T WORRY IT'S NOT THE IT'S
IT'S MY DYSLEXIA VERSES ANYWAY --
AND THEN WILL FOLLOW IT WITH
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
CENTERS THANK YOU ALLOW ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL -- SEVEN
EIGHT SEVEN WHICH WOULD -- HELP
PROVIDE INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
COUNTY JAILS INFORMATION ON
VOTER REGISTRATION AND VOTER
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
INCARCERATION INCARCERATE OVER --
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN ITS --
JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF OF THEM
HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED OR ARE
ON FENTON'S AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE ON SENTENCE.
THIS IS A LARGE COMMUNITY THAT
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM CIVIC PARTICIPATION DUE TO
MISS INFORMATION OR THE LACK OF
INFORMATION MANY ARE BEHIND BARS
NOT KNOWING THEY CAN.
AND HAVE THE RIGHT TO REGISTER
TO VOTE -- CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
STATE AND LOCAL.
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITIES TO
ASSIST IN VOTER REGISTRATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OF AGE AND
ARE NOT SERVING A FELONY
SENTENCE.
THIS BILL WOULD AN ACT SIMILAR
PROVISIONS OF FOR ADULTS BY
REQUIRING EACH OF US EACH COUNTY
JAIL TO ALLOW AT LEAST AT LEAST
ONE ORGANIZATION TO PROVIDE.
A VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAM IN
COUNTY JAILS THE PROGRAMS WOULD
INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT VOTER
RIGHTS AND VOTER REGISTRATION
AND ASSISTING IN ASSISTING WITH
RETURNING VOTER CARDS TO THE
ELECTION OFFICIAL WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY.
IS A REPRESENTATIVE FROM NEW WAY
OF LIFE AS WELL AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ACLU
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BERNICE
STONECIPHER ENEMA VOTING RIGHTS
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA THE ACLU IS PLEASED
TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
WHICH WOULD REDUCE BARRIERS TO
DEMOCRACY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
JAIL BUT NONETHELESS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE.
DISPROPORTIONATELY THESE ARE
VOTERS OF COLOR.
IN RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING A MORE INCLUSIVE
ELECTORATE.
AND THANKS TO SOME OF THESE
REFORMS TODAY PRACTICALLY ALL
ADULT CITIZENS AND CALIFORNIA'S
JAILS PRE TRIAL AND SENTENCED TO
LIKE HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
NONETHELESS THESE INDIVIDUALS
FACING UNIQUE OBSTACLES WHEN
THEY REACH THE BOUT THE BALLOT
BOX WE WERE RECENTLY CONTACTED
BY MAN AND LOCAL JAIL FOR
INSTANCE WAS DISENFRANCHISED IN
THE LAST ELECTION BECAUSE HE WAS
DENIED ACCESS TO A PAN.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAILS
OVERCOME THESE BURDENS EVER
CRYING SHARES TO ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONDUCT IN
PERSON VOTER REGISTRATION
ACTIVITIES.
THIS WILL ADD VOTER REGISTRATION
TO THE ALREADY DIVERSE RANGE OF
PROGRAMMING THAT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDING COUNTY
JAILS FROM LEGAL EDUCATION AND
SOBRIETY SUPPORT TO RELIGIOUS
SERVICES AND LEGAL AID.
AS WITH THESE OTHER VOLUNTEER
PROGRAM SHERIFF'S RETAIN THE
RIGHT TO DENY CLEARANCE TO
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO THEY BELIEVE PRESENT A
REASONABLE BASIS HAVE A REGIONAL
BASIS TO BELIEVE PERCENT OF REST
TO THE SECURITY THE INSTITUTION?
AND AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
PROVIDE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE
HOW VOTER EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND
OUTREACH PROGRAMS WILL LOOK IN
THEIR JAILS.
AND LOS ANGELES FOR INSTANCE
THERE JR JAIL WAITING PROGRAMS --
HAVE A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
SHERIFF'S COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE REGISTRAR
VOTERS WERE TRAINED VOLUNTEERS
PROVIDE SUPER VOTER SUPER AS
BETTER REGISTRATION AND JAIL DAY
ROOMS.
DISTRIBUTE BALLOTS TRACKED BY
INMATE BOOKING NUMBERS AND THEN
COMPLETE RETURN COMPLETED
BALLOTS ON ELECTION DAY.
AND THESE PARTNERSHIPS WORK IN
LA -- JUST IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ORGANIZATIONS HELP TO
REGISTER EVERY THREE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND RETURN OVER
THOUSAND COMPLETED BALLOTS ON
ELECTION DAY.
WE ASK YOU TO HELP INSURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT.
DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE OF
PRACTICAL BERIA'S PRESENT BUT
PRESENTED BY JAILS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT ON HELLO MY
NAME IS ANGELIQUE IN -- I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
OUR ORGANIZATION IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN
AND I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY.
AB SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN ADDS MODEST
STANDARDS TO EXISTING LAW.
WHICH CURRENTLY ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE VOTER
EDUCATION IN THE JAIL TO INSURE
FAIRNESS.
CREATE CONSISTENCY AROUND THE
PRICES AND PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY.
THE BILL ALSO STREAMLINES DATA
SHARING REGARDING VOTER
ELIGIBILITY WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE.
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY A NEW WAY
OF LIFE HAS PIONEERED THE WORK
ORGANIZATIONS CONDUCTING VOTER
REGISTRATION AND EDUCATION
EFFORTS IN LA COUNTY JAILS.
JUST AS RECENTLY AS TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN AMIL PARTNER WITH
LA COUNTY AND OTHER COMMUNITY
ALLIES ON THE LA FREE THE VOTE
CAMPAIGN.
WE DO WE DEVELOP VOTER EDUCATION
MATERIALS.
TRAIN STAFF AT VARIOUS COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS ON HOW TO REGISTER
VOTERS AND DISTRIBUTED VOTER
REGISTRATION CARDS A COUNTY
FACILITIES IN VARIOUS EVENTS
COUNTY WIDE.
JOINED BY THE LEADERSHIP OF
SUPERVISOR MARK RIDLEY THOMAS RD
CITY ENTERTAINER COMMON IN OUR
COMMUNITY ALLIES.
WE PARTICIPATE IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE A MISS CENTRAL JAIL
WHERE WE ANNOUNCED OUR EFFORTS
HAS ALREADY REGISTERED ONE
THOUSAND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS.
HOWEVER DESPITE OUR SUCCESS THE
CONF THE THERE CONTINUES TO BE
INCONSISTENCIES AROUND THE
PROCESS WHICH AB SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN RESOLVES.
VOTING IS A FUNDAMENTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
IT IS ALSO CONSIDERED TO BE A
BEDROCK PRINCIPLE SOCIETY AND SO
UNDERSTANDING THE PROCESS VERY
POLICIES IMPACT IN THE COMMUNITY
IS CRUCIAL CRUCIAL TO CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
BY PROVIDING CONSISTENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR ORGANIZATIONS
CONDUCTING VOTER EDUCATION IN
THE JAILS AND STREAMLINING DATA
SHARE RESPONSIBILITIES AB
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL BE AN
IMPORTANT STEP MOVING FORWARD TO
PREVENT THE VOTER
DISENFRANCHISEMENT. FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WE PROBABLY
SPONSOR AB SEVENTY SEVEN AND
NEXT THREE ARRIVAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER WITNESSES -- IN
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
RAIN X. CALIFORNIA GREEN PARTY
IN SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE IN
THE BILLY C. P. AND SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANDREW MUSICIAN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
DONNA SITES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
HAD CARRILLO SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT.
ISRAEL VIA REPRESENT LACKS A
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR CALIFORNIA
LINES FOR YOU THINK COMMUNITY
JUSTICE INSTRUCTS PORT.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BON
ROSARIO TIMES YOU JUST COALITION
STRONG SUPPORTER.
MILLER LIKE A SERBIAN YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALLEN MARKHAM ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
IRVINE YOUTH HAS COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOING BACK AYE SLAMMING DAD ELLA
BAKER CENTER IN SUPPORT.
CURRENT ANY OTHERS.
OKAY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND WILL NEED TO MAKE ROOM AT
THE TABLE.
OKAY YOU I THINK YOU CAN STAY
THERE THINK IT'S ONE QUE.
SHE SHE CAN STAY AT THE TABLE
YEAH GO AHEAD.
THERE'S ENOUGH SPACE
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
IS SHOWN MUCH LOWER HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL -- SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN
OF COURSE WE APPRECIATE THE WORK
AND RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE LA COUNTY.
BUT ONCE AGAIN OUR OPPOSITION IS
BASED ON THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH AND
MANDATE.
ON ALL THE JAILS IN THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
DO THE SAME THING.
ON THAT PERHAPS LA COUNTY IS
DOING -- SOMETHING THAT MAY NOT
WORK FOR OTHER JAILS -- SO ON
FAITH BASED ON THAT -- BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY OUT OPPOSE THE BILL
ALSO -- JUST -- THE BULLET
POINTS ARE MADE IN THE ANALYSIS
SOME OF THE THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE REQUIRED TO BE DONE BY THE
SHERIFF.
IN EACH COUNTY ON BASICALLY
HAVING -- IF STAY.
DENY AN ORGANIZATION OR
INDIVIDUAL FROM COMING INTO THE
THROUGH THEIR JAIL.
THERE ARE GOING TO HAVE -- TO
LET THE PERSON KNOW WHY THE
DENIAL IS SO.
THEN OF COURSE THEY WOULD HAVE
TO ALLOW THE PERSON TO APPEAL --
THE DENIAL AND THEN THEY WOULD
HAVE TO GO BACK AND LET THE PELL
PERSON NO AND THAT.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHOSE APPEAL
WAS DENIED AND GIVEN THEIR
WRITTEN NOTICE TO ALL THE STEPS
AGAIN OUR MANDATES.
ON INDIVIDUAL SHERIFF'S TO
FULFILL AND TAKES RESOURCES AWAY
FROM WHAT THEY NEED TO BE DOING
AS FAR AS SERVING DESERVE ALL OF
OUR POPULATIONS IN THEIR JAILS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEING NINE BUT SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS.
SENATOR -- SORRY SENATOR
MOORLACH THANK YOU MANAGER MISS
MODULAR -- ARE ARE THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES READY.
COMPLYING WITH THIS REQUEST.
YES MANY COUNTIES ALREADY ON
THEIR OWN HAVE ALREADY HAVE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS ORGANIZATIONS TO
COMMAND.
AND HALF THE INMATES PARTICIPATE
AND NO OF THE RICE TO REGISTER
TO VOTE -- OKAY I'M I'M JUST
HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE THE
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRES AND IF
WE'RE EVER NOT.
FIXING A PROBLEM WHY.
WHY GO TO THAT MANDATE?
POSITIONS THAT'S WHERE I'M
HAVING DIFFICULTY WITH THIS BILL
SEVEN MEMBERS GIPSON -- ME MAYOR
TO RESPOND TO SOMEONE NUMBER.
DROUGHT DIFFERS ACLU -- AND
THEY'LL MAKE A COMMENT -- SO
ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
A PROGRAM CALLED UNLOCK THE VOTE
AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN PARTING WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND LA BUT AN
ORANGE COUNTY THEY'VE BEEN
DENIED ACCESS TO THE JAILS BY
THE SHERIFF THERE AND THEY'VE
HAD TO RESORT -- THEY'VE HAD TO
RESORT TO MUCH MORE -- INTENSIVE
RESOURCE -- BASEMENT SO WAITING
OUT THE OUTSIDE THE JAILS AT
NIGHT TO REGISTER PEOPLE ON THE
RELEASED SPENDING MONEY DOING
MASSIVE MAILINGS ON THEIR OWN
AND THE INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT ALL
SHERIFF'S A LOT THIS AND
CURRENTLY.
WE HAD SOMEONE OR IF YOU WANT
HELP WELL SHE HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD ROB ALREADY SO I DON'T
NEED TO ADD.
ANYTHING TO IT.
RIGHT OTHER COMMENTS SIR -- I I
I WALKED IN LATE AND I WAS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
SHARES OPPOSITION IS TO THIS AND
WHAT ARE ALL THE GREAT SERVICES
THAT YOU NOW PROVIDING THAT THIS
WAS IN PITA PARK.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER MY TESTIMONY
AGAIN -- I WE DO NOT DISMISS THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE FOR
EXAMPLE LA AS MENTIONED -- SOME
THAT WORK IS A GREAT WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE AGAIN OUR OPPOSITION
IS THAT -- THERE IS A VERY
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH BECAUSE
IT WORKS IN THIS COUNTY AND IN
THIS PARTICULAR JAIL THAT IS
GOING TO WORK AND ALL THE OTHER
JAILS IN ALL THE OTHER FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES.
AND WHEN RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH THAT APPROACH A LEADING
EACH COUNTY EACH JAIL TO HAVE
THEIR OWN PROGRAM THAT WORKS
FAST -- AFFORD THAT JAIL AND FOR
THOSE INMATES IN THOSE JAILS AND
ALSO I DID MENTION FOR BULLET
POINTS THAT ARE NOTED IN
ANALYSIS AS FAR AS THE REQUIRE
MIGHT BY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. TO GO THROUGH -- THE
STEPS THAT NEED TO GO THROUGH
SHOULD DAY A DENY AN INDIVIDUAL
ORGANIZATION FOR WHATEVER REASON
IT MAY BE SPECIALLY FOR SECURITY
OF THAT -- FOR THAT INSTITUTION
AND FOR THOSE OF POPULATIONS IF
THEY DENY ACCESS FOR WHATEVER
REASON THAT THEY HAVE TO GO TO A
PROCESS OF YOU KNOW ME.
SAYING WHAT TO DO NOW IS WHAT
THE APPEAL PROCESS IS AND ALL
THOSE THINGS TAKE A WAIT -- FROM
pPERFORM THEIR ON DAILY JOBS
THANK YOU.
BRADFORD.
I SAY MORE.
I DO BUT ONLY THE LAW.
OKAY -- BEFORE.
WE'VE GOT A MOTION CORRECT
ELECTED ART SO.
THANK YOU -- BEFORE I ASK IT
CLOSE.
I THINK AT A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE SHERIFF'S.
IN YOUR ANSWER TO SENATOR
MORLOCKS QUESTION YOU DID NOT
SAY ALL COUNTIES SO THEN I THINK
WE ALREADY HAVE EVIDENCE THAT
NOT ALL COUNTIES ARE.
AND WHILE.
YOU KNOW I'M FROM SIMILARLY
INCLINED NOT TO ALWAYS ADD
MANDATES -- THIS MAY BE ONE
WHERE IT'S NECESSARY BECAUSE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IS SUCH A SACRED
PART OF OUR CONSTITUTION AND OUR
THE A RIGHT THAT WE AS
LEGISLATORS.
REALLY NEED TO ENSURE IS
PROTECTED SO.
WITH THAT MAKERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION JUST WANT TO
BRING OUT THE LOS AS WAS SAID
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF LOS ANGELES --
INDICATED THERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS -- THEY ARE IN FACT DOING
THIS IN THE COUNTY JAILS IN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- WHICH
BEING THE LARGEST -- COUNTY JAIL --
IN CALIFORNIA -- AND ALSO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS GO INTO JAIL TO GO
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS SO
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANYTHING
DIFFERENT -- WITH YOUR RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
A LOVED -- ONE THEY GO TO
RESTRAIN SCREENING PROCESS THAT
ANYONE ELSE WOULD GO THROUGH AND
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ALSO BE
RECEIVING DENIAL NOTICE AS WELL
SO IT'S NOT CREATING A NEW
PROCESS IS USING EXISTING
PROCESS THAT ALREADY EXIST -- BY
WAY OF FROM SOMEONE IS NOT
ELIGIBLE TO ACTUALLY GO INSIDE
THE JAIL -- AGAIN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT VOTERS RIGHTS ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN -- ON
SENTENCE AND THAT'S THE THING
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO VOTE THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF
MISINFORMATION OR LACK OF
INFORMATION.
AND THIS BILL HELPS PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION AND ALSO DISPEL IN
ECONOMIST IN TERMS OF ORDER --
VOTERS RIGHTS OR MAKING SURE THE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THESE RIGHTS
NEXT SIZES RIGHTS IN COUNTY
JAILS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU YOU'VE GOT A MOTION IT
SAID DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL SKINNER
FIGHT SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
AROUND NO WINNER ALL RIGHT.
WIENER AYE.
RIGHT TO THE BILL'S ON CALL IN
BUT YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL AB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR ITEM
FOURTEEN GO AHEAD YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS MY
WITNESSES ARE COMING FORWARD
AGAIN THANK ON THIS BODY IN THE
SENATORS FOR ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL
ENSURE CONSISTENT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU -- WHO
WERE FORMALLY IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE -- THE SYSTEM OF THIS
BILL REQUIRES THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE PROBATION ALL ON
INDIVIDUALIZED TRANSITION PLAN
FOR YOU TRANSITIONING OUT OF
JUVENILE -- COURT SCHOOL EXIST.
THANK YOU EXISTING LAW ENACTED --
BY THE SIGNING OF AB -- TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX BOCANEGRA IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN REQUIRES A
JOINT -- TRANSITION PLAN A CITY
WITH THIS BILL WILL WILL DO --
ONE INDIVIDUAL IS LEAVING.
A JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL IT
PROVIDES A COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND THE
COUNTY OF OFFICE ADMINISTRATION
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING OUT DON'T ALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
I'M FAR TOO LONG -- THOSE WERE
LEAVING -- THE JUVENILE COURT
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS WITH N
PLAN WITH NO DIRECTION IN TERMS
OF CREDITS CLASSES WHICH NEED TO
BE TAKEN IN ORDER TO GO TO MOVE
THEM ON THE ROAD -- TO SUCCESS
IN TERMS OF ACADEMIC -- PROGRAM
AND THIS BILL WILL ALLOW ON THE
COLLABORATION WILL FORWARD IT
WILL ALSO ALLOW A YOUNG PERSON --
TO HAVE INFORMATION BY WAY OF
CREDITS I KNOW THE CLASSES TAKEN
SO THAT IT'S CHAO WILL FALL
BETWEEN THE CRACKS -- IT ALSO
WILL BE ABLE TO CHART A ROAD TO
SUCCESS AND DRIVE SO WITH ME --
TO STOP -- GIVE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY ON THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR
WHICH WOULD BE INDIVIDUALS ARE A
LUCY -- SO SAITO FROM THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER AND BROTHER IRVING
FROM.
IRVING COURTING FROM THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION WHO IS SELF OR
TO DO SO BY RAIL AND BEFORE OUR
WITNESSES STARTED JUST -- YOU
KNOW IF THERE IS A MOTION --
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AT LEAST
IN THE ANALYSIS AND THE TEARS
RECOMMENDING ICE SO PLEASE
PROCEED.
HI MY NAME IS LUCY SELFIE THE
CARTER WE ARE SPONSORING THE
BILL THE YOUTH LAWCENTER AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'M AVAILABLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO MISTER [inaudible]
IRVING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS IRVINE
COURT ON I AM A HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT OUR YOUTH ORGANIZER A
YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION IN LOS
ANGELES.
OURS YOU THE VOTE YES ON AB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR EDUCATION IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCE WE
NEED TO GET A JOB THAT PAYS
ENOUGH TO LIVE ON TO GET OFF THE
STREETS THE STATE OUT OF JAIL.
BUT 85% OF THESE PEOPLE IN STATE
PRISON ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
HAVE NO HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
I'M THAT 85%.
MY FIRST COURSES PENSION WAS AT
THE AGE OF THIRTEEN BECAUSE AN
IN CLASS AS AN IMMIGRANT I WAS
LEARNING ENGLISH I WAS
PRACTICING YOU WORDS I HAD TO
LEARN.
I TRIED TO APOLOGIZE BUT I GOT
IN IN SCHOOL SUSPENSION FOR TWO
DAYS I HAD TO FACE THE WALL
RIGHT I WILL NOT BE
DISRESPECTFUL THREE HUNDRED
TIMES.
AFTER THAT I STARTED TO FEEL IN
SECURING FEARFUL OF SCHOOL.
I STARTED TO GET INTO THE
BATHROOM TO HIDE.
I GOT INTO AN INTO ANOTHER IN
SCHOOL SUSPENSION FOR SKIPPING
CLASS THIS TIME.
IT WAS SEVEN HUNDRED TIMES
WRITING I WILL NOT SKIP CLASS.
AS I MADE MY WAY THROUGH MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHERS WOULD READ MY
STORY AND FILES.
THE WRITE UPS AND WOULD THEN
ASSIGN ME A BACK SEAT OF THE
CLASSROOM RESEARCH FOR THE SO
CALLED BAD KIDS.
SUSPENSION MET ME FURTHER BEHIND
AND MORE AND MORE DEPRESSED I
WOULD JUST SIT IN THE STADIUM
BLEACHERS DURING CLASS AND SO
SCHOOL.
POLICE OFFICER DRAG ME TO THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE FOR ANOTHER
SUSPENSION.
ON THE DAYS -- SUSPENDED ON
SUPERVISED BUT WORKING PARENTS I
STARTED DRINKING AND SMOKING
MARIJUANA AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN
I WAS AT A PARK DURING SCHOOL
HOURS WHEN A POLICE OFFICER JOE
BY.
I WAS ARRESTED FOR LOITERING HOW
SENTENCES TO YOUR APPROPRIATIONS
TWO YEARS FOR PROBATION.
THE JUDGE TOLD ME THAT IT WAS
MANDATORY FOR ME TO ROLL IN
SCHOOL.
BUT ONLY THEIR WEEKLY CHECK INS
WITH PROBATION A DRUG TEST.
I WAS VIOLATE IN N. DETAINED FOR
THE FIRST TIME WHEN I WAS IN MY
LOOK IN THE LATE TO MY PROBATION.
BEING LATE TO MY PROBATION
APPOINTMENT.
I WAS RELEASED FROM JUVENILE
HALL WITHOUT A REFERRAL TO
SCHOOL AND WAS SO FAR BEHIND I
NEVER THOUGHT I ON MY OWN GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL.
EVENTUALLY I STARTED DOING MORE
SERIOUS CRIMES I WITH THE STATE
PRISON AT AGE EIGHTEEN FOR
CARJACKING.
AND THE ADORE SYSTEM ALSO
OVERWHELMED BY WERE RACIAL
SEGREGATION.
AND POLITICS OF GANGS.
SOMETHING I NEVER.
SOMETHING I NEVER BEEN A PART OF
I WAS SEXUALLY AND PHYSICALLY
ASSAULTED LIKE MOST YOU WITH AN
ADULT JAILS AND PRISONS.
I WAS FORCED TO FIGHT CONSTANTLY
TO PROVE MYSELF.
AND THAT I WAS THE ONLY PERSON.
NO YOU SHOULD EVER FEEL
DEPRESSED HOPELESS AND FULL OF
FEAR ASIDE THE SINCE RETURNING
HOME PRISON I HAVE A ROLE IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I AM NEARLY FINISHED.
I AM WORKING PART TIME.
BUT IF I HAVE BEEN ENCOURAGING
AND ORDER BY RE ENROLL IN SCHOOL.
ONE FIRST WHEN I WAS FIRST UNDER
PROBATION BECAUSE CITY.
I WOULD HAVE A WAY TO HAVING AN
ADULT CRIMINAL RECORD AND STATE
PRISON SENTENCE.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR WAR CHOIR
THAT COUNTY OFFICES.
OF EDUCATION AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENT DEVELOP PERSONAL PLAN
WITH EACH YOUTH.
AND THEIR FAMILIES IN ORDER TO
MEET THEIR ACADEMIC SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND CAREER NEEDS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ARE
YOU TO HOLD -- ARGIVE -- ON AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SHARING
THAT VERY PERSONAL TESTIMONY AND
I KNOW IT'S DIFFICULT SO PRE
SHEET YOUR BEING HERE AND
SHARING THAT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CAN BE SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER [inaudible]
INSTRUCTS PORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
ANGELI GIVENS WITH THE NEW A
LIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
BROWN'S WIFE LEARN NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND SOMEONE
WHO EXPERIENCED REPEATED
DISRUPTIONS TO MY EDUCATION AS A
RESULT A JUVENILE INCARCERATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FRANCESCA FREQUENT NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BON
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN'T CORRAL SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIA DEGROOT A PAST TEACHER FOR
HOMELESS CHILDREN A STRONG
SUPPORT.
ISRAEL ISRAEL BE A WITH THE YCJA
AS WELL AS THE LAST WAS A MINUTE
COLOR STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN MARLING PHENOMENA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
SORRY IT'S TIME IS YOU JUST AS
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORTER.
MILLER LACKS SABEAN YOU'VE JUST
AS COALITION STRONG SUPPORT GOOD
JOB EVERY.
IT LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA'S FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT.
RESTORED ALONE TIME DOES
INSTANCE SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
OKAY.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION -- AS I
INDICATED NOW SISTERS NOT
OPPOSITION WHICH IS GOOD.
OUR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES -- THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL [inaudible]
I I THINK THERE WERE SOME OTHER
POLICY ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED --
IN YOUR TESTIMONY IRVING.
SUCH AS WHAT IS THE VALUE OF
SUSPENSIONS IN TERMS OF
EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
BUT THAT'S A SEPARATE
CONVERSATION.
WHICH HOPEFULLY WE WILL SUCCEED
WITH.
THEM BUT I APPRECIATE THAT AS
THIS IS VERY MUCH ORIENTED.
TO TRYING TO ASSIST OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND SUPPORT THEM RATHER THAN OUR
CRIMINALIZING THEM IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE IN SOME CASES IT WILL
BE BUT CERTAINLY WHERE IT IS
NECESSARY.
SO -- I WILL BE RECOMMENDING AYE.
IN A MISTER BRADFORD I BELIEVE
MOVED IT SO WE'VE GOT THAT
MOTION.
JULY CLOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY IS -- I COULD HAVE SAID IT
BETTER I WANT TO THANK IRVING
FOR ONE BEING HERE.
CERTAINLY HE SHARED A GREAT DEAL
OF HURT AND PAIN AND
DISAPPOINTMENT -- WE HOPE THAT
THE SYSTEM DOESN'T LET ANYONE
DOWN I THINK YOU'VE BEEN A
TREMENDOUS EXAMPLE OF SAYING --
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT AND FIGHT FOR NOW YOURSELF
BUT ALSO FOR OTHERS TO TO FOLLOW
AS WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE.
ALRIGHT LET'S DO -- ROLL CALL
IT'S TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SKINNER [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
BRADFORD SKINNER I SURPRISE
BRADFORD AYE.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL MOREAU.
WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
ELLISON CALL LOOKING GOOD BUT WE
HAVE TO WAIT TILL ARE ABSENT
MEMBERS RETURNED THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO.
TO WATER REBOUND ALL RIGHT --
READ VERBAL WHATEVER ITEM ELEVEN
AB TEN SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON MARCH.
TO THE PRESENT AB TEN SEVENTY
SIX WHEN THE AWFUL THANK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL.
WE ARE PROUD TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED.
BY.
AS AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE A. B.
CAN SEVENTY SIX WOULD REALLY
ALTER AND CHANGE THE LIVES FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
EITHER.
HAVE AN ARREST RECORD OR HAVE A
CONVICTION THAT IS ALLOWED TO BE
EXPUNGED.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR GOVERNMENT
HASN'T REALLY STREAMLINED THIS
PROCESS WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CLEAR THEIR RECORDS.
WHO HAVEN'T YET PARTLY BECAUSE
THE COST PER BECAUSE THE TIME
PARTLY BECAUSE THE DIFFICULTY OF
GOING TO DO THAT?
WE'RE PROPOSING A STREAMLINED
APPROACH ON HOW TO DO THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
THEY ARE WILLING TO DEVELOP A
DATABASE.
THAT CAN BE SHARED WITH THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
THAT DATABASE THEN CAN BE USED
TO NOT RELEASE INFORMATION WHEN
EACH OF THOSE COUNTIES ARE
ONTACTED.
WE THINK THIS IS A MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED AS WELL AS A CHEAPER
ALTERNATIVE FOR US.
AND BY DOING SO WE EXPECT THAT
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WILL
HAVE THEIR RECORDS ACTUALLY
CLEARED.
THAT CAN PAVE THE WAY FOR
TOWARDS BETTER EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AS OUSE
INTERPRETERS WITHOUT LET ME TURN
OVER. TO ONE OF OUR MAIN
SPONSORS DISTRICT ATTORNEY
GEORGE GAS GONE FROM CITY COUNTY
SAN FRANCISCO.
THANK YOU.
OUR TEN ON AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS TODAY THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT HUMAN DIGNITY.
OF THE LAWS ALREADY THERE WE'RE
NOT WRITING ANY NEW LAW PER SE
THIS IS A RELIEF THE PEOPLE
QUALIFY FOR UNFORTUNATELY.
LESS THAN 6% OF CALIFORNIANS
ACTUALLY AVAILED HIMSELF OF
THOSE RELIEF.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THEY IT IS SO
DIFFICULT TO DO THERE ARE SO
MANY HOOPS OF PEOPLE HAVE TO
JUMP THROUGH IT IS EXPENSIVE.
ALL IN CONSEQUENTLY THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN LEAST AFFORD TO HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD PEOPLE ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THIS SO.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS WE'RE
TRYING TO TAKE X. SYSTEM RELIEF
IT HAS BEEN PROVIDER READY BY
THE LEGISLATORS IN THE STATE?
AND MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE GET
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
IS A IS A REALLY OF ALL.
COMMUNITY SAFETY THIS IS OF ALL
FURNACES OF ALL HUMAN DIGNITY.
IS ALL PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO GET
HOUSING YOU KNOW TO GET
EMPLOYMENT BEING ABLE TO EVEN
PARTICIPATE.
IN SIMPLE THINGS LIKE A SCHOOL
ACTIVITIES WITH THEIR CHILDREN
THAT THEY MAY NOT IF THEY HAVE A
CRIMINAL RECORD.
ALL I'M FOR THE RECENTLY --
SHOOT TO UP TO SUPPORT THIS AND
OBVIOUSLY I'LL BE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TANK -- AND THIS THE THING BODY
FOR HAVING ME MY NAME IS A
JORDAN SENIOR AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE.
AND FOR THE SPECIAL OCCASION OUT
INSPIRED BY SENATOR BRADFORD
BARBARA MURMURING SUIT.
I WOULD BE REMISS TO SAY HEY.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T SAY THAT IT'S ALWAYS
HONOR TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE.
WOULD YOU SEE.
NUMBER A PROMPT.
IF THE CURRENT EXPOSURE PROCESS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
GLORIA.
THIS PROCESS BECAUSE SOMEONE UP
TO THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO COMPLETE.
THAT'S MORE THAN A MONTH'S WAGES
FOR MANY FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA.
EVEN THE AND THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE THE SOMEONE CAN BE
GRANT AN EXPUNGEMENT.
LAST TIME OFF WORK TROUBLED
MULTIPLE COUNTIES SOMETIMES WERE
THREE HUNDRED MILES PER TRIP.
DOING THIS MULTIPLE TIMES OF THE
COURSE OF A FEW MONTHS I DON'T
KNOW ANYBODY THAT HAVE THAT TYPE
OF FLEXIBILITY WHILE WORKING
FULL TIME AND THE KIDS ARE IN
SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT ONLY 6%
OF THOSE AMERICANS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR EXPUNGEMENT
ACTUALLY GET IT.
PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PAYING THEIR LIGHT BILL.
AND PAY FOR AN EXPUNGEMENT.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
AB TEN SEVENTY SIX IS NOT JUST
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
IT'S ABOUT WHO WE NEED TO BECOME
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THIS BILL HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
AFFECT OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICT.
SENATE MORE LACK.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
YOURS SENATOR JACKSON AND OVER.
NINETY THOUSAND THE NUMBER RAIL
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND SENATOR WIENER OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND SENATOR
BRADFORD.
AB TEN SEVENTY SIX TAKES A STEP
TOWARD GIVING OVER TWO MILLION
PEOPLE IN LA COUNTY THEIR
FREEDOM.
SO WHO DO YOU WANT TO BECOME.
A BUTTON IS MOMENT.
BUT WE WANT TO BECOME THOSE
VANGUARD TO STOOD UP FOR
REDEMPTION A RECONCILIATION.
THOUGHTFUL HARDWORKING FATHER
LIKE TERRENCE.
WHO STRUGGLE TO FIND HOUSING
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS A MASTER'S
DEGREE?
SET UP FOR INGRID AND ANGELIQUE
SET UP FOR MYSELF.
SO I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON A.
B..
TEN SEVENTY SIX NOT BECAUSE GOOD
POLICY BECAUSE ROOM FOR PEOPLE
LIKE ME ROOM FOR PEOPLE LIKE
TERRENCE ROOM FOR PEOPLE LIKE
INGRID ROOM FOR PEOPLE LIKE
ANGELIQUE AND THE THOUSANDS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
IN YOUR DISTRICT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE IF THERE'S OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND STRONG SUPPORTING GREAT
TESTIMONY.
NATASHA VENTURE FOR SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NOT A SITE YOUR PRESENT IN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
HERE'S HERE'S STEWART
REPRESENTING HIM.
CALIFORNIA STATE THE INJECTED IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
LESLIE CALDWELL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ALSO TAKE A GREAT DEAL OF COUNTY
FUNDS. TO GO THROUGH THAT LONG
PROCESS THAT YOU SAW THE
DEMONSTRATION OF JUST ENTER SOME
OF THE TIME DONE.
YVONNE SILVA CODE FOR AMERICA IN
SUPPORT.
KIM MORE UW IN SUPPORT.
SORRY TERMS YOU COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAT CARELL SACRAMENTO CHAPTER OF
THE ACLU IN SUPPORT.
IRVING OF YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
SIMILAR YOU JUST COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GRIPPING HICKS
CAN SUCK MY COUNTY GREEN PARTY
SONG SPORT.
INTERNET SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
PEACE AND JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT.
ALLEN MINE FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
IT WOULD LITTLE A CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ANDRE PERRY WITH CRIMES RUBBERS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHERS
HEART WE'VE GOT SOME OPPOSITION
OUR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE MAY NEED TO MAKE ROOM AT THE
TABLE NO IT'S OKAY I'LL JUST GO
AHEAD ARE EXPLAINED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WHO SHALL MUCH THERE HE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
ASSOCIATION OF RECORDS%
SUPERVISORS WHO WILL BE HANDLING
ALL THAT -- DISMISSALS HERE --
WE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS IT IS
WRITTEN WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK AT
THE MAN MEN'S -- SEE IF OUR
OPPOSITION WILL BE REMOVED -- A
WE HAVE HAD WERE VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AS TO WHY WE BELIEVE AT
THIS WILL OBVIOUSLY BE A HUGE
MANDATE.
ON LOCK LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO FULFILL
THIS REQUIREMENT AS WELL AS THE
LIABILITY OF WHAT WILL HAPPEN
ONCE THESE DISMISSALS MAKE THEIR
WAY.
OFF FROM DOJ TO THE COURT SYSTEM
AND TO THE LOCAL DEPARTMENTS AND
ADAM IF FOR SOME REASON AT
PERSON I GETS MISSED IN THE
SHUFFLE OF WERE.
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AS WELL BUT
AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK AT
AMENDMENTS AND SEE IF THERE WAS
ALL OF OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MACKEY'S ON HALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE TO HOPE TO AND TO FIND
SOME COMMON GROUND ON THIS.
GREAT ANY OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT -- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
EXCELLENT -- FOR A SEE IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO MAKE COMMENTS I
WELCOME THIS BILL.
I HAVE CARRIED AT LEAST THREE
PIECES THE LEGISLATION MAYBE
MORE AND GOTTEN LANGUAGE IN
BUDGET MULTIPLE TIMES TO LIKE
LITTLE BIT A LITTLE EASIER HERE
FOR THIS CATEGORY LITTLE EASIER
FOR THIS CATEGORY.
AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY ABSURD THAT
WE FORCE PEOPLE TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS WE DO FOR THE
EXPUNGEMENT OF THE RECORDS WHEN.
IF THEY MEET THE CRITERIA THAT
ALLOWS FOR EXPUNGEMENT IT SHOULD
BE EASY -- SO I ARE WELCOME THIS
BILL THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TAKING.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST AGAIN FATE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE IN THIS RESPECT AS RIVAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE
MOORLACH.
BRADFORD I'VE BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER.
WIENER HIGH.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
IT'S ON CALL -- SO WHAT WE HAVE
NO AUTHORS.
HOW DARE THEY ARE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A MOTION I
CONSENT CALENDAR -- LET'S DO
REAL CALLING CONSENT.
SKINNER.
BYE BYE MORE LIKE.
WHAT I BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE?
WIENER.
WIENER AYE EXCELLENT LET'S DO A
MOTION ON OUR VOTE ONLY THAT C.
B..
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT EXCELLENT.
IT SAYS THAT IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER OF OUR I IT WAS YOUR
RECALL WE HEARD IT AND THERE WAS --
JUST -- SOME LANGUAGE ONE TO
WORK OUT WHICH REALLY REFLECTED
EXACTLY THE BILL'S INTENT BUT
IT'S ALL IN THERE AND IT'S IN
THE ANALYSIS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DID IS VOTE ONLY
AND WE HAVE THAT A MOTION NOW DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ROLL CALL SKINNER AYE SKINNER
AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
WIENER WIENER AYE GREAT NOW DID
WE EVER GET EMOTIONAL MISTER
BERMAN'S I DON'T BELIEVE SO OKAY
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON EIGHTY
FIVE TO ONE NUMBER ITEM SIX AB.
FIVE TWO ONE ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S AB FIVE
TWO ONE ROLL CALL SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'M MORE LACKEY.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON MITCHELL
MORALE.
WIENER RIGHT WIENER AYE
EXCELLENT THOSE ARE ALL ON CALL
BUT AT LEAST WE GOT THEM.
GOING SO LET'S GO TO ITEM
NINETEEN SB
SIXTEEN HUNDRED WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT THIS BILL
FOR YOU TODAY THIS BILL.
WOULD MAKE TWO CHANGES TO
EXISTING PITCHES MOTION
PROCEDURES TO ENSURE GREATER AND
GREATER ACCESS TO DUE PROCESS.
AND THE RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL
FOR PERSONS CHARGED WITH CRIMES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR NEVER TO BRING
PITCHES MOTION TIME LINES INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH REGULAR COMEAU
DISTURBING NOTICE TIMELINES.
AB SIX SIXTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
AMEND THE EVIDENCE CODE TO ALIGN
THE TIME PERIOD OF PITCHES
DISCOVERY MOTIONS WITH THE
NOTICE PERIOD FOR DISCOVERY
MOTIONS IN CRIMINAL CASES.
SIXTEEN DAYS TEN DAYS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW A SPEEDY TRIAL
IS LIMITED TO THIRTY DAYS A
MISDEMEANOR CASES AND SIXTY DAYS
FOR A FELONY CASE.
THE SIX DAY DIFFERENCE MAY SEEM
INCONSEQUENTIAL BUT IT AMOUNTS
TO A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF A
PERSON'S LEGAL ABILITY TO PROVE
THEIR INNOCENCE.
BY ALIGNING THIS TIMELINE TO THE
SAME DISCOVERY TIMELINES
AFFORDED FOR OTHER DISCOVERY
TIME LINES WILL HELP TO BALANCE
RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS WITH THE
RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL.
AS A FORMER DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER OF EXPERIENCE FIRST
HAND THE CHALLENGE OF PURSUING A
TIME NOT WAIVE A JURY TRIAL.
OUR MY CLIENT HAD TO WE THEIR
RIGHTS TO SPEECH TRIAL AGAINST
HIS OR HER RIGHTS TO DUE PROCESS.
ONE SHOULD NOT BE SACRIFICE IN
LIEU OF THE OTHER.
SECONDLY WOULD ALSO REPEAL
RESTRICTIONS EXEMPTING
SUPERVISING OFFICERS IN THE
DISCLOSURE RECORDS THROUGH A
PITCHES MOTION FOR THE PRIOR
MISCONDUCT WHEN IT IS PERTINENT.
TO DEFEND HIS RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS CURRENT LAW RESTRICTS
THE ABILITY FOR SUPPORT FOR
ISRAEL OFFICERS TO BE SUBJECT TO
A PITCHES MOTION.
EVEN IF THAT PERSON WAS INVOLVED
IN DIRECTING OR OVERSEEING THE
CONDUCT IN QUESTION.
A WORK CLOSELY WITH PORAC THE
PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ON THIS
LAST REVISION AND HAVE DROPPED
TO NEARLY. ZERO TWO LANGUAGE
THAT WAS RECENTLY AMENDED INTO
THE BILL TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND AS OF AS A RESULT
THEY REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
BUT MAKING THESE MODEST CHANGES
CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE PITCHES
PROCEDURES LESS BURDENSOME AND
TIME CONSUMING WHILE INCREASING
FAIRNESS IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS.
BRITNEY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OUR
SUSAN LEFT THE COMPANY PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
AND KATHLEEN GOING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE ACLU [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MORNING MY NAME IS TO THE LEFT I
AM THE ASSISTANT PUBLIC DEFENDER
OF NEVADA COUNTY.
WHERE I SERVICE THE MISDEMEANOR
SUPERVISOR?
TODAY I'M HERE TO SHARE WHY THE
FIRST PART OF THIS BILL WILL
MAKE AN IMPORTANT CHANGE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND THEN WHEN I'M DONE KATHLEEN
FROM THE ACLU WILL ADDRESS THE
SECOND PORTION OF THE BILL.
CURRENT LAW CAUSES THOSE CHARGED
WITH MISDEMEANORS TO HAVE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN ON THE ONE HAND
AFFIRMING THEIR RIGHT TO A
SPEEDY TRIAL OR ON THE OTHER
HAND.
ASKING COURTS TO PROVIDE
RELEVANT INFORMATION REGARDING A
POLICE OFFICERS PRIOR ACTS OF
MISCONDUCT.
THAT MISCONDUCT EVIDENCE IS A
CONFIDENTIAL BECAUSE IT'S
CONTAINED WITHIN THE POLICE
OFFICERS FILE.
IT MAY ONLY BE THE ONLY EVIDENCE
AVAILABLE TO CORROBORATE A
PERSON'S CLAIM OF INNOCENCE OR A
CLAIM THAT THE POLICE OFFICER
VIOLATED THAT PERSON'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
A DEFENSE ATTORNEY CAN SEEK
INFORMATION REGARDING WHETHER AN
OFFICER HAS DONE SIMILAR THINGS
IN THE PAST INCLUDING
FABRICATING EVIDENCE USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE OR VIOLATING A
PERSON'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THEY DO SO BY FILING A MOTION
FOR DISCOVERY CALLED THE PITCHES
pMOTION THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY
NEEDS TO BE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
WHAT INFORMATION IS BEING
REQUESTED AND WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
IN MY OWN EXPERIENCE I'VE SEEN
THAT THE RESULT OF A SUCCESSFUL
PITCHES MOTION CAN BECAUSE THE
PROSECUTION TO DISMISS THE CASE.
AND IT CAN HELP THE THE DEFENSE
WAY TO PROVE THAT SOMEONE IS
INNOCENT OF THE CHARGES AGAINST
THEM. ONE OF THE CURRENT
PROBLEMS A. B. C.'S AB SIXTEEN
HUNDRED SIX TO FIX IS THAT THE
PROCESS FOR HEARING ON A PITCHES
MOTION SIMPLY TAKES TOO LONG.
IT HAS AN EXCESSIVELY LONG
NOTICE REQUIREMENT OF SIXTEEN
COURT DAYS.
THIS DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE WITH
WHEN NEARLY ALL THE OTHER
MOTIONS THAT WE FILING CRIMINAL
COURT REQUIRES JUST TEN DAYS
NOTICE.
IF WE WERE REDUCE THIS PROCESS
BY JUST SIX DAYS FROM SIXTEEN
COURT DAYS OF NO. TO TEN COURT
DAYS OF NOTICE WE WOULD PROVIDE
MORE MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANTS WITH
ACCESS TO IMPORTANT DISCOVERY
WITHOUT FORCING THEM TO WAIVE
THEIR RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL.
THE OPPOSITION ARGUES THAT
SHORTENING THIS NURSES NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FROM SIXTEEN DAYS TO
TEN DAYS WOULD MAKE IT DIFFICULT
TO WRITE ANY WRITTEN OBJECTIONS
IN OPPOSITION AND MAKE A
DILIGENT SEARCH FOR RECORDS.
WHICH THEY SAY WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER FOR THEM TO PREPARE
MEANINGFUL OPPOSITIONS TO
PURCHASE MOTIONS.
BUT IN MY EXPERIENCE MOST CITY
ATTORNEY'S JUST BROADLY OBJECT
AND SIMPLY ARGUE THAT THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS MOTIONS NOT
SPECIFIC ENOUGH REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S ACTUAL
MERIT TO THE MOTION.
ALSO CITY ATTORNEYS DO NOT
ACTUALLY SEARCH THROUGH ANY THE
RECORDS AT ALL THEIR JOB IS TO
PROVIDE ALL THE POLICE OFFICERS
RECORDS TO THE COURT.
THEN THE COURT IS THE ONE THAT
REVIEWS THESE POLICE RECORDS
SORTS OUT WHAT INFORMATION IF
ANY SHOULD THEN BE TURNED OVER
TO THE DEFENSE.
THIS CHANGE IN THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FROM SIXTEEN CORE
DAYS TO TEN COURT DATES WILL
RESULT IN MORE EQUITY MORE
TRANSPARENCY IN MORE FAIRNESS
WITHIN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
ESPECIALLY TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANORS
AND WHO ARE IN CUSTODY AWAITING
THEIR TRIALS.
AFTER ALL WHEN PEOPLE HAVE MORE
MEANINGFUL AND MORE TIMELY
ACCESS TO PROPER TOOLS AT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ALREADY
HAS IN PLACE.
THEN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WILL WORK BETTER FOR EVERYONE.
I REMAIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B. SIXTEEN
HUNDRED THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KATHLEEN GUNARATNE I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE I WORK ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUES.
BEFORE THAT I WAS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
MORE -- MORE THAN A DECADE WHEN
I ARGUED MANY PITCHES MOTIONS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH A CRIME ARE DENIED
CRITIC CRITICAL INFORMATION
ABOUT A PATTERN OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT MISCONDUCT IN MANY
KINDS OF CASES WHERE A
SUPERVISOR SIGNED OFF ON A FALSE
REPORT.
WHERE SUPERVISOR INSTRUCTED HIS
SUBORDINATE TO FILE A FALSE
REPORT HELPED IN DRAFTING A
FALSE REPORT?
OR PARTICIPATED IN COVERING UP
THE MISCONDUCT. FOR EXAMPLE I
ONCE REPRESENTED A CLIENT
CHARGED WITH RESISTING ARREST
AND BATTERY ON A POLICE OFFICER.
OUR INVESTIGATION CONCLUDES
STRONGLY SUGGESTED THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WAS HE HAD LED THE
POLICE ON A FOOT CHASE THEY HAD
BADLY BEATEN HIM UP.
AND THAT THE CHARGES WERE AN
ATTEMPT TO COVER UP FOR THE
BEATING.
THE REST WAS MADE -- AND ON ON
SCENE BUT THE SUPERVISOR WAS NOT
ON SCENE DURING THE ARREST.
IN OUR INVESTIGATION IT APPEARED
THAT THE R. ARRESTING OFFICER
WHO MADE THE ARREST HAD TALKED
TO HIS SUPERVISOR ABOUT WHAT TO
WRITE IN THE POLICE REPORT THERE
WERE SEVERAL DRAFTS OF THE
POLICE REPORT THAT WE WHAT WE
SAW.
AND WE ACTUALLY EVEN RECEIVED A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT AUTHORED BY
THE ARRESTING OFFICER WITH
SUSPICIOUS NEW DETAILS THAT WERE
CONTRADICTED BY GRAINY BODY
CAMERA FOOTAGE.
I SUSPECTED THAT THE SUPERVISING
OFFICER HAD TOLD HIS SUBORDINATE
TO SAY UNTRUE THINGS IN THE
REPORT TO MAKE SURE THE CASE.
STOOD UP IN COURT.
UNDER EXISTING LAW I WAS
POWERLESS HOWEVER TO GET
PERSONNEL RECORDS FROM THE
SUPERVISOR.
THIS IS BECAUSE THE SUPERVISOR
WAS NOT PRESENT DURING THE
ARREST AND HAD NO DIRECT CONTACT
WITH MY CLIENT.
AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED MAKES A
MODEST CHANGE TO THE EVIDENCE
CODE THAT FIXES THIS PROBLEM
THIS BILL WILL NOW ALLOW PEOPLE
CHARGED WITH A CRIME TO OBTAIN
CRITICAL PRIOR MISCONDUCT
INFORMATION FROM DIRECT
SUPERVISORS.
WHEN IT'S RELEVANT TO THE
DEFENSE?
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY REPORTS OF
A STRONG CODE OF SILENCE THAT
EXISTS AMONG SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED AS NECESSARY
TO COMBAT THAT AND TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY PERSON CHARGED WITH A
CRIME GETS A FAIR TRIAL.
AND THAT SUPERVISORS TO SIGN OFF
ON OTHERS OFFICERS FALSE REPORTS.
ARE NOT EXEMPT FROM HAVING THEIR
MISCONDUCT DISCLOSED.
I REMAIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD ALSO URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SKINNER KARA -- JEFF TORTILLA.
VARIOUS COALITIONS BUT STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT HAVING SEEN THIS
OCCUR MYSELF.
LESLIE CALDWELL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
BARRY HAD FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CATCH GRILL SEGMENT OF CHAPTER
OF THE ACLU IN SUPPORT.
RED HOOK SACRAMENTO COUNTY GREEN
PARTY IN SUPPORT -- ROB A COUPLE
SECRETARY IN GREEN PARTY IN
SUPPORT.
WHEN BACK IS FOR ELEVATOR CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN SUPPORT?
ALLEN MARLINS MOUNTED A COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS.
ALRIGHT LET'S HAVE THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND WE'LL NEEDS A
ROOM AT THE TABLE.
I'M ASSUMING WE HAVE
[inaudible]
TO YES.
WELCOME YOU CAN BEGIN.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CHARLES HARVEY ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND WE ARE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED A WE'VE BEEN IN
TALKS WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF AND
WE APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS TO
ENGAGE IN ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ON
THIS BILL.
I WITH REGARD TO THE PROPOSED
EXPEDITED TIME FRAME IT IS
ALREADY DIFFICULT FOR CITIES TO
SUFFICIENTLY PREPARE FOR PITCHES
MOTIONS WITHIN THE CURRENT
SIXTEEN DAY TIME FRAME.
UP WHAT THE CITY RECEIVED
DEFENDANTS PITCHES MOTION SEPT
SEVERAL PROCEDURAL STEPS ARE
TAKEN.
OF THE OFFICER TO NOTIFY THE
CUSTODIAN AS TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO BE PRESENT AND A
DILIGENT SEARCH FOR RECORDS HAS
TO OCCUR -- IMPORTANTLY A CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE MUST ALSO
PREPARE ANY WRITTEN OBJECTIONS
AND OPPOSITIONS WITHIN THE
PRESCRIBED TIME FRAME.
THIS REQUIRES THE ATTORNEY TO
REVIEW THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES IN EACH CASE TO
FILL THEIR RECORD ETHICAL DUTY
ZEALOUSLY REPRESENT THEIR CLIENT
AND THEY HAVE TO DO THIS WHILE
BOUNCING ALL THE OTHER DEMANDS
ON THEIR WORKLOAD.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY DIFFICULT FOR
SOLO IN HOUSE ATTORNEYS WHO ARE
THE ONLY ONES AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST THEIR CITY.
WITH THE MANY LEGAL MATTERS THAT
INEVITABLY ARISE.
NOW CONSEQUENTLY SHORTENING THIS
NOTICE REQUIREMENT -- FROM TEN
DAYS TO FIVE COURT DAYS I WOULD
CONSTRAIN ALREADY TIGHT RESPONSE
WENDELL.
THEREBY REDUCING CITIES
OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE A
MEANINGFUL INAPPROPRIATE
OPPOSITION TO A PITCHES MOTION.
OF THE AUTHOR PROPONENTS ARGUE
THAT -- AS AN EXAMPLE --
MISDEMEANOR DEFENDANTS IN
CUSTODY -- WITH THE RIGHT TO A
THIRTY DAY SPEEDY TRIAL CANNOT
ACCESS MISCONDUCT RECORDS IN
TIME TO BE ABLE TO USE THOSE
UNDER THE CURRENT NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS -- HOWEVER SECTIONS
TEN FORTY THREE OF THE EVIDENCE
CODE ALREADY INCLUDES A PROCESS
FOR THE DEFENSE TO SHORTEN THE
TIME FRAME FOR PROVIDING THE
NOTICE GIVING THE COURT THE
AUTHORITY TO ACCOMMODATE THE
WISHES OF THE DEFENSE.
NOW IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING FROM
SPEAKING WITH CITY ATTORNEY'S
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THESE
REQUESTS TO SHORTEN TIME ARE
NEARLY ALWAYS GRANTED.
THIS BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY
REMOVE A JUDGE'S DISCRETION TO
DETERMINE THESE ISSUES ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS.
AND WOULD INSTEAD ALLOW DEFENSE
ATTORNEY TO MERELY FILE A MOTION
IN ALL CASES REGARDLESS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND CITY HEARING
JUST TEN COURT DAYS AHEAD OF
TIME.
LEADING CITIES AGAIN WOULD JUST
FIVE COURT DAYS TO RESPOND.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT WHILE
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS NO ONE CAN
PLAN WHEN THEY WILL FILE AND
TEND TO A PITCHES MOTION.
IS CITY ATTORNEY HAS NO IDEA
WHEN THE WHEN THEY WILL BE GIVEN
SUCH A MOTION THAT HE OR SHE IS
OBLIGATED TO RESPOND.
TO AGAIN RECONCILING THIS
UNFORESEEN TASK WITH OTHER WORK
OR COMMITMENTS THAT MAY BE THEM
INCLUDE COMPETING COURT
OBLIGATIONS COUNCIL MEETING
RESPONSIBILITIES OR DAYS OUT OF
THE OFFICE.
SCHEDULE VACATIONS ARE DUE TO
TEMPORARY ILLNESS -- OR ANY
OTHER CONFLICT REALLY -- THAT IS
NOT UNCOMMON FOR ANY WORKING
PROFESSIONAL.
IRONICALLY OUR WITNESS WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE TODAY WHO
SERVES AS A SOLO IN HOUSE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF SAN
RAMON WAS UNABLE TO BE HERE
BECAUSE IN PART SHE WAS THIRTY
PITCHES MOTION THAT SHE HAS TO
RESPOND.
TO UNDER THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENT.
THE DEFENDANT NEEDS TO SHOW WITH
SPECIFIC FACTUAL SCENARIO OF
POLICE OFFICER MISCONDUCT TO THE
CHARGES THAT THE DEFENDANT IS
FACING IN ORDER TO PREVAIL IN A
PITCHES MOTION.
MAKE THAT LEGAL STANDARD MORE
CONCRETE CITY ATTORNEYS HAVE
SHARED WITH US ANECDOTES THAT
DEFENDANTS HAVE ARGUED THAT THEY
SHOULD LOOK AT AN OFFICER'S
PERSONNEL FILES -- FOR SAYS THE
FORCE COMPLAINTS WHEN THEY ADMIT
THAT THERE WAS NO FORCE USED IN
THEIR REST OR WHERE DEFENDANTS
DON'T DENY THAT THEY COMMITTED
BATTERY.
BUT STILL WANT TO LOOK AT AN
OFFICER'S PERSONNEL FILE FALSE
REPORTS OR WE'RE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY HERSELF ADMITTED SHE
HADN'T EVEN SPOKEN WITH THE
DEFENDANT BUT WAS SURE THAT THE
OFFICERS LIED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED SO SHE FILED A PITCHES
MOTION.
NOW ACCORDING TO SOME OF OUR
CITY ATTORNEYS TO HEAR SOME
DEFENSE COUNSEL'S THEY WOULD
SUGGEST THAT POLICE MISCONDUCT
IS ALWAYS AT PLAY.
AND BUT FOR TIME CONSIDERATIONS
THESE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS WOULD
FILE MORE PITCHESMOTIONS WHILE
THE LEAGUE IS BY NO MEANS
SUGGESTING THAT POLICE MCCARTY
MISCONDUCT DOES NOT TAKE PLACE.
THEY CANNOT BE PRESUME THAT SUCH
MISCONDUCT OCCURS WITH EVERY
ARREST WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY THE
PITCHES PROCESS WITH ESTABLISHED
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT IS
NOTED THAT THE PICTURES PROCESS
APPROPRIATELY BALANCES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DUE PROCESS OF
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS.
ALONG WITH ANOTHER
ONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF PRIVACY
IN PERSONAL FILES.
THIS IS WHY THE COURT REQUIRE
SOME SHOWING BY THE DEFENSE AND
ANY WEIGHING OF THESE INTERESTS.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE HAD
MORE INSIGHT ON THE FREQUENCY.
IN WHICH A DEFENDANT DOES NOT
WAIVE THEIR RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
TRIAL BELIEVES THAT POLICE
MISCONDUCT WOULD BE A REASON FOR
HIS OR HER CONVICTION.
THAT SAID AB SIXTEEN HUNDRED
CAST A WIDE NET IN THAT THE
SHORT NOTICE TIME FRAME WOULD
APPLY TO CRIMINAL ACTIONS --
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER A
DEFENDANT WAIVES HIS OR HER
RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS HOPEFULLY
TOWARD A MORE WORKABLE SOLUTION
BUT AT THIS POINT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
I HAVE WITH ME MY COLLEAGUE
COREY MANNING ASSISTANT GENERAL
COUNSEL AT THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN THE EVENT
THAT THERE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
HIGHLIGHTS IF THERE'S ANOTHER
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DEAR
LUCIEN ON BEHALF OF THE LA
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR MANY MANY MEETINGS IN
NEGOTIATIONS TO TRY AND FIND A
RESOLUTION.
ULTIMATELY I THINK OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN DEALS WITH SECTION FOUR
OF THE BILL WHICH AUTHORIZES.
OF SUPERVISORS PERSONNEL RECORDS
TO BE ACCESSED WE WERE LOOKING.
FOR SOME LANGUAGE THAT -- AT ONE
POINT TIME WAS OFFERED.
TO ENSURE THAT -- JUDGES WOULD
NOT OVERREACH.
ALLOWING DISCLOSURE OF CERTAIN
RECORDS.
ARE TOURNEY'S AT THE LEGAL -- AT
THE LA POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
HAVE YOU KNOW BEEN IN SCENARIOS
WHERE THEY CAN TELL YOU.
ON THE LA COUNTY BENCH WHICH
JUDGES ARE MORE LIKELY.
TO LEAD A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
PERSONNEL FILE OR RECORD BE
ACCESSED -- AND WHICH ONES ARE
LESS LIKELY SO WE WERE LOOKING
FOR A LITTLE BIT MORE CERTAINTY.
WITH THE LANGUAGE AGAIN NOT
INTERESTED IN COVERING OF ANY
TYPE OF MISCONDUCT -- WE WE
BELIEVE THAT SOME GOOD LANGUAGE
WAS OFFERED BUT ULTIMATELY THE
AUTHOR DECIDED THAT -- THERE
THAT LINK WHICH WAS NOT --
SOMETHING THAT THEY WERE
INTERESTED IN AND SO -- WE'RE
WE'RE HOPEFUL TO CONTINUE
TALKING ON THIS TO FIND SOME
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
FAITH BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES AND OUR
COLLEAGUES AT SEA SAKE I A WITH
A LIGHTER COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
THE LEAK RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- RAINY
PERIOD BEHALF PORAC WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND OUR
SPONSORS.
AND BASED ON RECENT AMENDMENTS
WERE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER WINNERS OR
POSED.
OKAY.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE --
COMMENTS QUESTIONS MOTION.
GO AHEAD SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I I HAPPEN
TO HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
MEETING SURE OF PITCHES.
IT JUST SAYS SO IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING TO SEE THIS IN THE
MATERIAL BUT HIS SONS ARE
FRIENDS OF MINE.
A JOHN AND ANDY -- BUT I'M JUST
CURIOUS.
WHAT'S THE PENALTY IF YOU MISS
THE THE DATE IN SIXTEEN DAYS
WHAT.
WHAT ARE THE RAMIFICATIONS IF
YOU DON'T MEET THE DEADLINE?
WHAT I?
LIKE ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
VIOLATIONS OF TIMELINES OF THE
COURT.
A YOU COULD BUILD CONTENT THERE
COULD BE OTHER PENALTIES.
OTHER COULD BE ABOUT A OF A OF A
COURT CAN HOLD THAT ARGUES THAT
IS PART OF THEIR ADVENTURE
PROCESS TO WHETHER THE EVIDENCE
SHOULD BE ADMITTED OR NOT -- SO
IT'S JUST LIKE BY THAT ANY OTHER
COURT RULE I THINK THAT AS A AS
A LAWYER -- I THINK THAT WE TAKE
THOSE RULES IN TIME AS VERY
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE YOU YOU
CERTAINLY CAN BE PENALIZED EVEN
DISBARRED IF YOU CHAU EXCESSIVE --
PATTERNS OF VIOLATING COURT
RULES AND REGULATIONS AND ORDERS.
SO SO MANY.
COLOR WHITE WHY WOULD EVEN TAKE
SIXTEEN DAYS I MEAN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT SEEMS TO ME YOU
COULD DO IT LESS THAN.
THREE THAT'S WHY OF THOSE EVER
SUGGESTING -- TEN SO THAT THERE
CAN BE NO ARGUMENT THAT ARE
ISN'T ENOUGH TIME SIXTEEN DAYS
IS EXCESSIVE ESPECIALLY IF YOU
CONSIDER THE THIRTY DAY TIME NOT
WAYNE JURY TRIAL KEEPING IN MIND
IT'S NOT LIKE DAY.
ONE DAY ONE IS DAVE ARRAIGNMENT
THAT SOMEONE OF PITCHES THE P.
VALUES YOU HAVE TO BE ASSIGNED
TO AN ATTORNEY.
AND THAT AT SOME POINT
SUBSTANTIVE THAT THE TWENTY LOOK
AT THE CASE AND DETERMINE
WHETHER IT BE JUST APPROPRIATE
YOU ALREADY.
AS MUCH AS A COUPLE WEEKS INTO
THAT THIRTY DAYS BEFORE YOU EVEN
GET AROUND TO MAKING A REQUEST
FOR A PITCHES MOTION REVILING
PUSHES MOTION.
THAT'S WHEN IT STARTS THAT.
SO I'M I'M CURIOUS WHAT HAPPENS
IF THE FILE HAS BEEN PURGED.
ALL THAT A EVERY LOOK THE IF IF
THERE ARE FILES THAT HAVE BEEN
REMOVED -- PURGE.
HILL AND THERE'S ALL ACCESS TO
ALLOW ACCESS TO THEM THIS IS
REALLY AN EFFORT. TO UNDER THE
BEST OF CIRCUMSTANCES WERE FILES
ARE AVAILABLE BUT THEY'RE MADE
AVAILABLE.
YOU CAN'T ACCOUNT FOR PAST BAD
BEHAVIOR BUT THERE'S BY
DEPARTMENT IN OFFICER ATTORNEY.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU CAN'T ACCOUNT
FOR THAT -- BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS MAKE SURE WHAT RECORDS DO
EXIST ARE REVEALED APPROPRIATELY
WITH BUT THE JUDGES UNDER THE
JUDGE'S DISCRETION THE JUDGE
STILL OFTEN SHERMAN THAT'S
RELEVANT.
AND SO THE SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW DEFENSE ATTORNEY.
SO THE YOU KNOW.
THE THAT -- INTERESTED THAT
WANTS TO BE RESPECTED BY THE
COURT IS GONNA FILE MOTIONS ON A
BROAD SWATH ON A WIDE.
FISHING EXPEDITION EVERY TIME
AND KEEP IN MIND OF A MOSTLY IS
MOTIONS ABOUT A PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ARE PART OF THE SAME JUDGES.
DAY IN DAY OUT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
AND SO -- AND FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
YOU WANT TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
ABOUT HOW AGGRESSIVE YOU ARE
WITH THESE TYPES OF MOTIONS IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR
AND HOW BOUT OF AND THAT.
THAT YOU WOULD ACTUALLY PUT OUT
THERE BECAUSE IF YOU COULD
BECOME KNOWN AS SOMEONE THAT'S
IS SEEKING FISHING EXPEDITIONS
ON EVERY SINGLE MOTION YOUR LAST
LESS LIKELY TO GET ANY.
EVIDENCE REDUCE YOUR TO HAVE ANY
OF THESE MOTIONS GRANTED
REGARDLESS WITH PURCHASE OR
OTHERWISE.
THANK YOU THINK I AM NOT A
LAWYER SO I THOUGHT I'D BURKE.
BURKE FORGET PRESENTS A VERY
LARGE ISSUE THE QUESTIONS BUT
I'M HAPPY TO MEET TO MOVE THE
BILL.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION -- WITHOUT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
I WANT TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUST MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE THE SUN
MORE LIKE FOR THE MOTION AND
REALLY APPRECIATE PORAC AS WELL
AS WITH SOME OF THOSE A SPOKEN
OPPOSITION THAT REALLY DIDN'T
WORKING WITH US TO TRY TO WORK
ON LANGUAGE AND CONCERNS -- THIS
BILL DOES NOTHING TO ALTER THE
STANDARD BY WHICH I JUDGE
USUALLY USES AND DETERMINING
WHAT THE RECORDS ARE RELEVANT
NOTS THE PROTECTION OF THE
OFFICERS RECORDS IS NOT ALTERED
IN THAT REGARD WHATSOEVER AND SO
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY BOOK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR LET'S DO ROLL CALL SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I BRADFORD JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE.
WIENER RIGHT WIENER AYE.
RIGHT BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO REMEMBER CAR LET'S
GO TO ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW -- IN MAY BE WILL BE
ABLE TO FINISH BEFORE CAUCUS
WILL SEE NEVER LIKE TO RUSH ANY
BILLS ONE EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE PROPER DISCRETION
BUT SIGNATURE GATHERS WITH
RESPECT ASK PRIVATE.
HER EIGHT WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY BHAMA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS LET
THAT BEA LESSON TO ME WE ARE
VERY STRONG SUPPORTERS MEASURE
AS WE HAVE PREVIOUS MEASURES.
OF DRIVER. FOR LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WHERE ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OKAY OPPOSITION.
AND PLEASE YOU'RE WELCOME TO
COME TO THE TABLE.
YOU CAN GET RIGHT THERE -- CAM
IS ABOUT ME YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LEAVE BUT SO IF YOU [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AT COMMITTEE --
TRENT LAYING OUT PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN --
BUT WE VERY MUCH OF A SHARE OF
THE GOALS OF THE LIMITING --
CURBING ABUSES OF THE INITIAL
PROCESS BY SPECIAL INTERESTS
THAT'S WHY WE WORKED ON THE
CALIFORNIA'S GOES ACT FOR FOR SO
LONG AND AND AND MANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN THAT
SO THAT THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHO IS
PAYING FOR BALLOT MEASURE ADS.
ON THAT'S WHY WE ARE WORKING.
ON AND AND MY MOST MEMBERS HERE.
ABOUT IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
SEVEN THE PETITION DISCLOSE ACTS
SO THAT WHEN INITIATIVE
SIGNATURE GATHERERS -- APPROACH
YOU DO KNOW WHO IS PAYING FOR
THEM THEY HAVE TO BE TRUTHFUL IN
THAT REGARD -- HE THE THE ITEMS
IN THE BILL WERE NOT NECESSARILY
OPPOSED TO IN CONCEPT THE
PROBLEM IS.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WHICH IS WHY THE WE YOU WHEN
VOTERS AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
GROUPS SHARE OUR ARE CONCERNED.
THE THE PROBLEM IS THE TWO FOLD
THERE'S THE THE 10% THRESHOLD
REQUIRED FOR VOLUNTEERS AND
ESSENTIALLY NONPROFIT STAFF TO
QUALIFY FOR TRUE GRASSROOTS --
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE REALLY
USING.
VOLUNTEERS THAT WILL BE VERY
CHALLENGING THRESHOLD IN THE SIX
MONTH PERIOD THAT YOU HAVE FOR
THE NATIONAL PROCESS.
ESPECIALLY.
IF IT HAPPENS TO BE RAINY SEASON
DURING THOSE SIX MONTHS FOR REAL
VOLUNTEERS TO GET THAT MANY
SIGNATURES -- AND THEN SECONDLY
POSSIBLY EVEN MORE CONCERNING IS
THE BAN ON PAYMENTS FOR
SIGNATURE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ABILITY OF GRASSROOTS
INITIATIVES REAL INITIATIVES.
THAT ARE NOT SUPPORTED BY
BILLION ERRORS OR OR SUPER --
WEALTHY CORPORATIONS -- IT WILL
INCREASE THE COST A IN IN SUCH A
WAY THAT THAT. ONE EXAMPLE IT
WAS A KEY PART OF A FLORIDA BILL
THAT WAS JUST PASSED AND SIGNED
INTO LAW IN FLORIDA WHO HAD THE
VERY TRANSPARENT PURPOSE.
OF WARNING THE CITIZENS INITIAL
PROCESS IN FLORIDA.
AND I'LL JUST QUOTE FROM A
COUPLE OF FLORIDA NEWSPAPER AS
THEIR THE SARASOTA HERALD
TRIBUNE DESCRIBED THE BILL THEY
PASS WOULD MAKE IT A CRIME. TO
PAY PETITION GATHERERS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES THEY
COLLECT.
THAT CHANGE THAT EXPERTS SAY
WILL LIKELY DOUBLE THE COST OF
GETTING PROPOSALS ON THE BALLOT.
AND THAT IS PRECISELY WHY THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE INCLUDED
THAT AS A KEY PROVISION OF THEIR
BILL THAT OTHER HEADLINES
IMPORTED SAID FLORIDA LAWMAKERS
PLACE BARRIERS TO BALLOT
INITIATIVES IT WAS THE THIRD
SOARED HIGH HERALD TRIBUNE.
DORLAND A WEEKLY FLORIDA
LAWMAKERS WANT TO MAKE IT HARDER
FOR SEARCHES OF THE MISSION IS
TO GET ON THE BALLOT.
IT GOES ON AND ON SOME OF MORE
MUCH MORE DESCRIPTIVE NEGATIVE
IN TERMS OF THEIR GOALS TO
THWART THE CITIZENS INITIATIVE
PROCESS WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
THE AUTHORS CALL.
WE ABSOLUTELY I APPRECIATE THAT --
AND WE'VE BEEN HAPPY TO BE
TALKING WITH HIM ABOUT POSSIBLE.
SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEM ONE
WOULD BE TO TO TO JUST LOWER THE
THRESHOLD AND AND NOT HAVE THE
BAN ON PAYMENTS PER SIGNATURE SO
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT INCREASE IN
COSTS.
ANOTHER OPTION THAT WE'VE TALKED
WITH HIM.
THE OTHER EIGHT STATES THAT BAND
PAYMENTS PER SIGNATURE ALL HAVE
A MINIMUM OF ONE YEAR FOR
SIGNATURES TO BE GATHERED ONE
YEAR IN MANY CASES TWO YEARS
ARIZONA OREGON FLORIDA ALL HAVE
TWO YEAR PERIODS ACTUALLY
PERSISTENCE TO QUALIFY.
IF YOU HAD THAT THEN -- THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO THAT WOULD
MAKE UP FOR THE ADDED COSTS OF
BANNING PAYMENTS.
UPPER SIGNATURE AND ALLOW TRUE
VOLUNTEER BECAUSE TRUE VOLUNTEER
CAMPAIGNS WOULD HAVE MORE TIME.
TO GET SIGNATURES UNPAID WHICH
IS I THINK WHAT WE WOULD ALL
WANT AND WHICH IS THE PURPOSE OF
THE SIGNATURE GATHERING OUT
PROCESS SO WITH THAT WE RICK
RESPECTFULLY WE'RE HAPY TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR BUT BUT
WE SUPPOSE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAID
DAVID WOLF BARRETT JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE AS WE WERE AT MISTER
LOW'S BILL -- LAST YEAR WHICH
DID BASICALLY THE SAME THANKS --
MADAM CHAIR LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
THERE IS TOO MUCH MONEY
[inaudible]
IN POLITICS.
WE ALL WE ALL AGREE.
RIGHT.
WE ALL AGREE THAT WE WANT TO SEE
REDUCTIONS IN THE COST TO
QUALIFY A ALLOT MEASURE FOR THE
BALLOT.
IT'S ABSURD THAT IT TAKES THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO QUALIFY A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT FOR THE
BALLOT.
WE WANT TO SEE DECREASES IN THAT
WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR I AGREE
WITH MISTER LANG.
REPEAT SIX THAT WE ALL.
THAT WE ALL WANT TO SEE THIS.
THERE'S A FIRST TIME FOR
EVERYTHING MEMBERS -- WE ALL
WANT TO SEE THIS.
OKAY.
A BUT DOES THIS BILL REALLY
STRIKE AT THE SOLUTION TO THAT
PROBLEM BANNING PAID SIGNATURES
AND MOVING TO AN HOURLY RATE.
YOU MAY HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THERE ARE ACTUALLY
INCREASING MONEY IN POLITICS NOT
DECREASING IT SO WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT WE'RE NOT
SURE IF THIS ABSOLUTELY FIXES
THE PROBLEM.
AND WE AGREE WITH MR LYING AS WE
SAID IN OUR OPPOSITION LETTER
THAT INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
TIME TO GATHER SIGNATURES FROM
SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR WILL
ABSOLUTELY FUNDAMENTALLY
DECREASE MONEY IN POLITICS.
LISTEN WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS IN OUR
ASSOCIATION -- WE CAN GO OUT AND
YOU KNOW USE VOLUNTEERS GET
SIGNATURES FROM THAT.
BUT WE NEED MORE TIME TO DO IT
IT'S VERY HARD TO MOBILIZE ALL
THAT IN SIX MONTHS YOU GIVE US A
YEAR.
IT MAKES IT FAR MORE LIKELY WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS SO WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR JUST AS WE SAID WE
WOULD LAST YEAR.
ON THIS ISSUE AND HOPE WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE FROM MAYBE WE CAN
COME OFF THIS BILL BUT IN THE
MEANTIME ASK FOR NOVA.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YEP THAT -- THIS TIME I
REPRESENTING KARA.
ALL IN A BUNCH OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN TELLING YOU THE
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES
LEGISLATURE'S WERE STRONGLY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS THING WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
WITH A ONE MINUTE OUT OF BREATH
PRESENTATION RUNNING UP FROM
JUDICIARY NO I'VE HEARD FROM TWO
IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST OF THIS
YEAR. THIRTY SECONDS SURE TO BE
A SUMMER THERE WITH CAL CHAMBER
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU FOR INTELLIGENCE.
WE DID ONE ADDRESS THAT WHILE
THE FINDINGS DO AND TO SUGGEST
THIS BILL IS TO JUST THE
PERCEPTION OF SIGNATURE
GATHERING ISSUES AND FRAUD.
PERCEPTION IS NOT SUPPORTED BY
DATA AND I DO WONDER AND POINT
OUT THAT THE COMMITTEE DID
CORRECTLY -- POINT OUT THAT THE
MISREPRESENTATION OR FRAUD IS
ALREADY A MISDEMEANOR UNDER THE
LAW AND WE DO NOT THINK THAT
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO AFFECT
THE PURPOSES THEY WERE PUT UP BY
THE BILL SO WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RED X. CALIFORNIA GREEN PARTY
SECOND COUNTY GREEN PARTY IN
OPPOSITION WAS AMENDED.
HIS INTERNET STOCKTON STRONGLY --
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
RIA DEGROOT STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA'S STRONGLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
SHELLY CAROL CONSTITUENT FROM
SAN FRANCISCO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
GREG PENNINGTON SAN FRANCISCO
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
SEVERAL LONGER IN MOUNTAIN VIEW
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
NANCY NFL OUT OF ME.
TO KATHY VARGAS DAVIS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANKS.
ESTHER SISTAN DAVIS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
CAROL CANCER OF GROW CALIFORNIA
POSE LESS AMENDED.
CAROLINE RAN PALO ALTO OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED.
WHEN HE REFORM TO CREATE
THERE'LL?
HE NARAL FERRE SAN JOSE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
DAN BERMAN DAVIS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
CHRIS HAMBLETON FROM BERKELEY I
CAME UP TODAY I WANTED TO SEE MY
HIGHLY RESPECTED SENATOR
INACTION.
BUT I AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED.
CAROL BADGER SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE OPPOSE UNLESS REFINED
THANK YOU.
SURELY SHOWING DUSKY FROM
PLEASANT HILL AND I'M WITH THE
MONEY OUT.
MONEY OUT PEOPLE IN AND
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
ALLEN MARLING NANCY CENTERS
CONSTITUENT OPPOSE MY CEMENTED.
THAT'S WHEN OAKLAND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
MARY KILL STANFORD OPPOSE LISTEN
AND M. E. GREATEST OPPOSE.
UNLESS AMENDED I'M FROM DAVIS.
GARY APPEL MILL VALLEY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
RUSSELL REAGAN FROM DAVIS
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
KAREN BACK FROM DANVILLE SAME
SEE SAID AND ALSO PLEASE DON'T
MAKE IT ANY HARDER FOR US TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES THANK YOU.
OKAY CORRAL SACRAMENTO AS AN
ACTIVIST IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS I MUST
POSE THIS BILL UNLESS IT IS
APPROPRIATELY AMENDED THANK YOU.
THAT FAX FROM OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
PLEASE OPPOSE THIS.
I OPPOSE THIS UNLESS AMENDED.
JENNIFER HAGEE SAN FRANCISCO I
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
DON CURRY MENLO PARK OPPOSE.
RICHARD ROSE DAVIS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE CELESTE AMENDED.
SHANE MCLEOD OF SACRAMENTO AND
REPRESENTING MONEY OUT VOTERS IN
A POSE THE MOST AMENDED TO ONE
YEAR THANK YOU.
ANDREW MUSICIAN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRISTOPHER LESS THUNDER FELL
PLEASE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
LARRY BATHGATE MILL VALLEY.
PLEASE OPPOSE LIST AMENDED THANK
YOU.
KEVIN LOVE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA THE MANY ACTION FUND.
POSE UNLESS AMENDED.
A ROBBER COUPLE SECOND A TEAM
SHOULD BE -- PULLED A LIST
AMENDED THANK YOU.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COURAGE
CAMPAIGN AND ARE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS.
A MOST ALL OF WHOM I WAS ABLE TO
PERSUADE NOT TO COME TODAY.
A OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
HER.
EIGHT COMMITTEE BACK TO OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WELL I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD.
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL -- WE JUST
WANT TO MENTION THA WERE
WORKING WITH SOME OF OUR
AFFILIATES TO DEAL WITH ONE
OUTSTANDING REMAINING CONCERN
HAVING TO DO WITH THE
DIFFERENTLY COLORED PETITIONS --
HOPEFULLY THAT GET TAKEN CARE OF
AND WE COME BACK ON AND SUPPORT
WE'VE SPONSORED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION IN THE PAST DEALING
WITH THE ACTIVISTS THRESHOLD.
WE THINK IT'S FANTASTIC WAY TO
HELP RETURN THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS BACK TO THE WAY THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING BACK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EVE CERTAIN AND MANY
OF THE PEOPLE ON THE COMMITTEE
ALREADY GET EMAIL FROM ME THAT
STARTS WITH NEW LAWS IN THE
SUBJECT LINE -- THAT'S A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE UP AND DOWN CALIFORNIA
WHOARE FIGHTING ILLEGAL
FORECLOSURES AND ILLEGAL
EVICTIONS AFTER FORECLOSURES.
IT'LL BE A MERE OPPOSE OR NOT
YES SO PLEASE OPPOSE INVESTMENT
BANKING [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
CENTER WIENER.
HERE ON OUR TO THE AUTUMN THIS
IS -- IS A THORNY SUBJECT
BECAUSE DE THE ABUSES.
WHAT THE SIGNATURE GATHERING ARE
IT'S JUST?
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU COMBINE
SOMEONE WAS LIKE -- FIFTEEN
PETITIONS AND AN ARTIST.
OFTEN DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
SIGNING LIKE TO GO ON AND ON
ABOUT.
HELD BROKEN THE BALLOT MEASURE
SYSTEM AS IS ALSO.
DISTINCTION BETWEEN STATE AND
LOCAL ART FOR AYE AYE.
I THINK.
IN TERMS OF WHEN THE LAST
VOLUNTEER DRIVEN STATEWIDE
MEASURE QUALIFIED HASN'T BEEN
LIKE THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY ON FORCING
IMPOSSIBLE -- INTO STATEWIDE
BALLOT MEASURES SYSTEM.
IN CALIFORNIA IS SUCH A TOXIC
DISASTER AND THE VOTERS SEE IT
WHEN.
WE SEE WHAT MAKES ON THE BALLOT
ALLIES LIKE WISE OR AN AMBULANCE.
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT RIGHT IT
SAYS BECAUSE CORPORATIONS
COMPLETE WHATEVER THEY WANT ON
THE BALLOT LOCALLY OF COURSE
IT'S IT'S DIFFERENT.
LOCAL BALLOT MEASURES WE STILL
SEE VOLUNTEER DRIVEN SO IT'S A
IT'S A MIXED.
BAG SO I GUESS I'D TO THE AUTHOR
IF YOU WOULD PROFS JUST RESPOND
TO SOME OF THE SPECIFIC I GUESS
THE TO SPECIFIC CRITICS.
OF FROM THE OPPONENTS ABOUT 10%
AND ABOUT THE ONE YEAR VERSUS
SIX MONTHS.
YES -- AS WE OF A SIMILE STATED
IN PRESENTATION AND SENATE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE -- AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AS WELL WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE THE
BEST THE TYPE OF PRODUCT THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US AS IN NOTED
INCOME NOW SAYS THIS IS.
BEEN A SUBJECT OF MANY
ITERATIONS OF BEFORE AND
INCLUDING FROM THE SENATOR AND
PREVIOUSLY FROM CENTER NEWMAN.
ABOUT WE LEAVE THAT THIS IS THE
BEST A COMPROMISE APPROACHED HIM
ENSURING THAT TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY --
AT THE HEART OF THIS WAS SUCH
THAT -- AYE SIMILE WAS
APPROACHED BY SOMEONE OUTSIDE A
TRADER JOE'S AND THEY SAID I DO
WANT TO STOP THE TYRANNY OF THE
SACRAMENTO POLITICIANS AND I
SAID EXCUSE ME PLEASE.
INFORM ME ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING -- TO AND OF COURSE --
WHEN THEY START TALKING ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION REVENUES GAS TAX
THEY SAID THAT THIS SEGMENT OF
POLITICIANS WE'RE GOING TO USE
IT TO BALANCE THE BUDGET IN
OTHER AREAS AND I SAID I THINK
YOU'RE FACTUALLY INCORRECT? TO
WHICH THAT PETITION TOGETHER
IMMEDIATELY STOPPED AND WENT TO
THE NEXT INDIVIDUAL TO TRY TO
PERSUADE THEM TO ALSO SIGNED
THAT PETITION IT'S CLEAR THAT
WHEN INCENTIVIZE -- PAID BY
SIGNATURE UP TIGHT UPWARDS OF
TEN DOLLARS A SIGNATURE A THERE
IS NO INCENTIVE TO TALK ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY AND HAVE A ROBUST
DIALOGUE CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT.
RATHER THAT OF THE HEART
SIGNATURE AND I WITNESSED THAT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN SIMILARLY SO
AGAIN THAT THIS IS NOT THIS DID
THAT JUST HAPPEN OVERNIGHT AT
THIS BEEN.
MANY ITERATIONS OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO WHICH IS IN CAPS
LATE BEFORE CJ AND BOUNCE THE
PROVISION I THINK A WITH THE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES HERE.
ACCURATELY REFLECTS THAT OF
COURSE WILL BE COMPETING
MEASURES BUT AS YOU HEARD WE'VE
BEEN I TRYING TO WORK AS MUCH IN
GOOD FAITH AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO WITH THE INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION -- SHOULD THIS TO
MOVE FORWARD AND SPECIFIC IN
TERMS OF THE SIX MONTHS VERSUS
TWELVE MONTHS COULD JUST COMMENT
ON THAT YES -- I BELIEVE THAT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME -- AT
CHALLENGES WITH THE BE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES -- BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT THAT TIME
FRAME AT THIS POINT IS --
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO SEE
MOVE FORWARD AS THE BILL
PRESENTED BUT OF COURSE WILL BE
CONTINUALLY HAPPY TO TALK TO
OPPOSITION SHOULD THIS MOVE.
FOR CENTER WIENER DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTION SIR OKAY ANY
OTHER FROM THE DíAS -- I JUST
WONDER EXPRESS I APPRECIATE.
THE FOLKS.
AND COMING TO THE HEARING AND
TESTIFYING AND THE CONCERN THAT.
THE BILL WOULD -- BASICALLY
FAVOR MONEYED INTERESTS IN TERMS
OF THE N. INITIATIVE GATHERING.
PROCESS AND I THINK THIS IS ONE
OF THESE FUNDAMENTAL WHERE IT'S
KIND OF IT -- I CAN SEE I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THAT OCCURS
BUT IT DOESN'T SEEM VERY
PROBABLE TO ME ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SUCH A
HUGE STATE [inaudible]
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE ENTIRE
INITIATIVE PROCESS IS SKEWED
TOWARDS MONEYED INTERESTS.
AND HAVING.
OF HAVING THE INDIVIDUAL PAID
SIGNATURE [inaudible]
IT'S AT IT ALLOWS FOR THOSE
MONIED INTERESTS TO BE BE ABLE
ALMOST UNLIMITED NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE -- TO THEN COLLECT
SIGNATURES AND THEY HAVE A GREAT
INCENTIVE BECAUSE THEY ARE AT
PAID PER SIGNATURE.
MOST OF OUR GRASSROOTS EFFORTS
PEOPLE ARE MOTIVATED OBVIOUSLY
BY.
MORE THAN MONEY IN TERMS OF THAT
SIGNATURE GATHERING PROCESS IS
STILL GOING TO BE DIFFICULT FOR
GRASSROOTS EFFORTS -- TO GET
THINGS ON A BALLOT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE'VE KNOWN
THAT FOR A LONG TIME I DON'T
KNOW.
QUITE WHAT REFORMS WE'D HAVE TO
DO TO DEAL WITH THAT GIVEN THAT
WE ARE A STATE OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE -- BUT I AM WILLING TO
HAVE THE BILL MOVE.
AND I DO APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
SHOWING UP AND I DON'T MEAN TO
INVALIDATE THEIR CONCERNS BUT I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE WHERE
IT'S A. -- WHETHER WE FEEL THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL PAYING PER
INDIVIDUAL SIGNATURE OR MAKE IT
LET MORE EXPENSIVE OR PAYING
FROM BY OUR IN FACT AND I THINK
THAT'S THE THAT'S THOSE ARE.
THE LEGITIMATE DEBATABLE POINT
[inaudible]
ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR THE
DIALOGUE AND JUST WANT TO
REITERATE AND WE FROM THE POINT
THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN STILL BE
PAID BY STIPEND AND OUR HOURLY
SO -- INDIVIDUAL STILL HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT AGAIN JUST NOT
TO BE INCENTIVIZE BY THAT
SIGNATURES THAT WE CAN HAVE A
ROBUST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
INTEGRITY.
OF THE PROPOSITIONS OF POTENTIAL
OPPOSITION THAT WE HOPE TO SEE
ON THE BALLOT AND HOPE NOT TO
SEE SO OF WITH RESPECT TO ASK
THE PRIVATE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION I
BELIEVE NO YES NO OKAY IS THERE
A MOTION.
WE'LL GO.
RIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD IS MOVED
THE BILL -- LET'S DO A ROLL CALL.
IT SAYS THE MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S TO ROLL
CALL SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE NOW BRADFORD PARK
BRADFORD AYE JACKSON.
MITCHELL MORALE.
ROSE SAID NO.
NOW WINNER OR NOT VOTING OKAY
ALREADY SIXTEEN OCT POLITIES.
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL -- IT IS
LIKELY THAT WE WON'T OPEN UP
CALL UNTIL AFTER ACT CAUCUS.
ON JUST TO GIVE YOU INFORMATION%
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR ONE MORE
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO IS.
THEN WE WILL HAVE TO BREAK FOR
CAUCUS AND I WILL GIVE THE
INFORMATION AS TO WHEN WE WILL
CONVENE AGAIN AFTER WE HEAR --
AND BEFORE WE BEGIN -- AND I
KNOW YOU PRIDE CAN OPEN WITH
THIS BUT I JUST WANTED -- TO
CLEAR BECAUSE IT HELPS GET IT
OUT OF THE WAY.
THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT -- I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE AGREEING TO
TAKE WOULD DELETE SUBSECTIONS
FIVE THROUGH.
TEN SO EVERYTHING FROM PAGE --
THREE LINE NINE THREE PAGE FOUR
LINE THIRTEEN SO THAT IT FOCUSES
ON THE AB PERSON IMPERSONATING A
CENSUS WORKER.
YES MA'AM.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'LL BE BRIEF --
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE WOULD
MAKE IT A MISDEMEANOR FALSELY
REPRESENT ONESELF AS A CENSUS.
TAKER OR OTHERWISE INTERFERE
WITH THE CENSUS WHAT'S AT STAKE
IS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CALIFORNIA IN EACH ONE OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
I HAVE WITH THE SOME WITNESSES --
AND THINKING MANAGER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GO
AHEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME IS A FAMOUS GO BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
WE ARE ALSO SERVE AS ONE OF THE
STATE. TEN ADMINISTRATIVE CBO'S
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP ON THE
CENSUS IN HERE TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL WE WE KNOW FROM REPORTS ON
THE GROUND WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFUSION AND MISINFORMATION OUT
THERE.
WE'VE SEEN IT IN ELECTIONS AND
ADDING THE SECTIONS THE BILL.
THIS ONLY REINFORCES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO A
FREE.
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT CENSUS
PROCESS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IF THE
MARK ON BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY
STATE OUT EXPEDIA WE WANTED TO
THANK STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND THE AUTHOR AND ALL THOSE
INVOLVED.
A WE HAVE NO OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL THIS TIME WE PLANNED
IT TAKE A SUPPORT AND APOLOGIZE
FOR THE LACK OF A LETTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ALL
YOUR WORK.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IT'S IMPORTANT CHIRLA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GREAT.
OTHERS.
ALL RIGHT TO WEAR ANY WORDS IN
OPPOSITION.
ON SEEING. NINE FIVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
DíAS HEY WE HAVE A MOTION.
SIMILAR OVER SANTIAGO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL.
RIGHT SO THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WHAT DO A ROLL CALL SKINNER HI
SKINNER I'M MORE LACKEY?
BADFORD BRADFORD AYE JACKSON
MITCHELL MORALE.
WELL NOW WINNER.
WIENER HIGH GREAT WILL HAVE THE
BILL ON CALL.
AND WE ARE GOING -- TO RECESS
AND I WAS GONNA ASK.
OUR VICE CHAIR WE HAVE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS WHO HAVE TO PRESENT
BILLS AT ONE THIRTY AND OTHER
COMMITTEES WE WOULD NORMALLY.
COME BACK AT ONE THIRTY BUT I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY WISE FOR US
TO DELAY THAT -- IF THAT'S
POSSIBLE IS THIS ROOM AND WE
HAVE A THE WHOLE TIME SO.
AS SOON AS SENATOR WIENER YOU UP
TO BILLS YOU HAVE 2% DO YOU
THINK.
TO THIRTY I NOTE.
YEAH I KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE
CHAIRING A COMMITTEE BUT WE
WOULD JUST HAVE TO OPEN ROLE HOW
YOU WORKED OKAY THAT'S NOT TILL
TOMORROW OKAY.
OKAY.
ON EITHER ONE OF THE YEAH I MAY
NOT BE DONE BY [inaudible]
TWO THE LOCAL.
YOU NEVER KNOW SO I THINK WE
WILL RETURN AT TWO THIRTY AND WE
WILL BE IN THIS ROOM. THREE ONE
NINE ONE AND WE'RE RECESSING
UNTIL.
TWO THIRTY THANKS SO MUCH
WERE
IN NEED OF AN AUTHOR.
AND THE WE COULD RE OPEN THE
ROLE SINCE MISTER BRADFORD WORKS
IN BECAUSE WE CAN GET THAT DONE
.
TO ARE THEY GOT.
KNOCKED OUT POWER.
WE HAVE OUR BECAUSE LET SOME
OPEN THE ROLE LIFT SOME CALLS.
OKAY LET HISTORY YEAH -- ITEM.
ONE AB THIRTY TWO BONTA MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT ABOUT IS. TO TO TO CHAIR
VOTING I'D BRADFORD [inaudible]
BRADFORD HI.
BILLION MISSING OKAY KEEP GOING.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- JACKSON
MITCHELL MOREAU [inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
WELL I ITEM THREE EIGHTY THREE
FORTY IRWIN MOTIONS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS TO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING HI BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HIGH MORALE.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE AS A THREE FORTY ITEM
FOUR EIGHTY THREE NINETY SEVEN
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT IS TWO TO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING HIGH.
BRADFORD.
HIGH MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM FIVE AB FIVE ONE SIX MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
VOTERS TO TO SHARE VOTING I THE
WINNER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
ITEM SIX EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT PHONE IS
THREE TO ZERO CHAIR VOTING HI
MOORLACH.
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE NO
AROUND THEM.
ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FIVE SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS YOU
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS.
THREE TO ONE CARE VOTING HI.
SORRY WE GOT EVERYBODY IS HERE.
I AM. EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TO PASS AS A TWO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ONE
CHAIR VOTING I MORE LOCKED
[inaudible]
NOTHING.
THESE BILLS ARE STILL GOING TO
BE ON CALL KEEP GOING.
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY
SIX MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
IS. THREE ZERO JACKSON THAT
TOMORROW [inaudible]
AROUND THEM.
IN THIRTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
HI SKINNER AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I DO PASSES AMENDED
YOURSELF THAT RIGHT YEAH OKAY
SORRY SEC MORRELL.
BROWN AND WIENER I WIENER AYE.
I AM FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT FILE IS
THREE TWO ZERO MORALE.
AROUND NOW.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE WE HAVE THAT.
ONE ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE IS.
THREE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI.
I AM EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE TO ONE CARE VOTING I
JACKSON MITCHELL.
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED OCEAN IS TO PASS THE
FLOOR CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TWO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I'VE BRADFORD.
HI MORALE.
AROUND NOW.
I AM TWENTY NO THAT'S NOT.
RIGHT -- TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE.
IS THREE TO TWO CHAIR VOTING I
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE.
AND THEN THE VOTE ONLY ITEM
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ALL AROUND MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THIS.
FORTY ZERO MORALE [inaudible]
I ALL RIGHT.
WE ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO --
TO PRESENTER BILL.
SO REMEMBER CREE ARE YOU READY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE HAVE A BUNCH MEMBERS HAVE TO
GO PRESENTED OTHER COMMITTEES.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
VERY PROUD TO BE HERE TODAY. TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE BILL
THAT ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND WOULD CREATE AN EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT REENTRY PROGRAM. TO
BE OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS OF PROVIDE
VALUABLE JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
INDIVIDUALS.
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL THEY WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PROVIDE
HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS BY OFFERING A TRUE
PATH TO A LIVING WAGE JOB.
THE MOVES ARE STATE FORWARD.
ON CRITICAL RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
OBJECTIVES FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE A RANGE
OF SINCERE CHALLENGES WHEN RE
INTEGRATING BACK TO SOCIETY.
SUCH AS REDUCE TIES TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES AND
OFTENTIMES BARRIERS TO HOUSING
AND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT PULLS
RELEASE.
IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF CURLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE SERVING
PRISON FIRE HAND CREWS THAT WILD
FIRE SCENES.
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS WHILE
HELPING TO MANAGE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES.
WHICH HAVE UNFORTUNATELY BECOME
THE NEW NORMAL FOR OUR STATE.
IN FACT ON JUNE THIRTY FIRST OF
LAST YEAR DURING THE CAR FIRE
THE FERGUSON FIRE AND THE
MINUTES YOU KNOW COMPLEX FIRE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
TWEETED.
TODAY MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
VOLUNTEER IN ME FIREFIGHTERS
INCLUDING FIFTY EIGHT USE
OFFENDERS.
ARE BATTLING A WILDFIRE FLAMES
WELL CALIFORNIA INMATE
FIREFIGHTERS SERVE A VITAL ROLE
CLEARING THE BRUSH DOWN TO BARE
SOIL. TO STOP THE FIRE SPREAD
AND QUOTE.
MEMBERS THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO DO
THIS WORK HAVE OFTEN RECEIVE THE
TRAINING EXPERIENCE AND HAVE THE
SKILLS THAT REAL EMPLOYMENT
VALUE.
IN THE CRITICAL AREAS OF REAL OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT
FUEL IN VEGETATION CONTROL AND
DISASTER SUPPORT.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE FOLLOWING.
THE COMPLETION OF THEIRS
FOLLOWING THE COMPLETION OF
THEIR SENTENCE THESE INDIVIDUALS
CAN UTILIZE THE SKILLS THEY HAVE
ATTAINED THROUGH THE ALREADY
EXISTING.
CONSERVATION CAMP PROGRAM
OPERATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS A WAY.
FOR CALIFORNIA IT IS A STEP
FORWARD IN INCREASING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES REDUCING
RECIDIVISM AND HELPING OUR STATE
OUR ALLOW.
ME WITNESSES HERE TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS BILL FOR
YOU.
AND WITH YOUR INDULGENCE MADAM
CHAIR WOULD JUST LIKE THANK YOU
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK WITH US EVEN UP UNTIL THE
LAST MINUTE.
I'M TO COME TO SOME AGREEMENT ON
AMENDMENT WHICH WE ARE HAPPY TO
TO ADD TO THE BILL.
WE REALLY -- OUR MEMBERS.
RECOGNIZE THE WORK AND THE
TRAINING THAT THESE HAND IN MAY
HAND CREWS GO THROUGH ON THEIR
INCARCERATED -- THEY'RE DOING
HARD WORK WELL THEY'RE
INCARCERATED ON ON FIRE LINES --
AND WE REALLY WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TO FIND A
PATH FOR THEM TO USE THE
TRAINING THAT THEY THAT THEY
WENT THROUGH AND BOB THEY WERE
INCARCERATED AND AND FIND AN
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THEM A GOOD JOB --
AND WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY SORT
OF MAYBE FALSE HOPE FOR UP TO AN
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY IN THE
PAST WE REALLY WANT THIS TO LEAD
TO MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT.
BUT THESE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND WE THINK THIS
BILL IS A IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP.
BUT OUR LEADERSHIP AND OUR
MEMBERS HAVE DECIDED TO TAKE ON
THIS YEAR AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE -- AND
AND OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
HELPING US GET THERE WE WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU.
NATASHA MINSKER FOR SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA WE ARE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT I AM
PROUD TO BE AN ALLIANCE WITH A
PUBLIC SAFETY UNION THAT IS
LEADING AN EFFORT TO EXPAND.
JOB OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COME JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
YOUR SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
CHEN MEMBERS [inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION JUST IN
CASE I HAVE TO ASK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN FOR THE
SPONSORS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TAKING THEM AND
IT'S KIND OF MINOR BUT AT LEAST
I THINK IT.
I'M.
JUST.
GOOD EDITION AND I THINK OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICANTS REVISION
COURSE A GREAT PLACE FOR
TRAINING AS WE'VE SEEN IT
ALREADY PROVIDE REALLY
INCREDIBLE TRAINING AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR MANY MANY PEOPLE SO AND WITH
THAT I MANY BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND I WANNA SEE IF ANYBODY
ELSE'S ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OR MOTION.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB --
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IT'S GOOD
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
NEW NORMAL FOR CALIFORNIA ALSO
INCLUDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED.
THE TRAINING THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS HAS INVESTED IN THEM
ALREADY TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR A GOOD JOB THIS IS A GOOD
STEP FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE.
SO I SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS ARE.
WE'LL TAKE A ROLL CALL AND THAT
IS DUE PASSED. TO APPROVE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
YEAH HI THERE I MOORLACH.
LIKE I BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
JACKSON MITCHELL MORALE.
MORRELL AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THANK YOU IT'S ON CALL WE'RE
MISSING A FEW PEOPLE WERE
BRINGING HIM BACK NOW
.
WE ARE RE OPENING THE ROLE
[inaudible]
LET'S GO.
ITEM.
ONE ITEM ONE A. B. THIRTY TWO TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT BOTH
TREATED TO CHARITY HI JACKSON HI
JACKSON HIGH.
CONSENT CALENDAR JACKSON FIVE
JACKSON.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY THREE FORTY
TWO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THREE FIVE ZERO JACKSON AYE
JACKSON AYE.
AB THREE NINETY SEVEN EIGHT TO
PASS AS A MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO
JACKSON AYE JACKSON.
GREAT RIGHT WONDERFUL GO AHEAD I
KEEP GOING ITEM FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO TWO CHAIR VOTING AYE
JACKSON [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MITCHELL AYE.
THIS WAS AB FIVE SIXTEEN DID YOU
WANT TO PAY OFF YEAH OKAY FINE
NO WORRIES.
AB FIVE SIXTEEN IS OUT NOW.
422-685-21 MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE CHAIR VOTING I
JACKSON HIGH JACKSON AYE
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE.
ALL RIGHT -- AB FIVE TWENTY ONE
IS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE I KNOW SEVEN AB SIX
FIVE SIX MOTIONS TO PASS OF
CORPORATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE CHAIR VOTING AYE
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE -- AB SIX FIVE SIX
IS NOW UP.
FIVE ONE ITEM EIGHT AB SEVENTY
SEVEN MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE CHAIR VOTING RIGHTS
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ARE AB SEVEN EIGHT
SEVEN IS OUT.
FIVE ONE GOING BACK TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MITCHELL.
MITCHELL ACT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY
TEN SEVENTY SIX MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IT IS THREE TO ONE CHAIR VOTING
I'D JACKSON.
MITCHELL MITCHELL I DO YOU
INTEND TO STAFF.
IS THAT WHAT.
ALL RIGHT SIR AB TEN SEVENTY SIX
IS OUT.
FORTY ONE ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE TO ONE TO VOTING I'D
JACKSON HI TECH [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
THIS IS THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
ORDERS PASS AS AMENDED.
IN THE AMENDMENT.
OUR SONG.
WHICH SPECIFIC DATA POINTS
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YEAH -- RIGHT [inaudible]
IT WAS.
THERE WAS NOT A IT WILL
CERTAINLY TRY TO FIND.
SIR AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE IS
OUT.
SIX ONE ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOTION WAS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO ONE
CHAIR VOTING AYE JACKSON HIGH
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FORCE OUT.
FIVE ONE I HAVE SIXTEEN AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE TO ONE CHAIR
VOTING HI.
JACKSON.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL I AB FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
IS OUT.
FOR ONE I DO SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT FOCUS FOR TWO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING HI MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE.
OKAY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR OUT
FIVE ZERO ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE MISSION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE SHARE VOTING AYE
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE AB FIVE FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE
IS OUT.
FIVE ONE ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED MOTION IS TO
PASS OF THE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE
IS ORDER.
ONE VOTING AYE JACKSON JACKSON
AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE.
AB SIXTEEN ONE IS THAT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED IS OUT SIX TO ONE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
MOTION IS TO PASS.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT NUMBER.
SIXTEEN SIX SORRY.
OKAY SIXTY EIGHT MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO JACKSON IS OTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT WE YEAH.
YES THERE WAS AN IMAGE ACT YES.
JACKSON AYE MITCHELL.
YES I WILL READ THE AMENDMENTS
THE AMENDMENTS.
HAS IT ADDS A NEW SECTION THAT
SAYS THE PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
PURSUANT TO THIS CHAPTER SHALL
NOT REPLACE TO RESTRICT EXISTING
OR FUTURE PROGRAMS AND TRAINING.
OFFERED TO FORMALLY INCARCERATED
AND MITCHELL AYE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO I DON'T TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE ACTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS SUPPORT TO CHAIR
VOTING I'D JACKSON HIGH JACKSON
AYE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE IS OUT.
FIVE TO TWENTY TWO A. B. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ABOUT ONLY MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE ZERO JACKSON
HI. EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO JUST HAVE A
FEW I THINK THERE'S JUST A VERY
FEW WITH MS MITCHELL
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
ITEM ONE A. B..
THIRTY TWO ALL RIGHT MITCHELL HI.
BILLS OUT AT.
THIRTY TWO FIVE TWO TWO I AM A
THREE EIGHTY THREE FORTY
MITCHELL KNOWN AND SORRY SORRY
SORRY. FOUR EIGHTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN TO PASS AS A MANAGER OF
PATIENTS MITCHELL.
JULY AB THREE NINE SEVEN IS NOW
OUT.
SEVEN ZERO IF THAT WAS IT.
YEP YEP THAT'S GREAT THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY ALL RIGHT THE THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE IS NOW
ADJOURNED